so you
[Music]
can perfect
perfect yo what's up guys i am dopeziolo
thomas whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast i am here with marty o'neal
what's up folks oh
oh
i'm going all right sorry i was thirsty
oh okay
guys are you ready are you ready it's
another episode but this episode is the
first guest of the year and
fan favorite i'm gonna say it right now
from just
people talking and asking me non-stop we
need him back goblin what's up man it's
good to be here again thank you for
bringing me on my nick
would you ever call by anything else i
mean nick goblin whatever works
i'm not a picky guy i mean you can call
me whatever so the reason i said that
for everyone else that in case you're
new
i told you before we started your
episode is the biggest episode of our
[__] year uh-huh right
and i'm not putting anything down
but tommy chung steve oh and be real
that's putting him combined jesus christ
didn't touch the numbers on your episode
it's insane honestly it's insane
it's awesome i love you guys out there
that's insane that's crazy honestly it
just shows the community you built man
for real yeah for real it's sick and
when ours come together we do some
numbers yeah that's probably what really
what's like
what was it it's like the family guy
crossovers yeah
even even before we did a podcast or
anything i have people come in all the
time ask me if i know you or like stuff
like that so it's like our communities
they feel like already overlapped you
know there's not i feel like there's a
lot of weed
i guess you call them personalities
but none that i feel resonate with me
just because i'm i'll listen to somebody
i'm not like i said i'm not trying to
put people down but listen five minutes
ago that [__] sounded fake as [__] yeah
and by the way you're talking and i feel
like you just started smoking this year
and i can't i just can't watch this yeah
i feel that and i'm not like i said i'm
not trying to say you haven't been
smoking for more than you you're not
cool that's not what it is but yeah you
know you feel like the um yeah and
authenticity like it's not real you
could tell when someone's doing it for
their job versus when they're doing it
because they have been doing it and they
love it you know like because you you
just it's not like you were like i'm
gonna do drugs and then you know
one day i'll make videos yeah i didn't
decide to do drugs for a living you know
like i said i decided to do drugs and
then hey
yeah might as well talk about it a
little bit and here we are you know so
from your last episode
well you came with eric also yep
are you still drug free i am yeah i've
been trying my hardest to stay off that
[__] um i the only drug since last
episode that i think i've still done
that i've now stopped was i wouldn't do
xanax recreationally but i take it
before flights because that's not doing
drugs though yeah i know but i i hear
what you i told myself i was like i
gotta stop doing that too because i'm
still technically doing it you know and
like it's a slippery slope when you take
one before a flight because then what if
i take it before something else when i'm
feeling a little off you know yeah um
you know yourself so i stopped doing
that but now i [__] [__] myself every
plane i'm on dude
i hate i guess i hate yeah i try to it
doesn't work anymore usually i get
shit-faced with the zan and then i'm
like
so barely conscious that i can't think
about the plane you know i just i can't
i just [__] hate it i i hate it too
like [__] we had um so i just flew in
here from vegas we had a 40 45 minute
flight and my legs were tapping the
whole time oh that's me too fantastic
flight but oh my god dude
plane bounces like two inches and i
think we're nose diving okay do you
watch my destination when you're a kid
yes not all of them but i've seen quite
a few so one time real quick uh-huh i am
[__] deathly afraid of planes
one time rosie and i were coming back
from denver okay i can see her face
already yeah she's already laughing
about this you came back from denver one
time
and i was like yeah sick there's only 10
people in the flight [__] yeah [__] yeah
but everybody's in shorts like oh you're
all from california
you don't know better i'm like where's
all the denver people and have you ever
been in a snowstorm in a plate no
actually thank god
so the guy's like we're gonna have a
delay there's gonna de-ice the wings
that scared the [__] out of me first off
de-iced the wings yeah meaning they can
ice [__]
so as we're sitting there the snow just
starts filling our window
on the outside and they have to come
with these big things and knock all the
snow off and then i'm thinking should i
be on this [__] plane
and then as we take off the pilot goes
good news folks we're the last uh we're
the last flight out they just shut down
the airport oh perfect good news for you
is that [__] good news yeah no no
it's not that's i should have stayed
yeah good news we're the last flight out
everybody else is stuck good for you
that's what he was like yeah clap like
no this is [__] [__]
there is an older asian man
as the stewardess and he was real mean
he was real mean yeah i can feel it
so we're going i say that because you'll
see as we're going
i look at rosie
and i'm just floating on my seat
my seat belt's holding me down look at
i'm like
what the [__] and then we go
oh
we dropped hundreds of feet in altitude
and
smacked in turbulence and i was in the
air for a second with my seat belt
holding me down
it was like a dream dude i get so
anxious on fl i couldn't imagine that i
get so anxious i have to put in like
noise canceling your buzzing close my
eyes
oh it gets worse you're telling me
that's not the way that's not the worst
part of that we started shaking
anything i've ever experienced
the pilot started saying put your uh
seat belts on if you're in the bathroom
you can hear it in his voice he's like
sit down yeah and then i'm like okay as
long as the stewardesses aren't freaking
out then i saw the old asian man sprint
for his [__] life to the back and
buckling
and then i just held rosie's hand like
are you [__] kidding me dude
nobody's left tomorrow
and then that happened for an hour and a
half just us just that's brutal and then
we looked out the window and did you
know the plane wings bent like that
really this
they were like that dude oh i just they
were bending like this oh [__] that and
we had the windows uh i'm sweating right
now
thinking about how scary yeah no i i i
see it on you oh it was terrible i was
gonna die for real for i was like yeah
so we're gonna die are you [__]
kidding i was just getting highest yeah
what a [__] way to go out dude so upset
did the plane have wi-fi at least you
could like tell people you were gonna
die i wasn't even looking at my phone oh
i don't blame you i was [__] i don't
blame you losing it dude yeah i don't
[__] blame you i was so so i'm
[__] sweating damn
[__] hold on
i'm just thinking about it all over
again that's scared the [__] you got
ptsd dude you got to talk to someone
like you for real gotta talk to someone
dog just scared the [__] i'm damn
legitimately my whole shirt just got wet
all right i couldn't do that [__] there
we go let me get back on track
[__] i couldn't do that [__] dude i get
mad anxious on the smallest bouncy
flights like even the smoothest flight
of my life i'm still [__] myself
have you been on a small jet
a few times yeah like regional jets and
[__] yeah
they are terrible you get there fast you
do you take pounds if you want yeah
check your bag so the the flight uh
because a lot of times for court when i
have to go up for court when i have my
license suspended i would just fly up to
chicago and then uber to like the time i
have cordon right uh because i live
further south in illinois now and those
little regional jets are [__] dude
there was one time i was on one where
uh not nearly as bad as the one you were
just talking about but terrible for me
because any bounce will make me cry so
like
that it's starting to get real bouncy
and it like it was clear when we took
off but it started like getting really
rainy and really bad as we were going
and it was only like a 25 30 minute
flight it was literally in illinois to
illinois you know but on the flight i'm
sitting there and i'm like i have no one
to talk to so i'm just looking out the
window but the window's scaring me
because it's raining and it's cloudy so
i close that [__] and i'm like yo i
really want to talk to this girl next to
me but i have a girlfriend so like she
might be mad but also like if i'm about
to die i want to like talk
some things in someone before i die you
know so i'm sitting there and i'm like
[__] dude and like i was like so focused
on just like closing my eyes and tapping
my legs that by the time that like
i had thought like i decided like yo i'm
gonna tell like my deepest secret to
this woman before i die the plane was
like coming down like landing and i was
like [__] yeah dude i don't know i don't
have to confide my darkest secrets dude
[__] yeah bro not dying today
that's the [__] the last episode of
seinfeld for that was literally
i love it dude i remember when i was a
kid that was like the only thing my mom
would have on the tv so i grew up yeah i
grew up loving that show i love it it's
so fire did you watch kirby enthusiasm
no actually never seen it
never what kind of enthusiasm is
seinfeld r rated really larry david the
creator of seinfeld that's his show see
i know it's good if you're comparing it
to seinfeld well he's a creator seinfeld
really larry david's creator with jerry
seinfeld he wrote all the episodes
so this is his version of
ah it's seinfeld same exact scenarios
except r-rated just a dull it's [__]
great that's fire it's so tight he's my
favorite person that's fire you gotta
watch it um
i talked about last time but i was on
mushrooms the other day and i kind of
got nervous and i just watched seinfeld
for hours in a blanket and i was fine
dude i told you about how i took that um
that chocolate bar when we were at the
airport yeah no really wait the one we
gave you yeah oh yeah lg gave it to me
last time i was out here oh yeah
oh yeah so so emily and i were at the
airport and we had missed our initial
flights the day after yeah the day after
so we had we had a bunch of time to blow
right we were like [__] we were how long
were we at the airport like a good like
longer it was like three i think yeah so
we were sitting there drinking
and like we ended up splitting up that
chocolate bar and she took like she
didn't take as much as me because she
flew out before me so i had the rest of
it hell yeah um but i had the rest of it
with me can i crack that brewski too go
for it we'll do it together beautiful
yeah that's fine what is this what is
this miller light
my favorite
miller lite ad restart today guys
cheers
perfect that just reminds me of
campfires
what better way to bring this
[__] in than like this for real
when i heard you got a beer sponsorship
i was like dude i'm
[__] yeah i'm an
alcoholic [__] yeah this is a straight
campfire nostalgia so did they just like
send you a bunch of miller light
or like do they like give you some money
and be like go to the store like like
you know what man
i don't know we need to talk about you
guys want a fridge
that would be crazy that would be kind
of tight that would be i know somebody's
got
some of the miller lights got to be
watching this probably right for sure
yeah all right they wanted to make sure
we didn't [__] it up miller like guys
get a fridge and call me
there we go
you know be sick if you could press a
button and one would roll
do you get like a tube coming down like
some
germans like you know you know those
tubes at the bank when like you drive up
exactly yes yes like the [__] like a
miller light comes down dude
that would be sick or a button under
here like a [__] boss yeah like a
seat like a big red like yo don't tell
people what it does though like have a
guest on and be like yo just whatever
you do like press the button when you
feel
ready but like don't [__] tell them
they think it's like some big deal we're
gonna have tyrese on one day it's gonna
be an ejection seat it's like a [__]
beer drops down like oh that'd be sick
just like the bank you're right yeah
yeah do you ever watch the movie blank
check no actually damn it's a disney
movie you ever seen blank check yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think so definitely had
definitely had more than a million
dollars sorry i brought that up but his
slide setup was so bomb when i get older
all right what's this movie about play
check
this kid gets hit by or his bike gets
run over he gets hit by a car and the
guy's like here here's a [__] check
just go get out of my way and the kid's
like a mill
finesse the [__] out of this dude and
gets it
because the banker is a dirty crooked
guy was waiting for a guy to come in he
goes you sent a kid good thinking and he
leaves like that wasn't the kid really
because that kid's got a meal [__] and
he cashes it oddly enough goes on a date
with a grown woman which is really weird
that's what you do she was in the fbi
though
pedophile [__] you got a bill to your
name [__] yeah dude i know but in the
movie he definitely had about six
that shit's not a mill the [__] he
bought
yeah but the reason i say it is when i
get our house one day i want to put in i
saw this thing on tick tock bro the only
reason that tick tock is it's vine dude
i love tick-tock it's just like vine
it's not as good as vine but like it's a
good my algorithm or my page is awesome
i see the craziest [__] this [__]
opened up her refrigerator and it was a
slide that slides down into her game
room and it wasn't even a refrigerator
i need that that's sick sick that's sick
so speaking of the button press that's
what i thought of yeah no that's [__]
dope dude you need something like this
yeah are you planning to get a house
soon yeah yeah we're gonna we're looking
nice
nice just california's expensive yeah
yeah i that's ball all i say is i pray
for you yeah how's the market out here
right now [__]
[__] the house i want to buy here
is times 10 it would be in my hometown
maybe a little more which is [__] up
yeah i mean the market out here is
absolutely insane it's good if you're
trying to sell your house oh yeah yeah
yeah once you buy the house and you're
on the flip side of it one day you'll be
feeling good yeah i'd be sick but
dude a million five house here is like
in the ghetto
yeah
it's crazy
because like all the all the areas where
you could get like a crazy nice house
for a million five have all been yeah
they're all great yeah they're all
jacked up it's all been bought out by
like companies and [__] and upgraded and
all that yeah exactly yeah we went on
straight rand city
chocolate mushroom bar let's go really
what's happening no what happened oh
so never even remember i don't know dude
i yeah dude i was part of the joint
can you get my hat these lights this
beanie doesn't work i'm dying over here
i haven't done it yet and i'm [__]
just
we've not tested these out with a beanie
so um we had some down time and i was
like oh i think i just lost the cherry
what a brutality right there that's okay
right so carson tends to pack them hella
hard at the end i've been trying to tell
her hey it's too much weed i do the same
thing with my joints i do the save the
update
but um
now so we were at the airport we had
some downtime and i got this chocolate
bar through tsa i just took the label
off you know perfect uh yeah i mean
they're not gonna whatever you know
sample it yeah exactly they're not gonna
like take it but you can be like you
know i kind of taste the psilocybin in
this like you're going downtown you know
so we're going downtown [__] um let's
throw it i ate i didn't eat like a ton
of it but
prior
thank you that's a nice toss
thank you
but um
prior to to this day i'd only done
streams once and it was in high school
because you're like acid only yeah i'm
an acid guy so this is my second time
doing shrooms so i only ate probably the
equivalent of like 1.5 or 2 grams it was
still enough to make me feel it you know
because i didn't want to have like a
full on out of my mind trip on a [__]
airplane for my second time but also
like i was so bored i was like dude i
kind of want to see what happens here
you know
so i remember
i took that [__]
and like
i didn't have any really insane visual
effects but i remember when i got on the
plane is when it really started to hit
me and the plane just looked super
[__] long the whole time and like no
matter how many lights were on it felt
like it was dim in there and it was like
really it was really strange i didn't
like i remember my first time doing
shrooms i did a way bigger dose and i
got way more intense visuals where like
[__] was pulsing and like i was walking
by houses and they look like they were
jello cues they were like wiggling and
[__] you know and i was like this is
[__] i didn't have anything that crazy
but like i almost had this like tunnel
vision effect in the plane and like i
just like
weirdly enough it actually calmed me
down like i was like more chill and less
anxious about flying when i was on the
like small dose of shrooms as opposed to
when i'm drunk or like
really anything else besides sands hands
do the trick but that's because there's
ann's you know um
but i i had a really nice time and i
ended up
for most of the flight just [__]
around on my phone playing youtube
videos and [__] because i had um
so
a while ago
i had made the discovery
that there's this app um this app called
like musee or something muesli where you
could download youtube videos like watch
without youtube red you know i probably
shouldn't be saying this as a youtuber
but uh
pardon me i hypothetically downloaded it
um
but i i would download a bunch of [__]
on this app
and like play it on my flight so i was
like on my phone just [__] around
watching like music videos and [__] you
know just anything i could get my hands
on i listened to the same [__] song
like eight times in a row just to watch
the video you know it was an asap rocky
song uh lsd actually i love i love the
video on that yeah it's so dope
sometimes you just gotta listen to music
for the video like videos make that [__]
you know i always say a good song can
have a trash video and then nobody cares
but a okay song have a dope video and
everybody loves it absolutely do you
listen to hip-hop mainly
oh so real quick
that was my next question oh [__] yes
what kind of music you listen to i never
pretty much i never even thought of it
um
almost exclusively hip-hop the only
exceptions are being i like young lean a
lot and i don't consider him necessarily
yeah he does rap but he does like a lot
of different genres i like a lot of
young ladies um stockholm yeah he's from
sweden sweden uh but
i like him a lot uh other than that yeah
pretty much all rap like
i i need to hit this more did you you
guys see that story i'm sorry to go off
talking about this when you said sweden
where the [__] this dude's from
did you guys read that story about the
rapper from like he's like from [__]
belgium or whatever he's a white dude
his girl got his girl caught him
[__] a fan
she killed him and dismembered him with
a hacksaw and fed him to rats what
and allegedly did sexual things to his
dismembered body i was watching this
[__] on world style that could be a
[__] trouble that's a world star ass
moment
holy [__] i'm assuming you guys haven't
heard about this oh i've never heard
about it go ahead world star that one
jesus christ she looked just like
the [__] on the thumbnail just
looking regular as [__]
dismembering this wool
a lot dexter whoa
it fed him to wrestle
and fed him to the some local rats i
don't [__] know first of all she
should have been like he's an artist
it's probably not going to work out
yeah first off just like it's probably
going to happen yeah do you just have
that in you like do you know that that's
in you before you do it you talking
about
banging a fan or killing i'm talking
about killing and dismembering your
[__] yeah
because killing is i feel like killing
and then dismembering are two different
like tears oh you know you've got to be
a psychiatrist
absolutely deranged to dismember someone
after you killed that you know that's
beyond some heat of the moment i didn't
like killing bugs i couldn't shop on the
lagos i know i apologized to a bee this
morning or my little emery was screaming
crying at this [__]
sorry [__]
yeah oh cause you had to kill it yeah uh
i always say sorry i have to kill a
spider too
oh dude i'm terrified of spiders i don't
feel bad i do what i have to do
i [__] i can't do spiders man i i try
to sometimes watch youtube videos like
to rant you listen [__] to like you know
a
yeah
it doesn't fly it doesn't fly i'm still
terrified every time i see one in person
i don't like them like the tiny little
spider could crawl like if a daddy
longlegs
oh don't get that don't you get me
thinking about that
i thought you were talking about oh [__]
i'm sorry i got this on film not that
long ago i was out in the backyard
[__] smoking a little lizard i'm high
as [__] lizard gets caught in a spider
web spider starts inching towards it
about to kill this [__] wizard
i did i threw basketball out how big was
the spider where it could kill lizard it
was like as big as the little baby
lizard oh my god yeah it was horrifying
the spider was [__] pissed oh hell no
[__] that spider i know that's what i
said i made the decision hey [__] that
thing spiders are horrifying spiders are
so terrifying hell no [__] that [__] i
can't do it regular natural animal death
can happen when i'm not looking exactly
i know i had to play god there
that's where we're in foreign [__] too
you know yeah exactly
high up on this [__] totem pole yeah
we decide this [__] we earned this i
want you guys to see something
talk about what music you like somebody
killed somebody in sweden to spiders
what kind of music do you like
we never even talked to it dude that's
how bad all of our brains just went
you know adults
i will say ever since i stopped taking
adderall my brain's [__] pancakes
dude fried when wait when'd you start
taking that roll when i was uh in high
school early high school did you stop um
i took it on and off until about like a
year ago i fully just stopped i didn't
like it i tried it one time i have
really bad adhd and it helped when i was
in school but now that i'm out of school
it doesn't really do [__] for me it just
makes me uncomfortable
but all right rap music oh [__] music
let's go music get this [__] question
answered
yo i already forgot yeah i got to fight
but you're going out i don't know bro i
think it's because i'm talking more than
i'm hitting it i think maybe and i got a
little i just got no i'm gonna i'm gonna
revise my strategy here okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna get it done no i think they're
a little
i don't think it's the pack i don't know
you saw how sticky that [__] was maybe
it's just that it's clogging we're
smoking murder it's
very strong it's ridiculous actually
it's like a piece of art the [__] looks
like it's got diamonds on it no it's
i listen to a lot of rap i like um
i like a lot of little uzi you know
playboy cards i never got into
i i just i've been listening to music
for a while i like it um
future chicago artists like tierrabow i
like kanye
west i like kanye west yeah he's one of
my favorites um but not all of his
projects i like i thought dondo was
actually really good
and i thought college dropout's like one
of the best albums ever college dropout
that's the first mistake yes that's his
first his first like real album yeah
that's one of those
is fantastic i was listening to it
almost died remember
oh the camp almost drove over the cliff
because that's the one where he his
first big song was talking about
crashing and almost dying first time i
ever heard the through the wire song i
was right in front of the merced high
bear painted on the cafeteria with my
headphones and going to pe
and i remember going crash
who is this anthony avila beast
he burned me an eight ball i like um
i like lil wayne a lot
lil wayne is great
yeah um so
i don't listen to mainstream music ever
until a couple years ago i just listened
to lil wayne for the first time last
year really ever what song ever
the whole discography everything wow you
sat down and said well wait 30 years
worth i had to wow yeah that actually it
was it was an eight-hour road trip we
did through almost all of it how'd you
like it [__] amazing i'm tripping no
that wayne is fantastic
lil wayne is fantastic i'm [__] i'm
dumb as [__] i if i if i knew you're on
the radio i'm like nope
nope i was so un like in tune
underground like this i'm garbage it's
garbage it's mainstream garbage lil
wayne really earned his his position and
then i remembered like he's amazing when
i hit like 22 i told rosie 23.
you had to be poppin and dope to be able
to get mainstream so let me listen to
your [__] before yes and i was just
biased i'm a bias i was a hater
[__] yeah and i always admit it
like when it came to music it happens it
happens it happens but this is last year
[__] man
and kanye west i only listened that
first album never listened to him again
until last year and listen to the whole
[__] physiography too [__] i've been
missing out to be fair honestly the only
kanye projects i do listen to are his
first album and donda i really [__] with
that uh pablo life of pablo one life of
pablo has a few good love [__] wait is
that the same one i'm thinking of
the orange one yes that's like i love
that [__]
yeah pretty gospely but dope yeah i [__]
with it yeah i mean he's a gospel guy he
dropped jesus king for [__] sake i
mean yeah
so
so you listen a lot of
chicago artist basically yeah yeah um
nowadays my playlist i feel is a lot
more like i'll listen to whatever comes
on honestly as long as it's rap just
because like i like to hear new stuff do
you listen to old rat
yeah if it comes on i don't have any on
my playlist though mainly new musicians
uh the oldest i'd listen to is like
those old like
2010 2011 air little wayne and drake got
something
uh i will say
oh what what was the drake album there's
one drake album that's good i don't know
one
i i people might get mad at me for
saying that honestly this first one like
one no i think it was because nothing
was the same it was a superstar it was
guessing nothing else it was the one
with the blue cover you know with the
the clouds
yeah that had kkk
kim and jay-z yes yes yes yes yes what
was that album called do you remember
i don't know i'm drawing a blank on it
too but that was a great album yeah i
listened to that still
um how about the fact that lil wayne
first of all was out when he was a
[__] kid
and then
lil wayne was the [__] i listened to in
middle school and then early high school
i started listening to young lean a lot
really um yeah my friend knows young lee
he told us like this kid's gonna be real
pop and it's like no he's he i love his
music honestly my homie jeremy shout out
to jeremy this [__] knows every
artist before they start what do you
call post malone
because he was like awesome he's gonna
be popping soon like all right called
young lean
uh future he said this [__] had
some r b [__] but he's gonna be popping
next to your watch and what happened
drake and future album came out he was
right who else he's called every
[__] i've been in this house so
he'll be popping real hard next year and
they're all superstars that's crazy it's
it's insane when you when you see people
because i always tell you like i call
[__]
jeremy calls [__] big time
whatever happened sorry we're getting
off topic but he's an album and
everything too what happened man imagine
being lil wayne and putting on drake and
nicki minaj
yeah that's dope that's dope as [__] eat
off that the restaurant he's a true hall
of famer jesus christ yeah he really is
um
okay all right what about you like what
are your what are some of your favorites
i listen to oh rappers rabbit yeah let's
start with let's do it god i know marty
was like i'm surprising one of my
favorite rappers right now i just love
this guy so [__] much
i just love kodak black so much codex he
is so [__] hilarious to me but like
in a dope way i'm like you are so
[__] interesting to me
it's like you rhyme some of the dumbest
[__] but it sounds dope yeah i feel that
it's good it's like this
it's like when somebody knows they're
saying something ridiculous and they go
you like it though right i do all right
and then shut the [__] up all right [__]
go night blood he does say some funny
ass there's some funny [__] and he's
also just like he's just a funny
[__] in general like he knows it
like he's exactly so funny he knows he's
kind of funny
to it yes i don't know bro and orange
the whole orange thing it's like i don't
know when he came out the first thing i
ever saw world star post
this kid with dookie braids and orange
jeans dancing on a car and then a kodak
black the next rapper coming up oh who
the [__] is that his pants are sick
and ever since then i've been following
quite a flash career bro i love that guy
so much that's a good pick honestly
that's a really good picture yeah but
for music lately
i don't know i'd have to go through my
phone i've been listening to you ever
heard of valley v-a-l-e-e i think he's
from
i think i've heard that he signed a good
music comment i might have heard the
name i don't know if i've ever heard any
music
i've been listening to his [__] a lot
lately honestly dude you guys should put
out playlists it would take forever like
a dozen at a time it would take so long
give the people what you're listening to
dude for some reason i feel like i'm
drawing a blank i have to pick up my
phone and look who the [__] i've been
listening to lately
i mean [__] you want to really i mean
the first thing on here is 3 30 in
houston let's go yeah you [__] with the
betty the butcher
grisel's good he's good yeah
i don't know
him on my playlist but yeah he's good
all the god it just
it literally says system of a down 50
cent immortal technique griselda freddie
gibbs t grizzly maxwell cream emotional
zan
all over the place young doll that's
like young dolph is fire yeah young
dolphins stupid fire
yeah for real
horrible r.i.p to that guy i i'd listen
to a fair bit of him too
[Music]
um
when young dog came out
and he was rapping about getting p's
from l.a i remember i was i won't say he
was with a certain friend
and the fool stood up jumping like
that's me
like what do you mean he played it back
and he said i go
that is you [__]
and then after he's just after the next
lyric was all priced too high i went
[Laughter]
[__] that is you because my friend
taxes but he sells big boxes and tons
he goes i know that i was like i know
you chill with him like he just shouted
you out the song
without saying your name but kana said
hey by the way cut me some slack
yo i thought it was
did he ever cut him some slack uh no he
stopped selling too much he probably got
another kinetic man
fools buy a lot of weed um
so yeah i don't know uh yeah that's my
that's one of my questions i never asked
what kind of music you list do you
listen to any oldies or anything um not
really much no
honestly
yeah i mean mainly like i said the
oldest i'll really bump is like some
2010 2011 lil wayne [__]
damn yeah see
go back to 0405. he was down there the
best rapper alive for a stretch there
forever i will say i have not listened
to this whole discography the carters go
back to the carter one that [__] is
legendary i haven't i haven't bought
much of that
i need two i'm tight i need to that's
where rosie started me off when we were
like let me listen
um
okay okay real quick last time you were
here you talked about miami debauchery
trip
how'd that go i've been to miami quite a
few times since then yeah how did it go
all this it was always fun down there i
mean i don't do drugs anymore like that
well when you left you still did drugs
yes so how was that
you know bringing bringing blow through
tsa is always stressful i'll say that
probably not the best idea you were
[__] fired up you're like i got my
[__] hawaiians ready dude hello i
still wear those [__] i'm in the
right place i have quite a few in my
hotel room right now
fantastic i love him but um
no it's always a fun time going down
there i mean i go to a fair bit of bars
you know we go to restaurants the the
thing about miami is it's a place where
you can just go do casual [__] but it's
always nice you know
like the vibe down there is just dope
there's always a bunch of [__] you can
everybody's wearing everyone's chilling
the weather is [__] crazy like it's
december and it's still like 70 degrees
you know
it's it's nice out there
so i go down there i will say i haven't
done a ton of crazy [__] down there uh
i've kind of chilled out since then and
since the last time i think even the
last time we filmed i was pretty close
to being done with doing most drugs like
i didn't really do blow like that
anymore at that point the only thing i
did was a few zans here and there yeah
your slight smile as you say i mean i
don't like pills bro yeah i'm glad i'm
glad i feel you i feel you like them
never get they're not they're not worth
doing like they're really not you can
just smoke some weed i just don't want
to feel like
yeah no zan's making your [__] brain
dead like
they just they turn your brain into
oatmeal in my opinion i mean i've seen
some people stupid off the streets off
the oxis and [__] and that's
that's the saddest [__] when you know
your friends normally yeah and then when
they're on pills you're like yo this is
horrible bro we can't do this you're
gonna die yeah looking at somebody on
pills is like
like you said oatmeal it's like mush
yeah yeah they're brain dead zombies
they're
yeah i only did oxygen i was never big
into opiates i've done oxies i've done
perks all that [__] narcos but
it's just none of that shit's very fun
to me like i never got super into it
like that
since you're you're in the general he's
in a whole other generation than us
because you're nine years younger than
me oh happy birthday by the way happy
happy birthday thank you his birthday
this past two days uh yeah january 2nd
yeah happy birthday man thank you well
late birthday but
you have a different generation so
you're
you've seen a lot a lot like you just
said i don't really go past 2010 yeah
that's what you're bringing up with
[__] because that's that's your
music exactly
how do you feel about the opiates just
being cool and rap down it's so
prevalent it's kind of [__] opiates
are [__] but i get that these people
do it because they have money and [__]
you know
like i get it like rappers promote the
drugs they do because
they got money to do drugs like that
when you have money
it's a lot easier to maintain a drug
addiction you know
it's a lot easier and a lot of these
people come from areas where like
everyone's doing drugs you know like if
you're on the streets like you do drugs
like if you hang out with the right
people or i guess the wrong people you
do drugs you know it's epidemic yeah you
don't even have to be on the streets or
anything if you just hang out with
certain people you do [__] drugs you
know um if i see a rapper not with pills
but i think it's weird i think people
hearing it in rap does like glorify it a
lot you know more than anything else
and i feel like it is [__] that that a
lot of rappers just non-stop talk about
that [__] you know um
personally
i don't know if like it's something that
can really be stopped or anything though
you know
like you can't just be like yo it's not
[__] cool anymore i don't see rappers
ever shutting up about that [__]
it's like popular
people don't really care about
the lyrics they care more about the beat
and the rhythm of the song nowadays i
feel like of course and you could say
whatever damn near whatever the [__] you
want
and obviously
you know you got a bunch of people who
are drug addicts who are like also
rappers nowadays what are they going to
rap about doing a bunch of [__] drugs
you know
what we tell stories about yeah yeah
it's kind of like all they know yeah
exactly
i get it it's just
it's so like i said it's so odd when i
see a rapper and they don't have like
leaning pills it's like
what kind of rapper are you yeah
really an actual artist yeah i didn't
know that and that [__] was not
prevalent for you no that was like the
dif to me that's kind of like the one of
the defining things about the different
like generations of hip-hop was when the
lean and all that [__] because you
wasn't there was nothing like that it
wasn't cool to do drugs yeah we looked
at you crazy if you were doing [__]
drugs really yeah yeah big time how are
you going to [__] get into the studio
and not get shot that's why
[__] get shot so fast now and
get murk because like yo you're on drugs
you didn't see the comments yeah for
real
off points no i i believe that for sure
all these people are so high like
everybody's [__] not off weed they're
just yeah bills and lean of course no i
feel that for sure i agree with them or
get robbed
or [__] post stacks on instagram to
look cool and they get robbed to be fair
though also i feel like rappers in
general just get like
it's always something where like they
get killed because of their status in
like the streets or something like that
um
and a lot of those rappers don't stop
like living that kind of life yeah you
know even while they're rapping even
while they're doing [__] like they're
still involved in all that [__] for sure
you know but that's the difference
between some gang man or drug dealer
that happens yeah good lyricist and then
a lyricist rapping about gang bangers
yes yes you know yes because those those
are real and it's not like i'm not gonna
just stop being me because i can't deal
it's true bro it's funny no for real sad
that's like you got an opportunity to
just
break off with those people man
but it never happens and people get
killed as sad as [__]
more and more lately i feel like i've
seen like it's so much
absolutely even big stars it's like yo
these are major dudes so many artists
have died in the past like few months
it's been crazy weird man it's been
crazy
it's so [__] up it's like the next day
oh next day next year yeah it's insane
well i've been seeing so many videos
like the video you showed like oh my god
fool's getting shot it's so sad because
there's a camera everywhere yeah so
people don't realize nowadays there's
footage of everything everything
everything yo someone's gonna see their
kid get killed on camera you can get on
twitter and click the hashtag and you'll
find that [__] instead ten minutes yeah
ten minutes probably a stretch honestly
it's so sad yeah
it's dangerous to be a [__] rapper
absolutely absolutely city to city if
you're out there like man if you're not
moving like a commercial production
or just be a normal guy you don't have
to be a rapper
you could just be a rapper you could be
a j cole like you know about life
yeah for sure
i'm pretty sure jacob's like impressed
yeah no j cole
yeah he's moving with like a
professional team i'm saying i don't
think he's that style of rapper energy
yeah cause you're not provoking that
chicken that's fair exactly fair share
don't post guns and money unless you're
not ready to get killed for it yeah
absolutely scary as [__] it's sad though
absolutely
almost every rapper i just named
talks about guns and drugs
90 of rappers nowadays do it you know i
mean that's fine that's fine whatever
but you know it's kind of crazy because
a rapper can have pounds and pills and
lean in their video with millions of
views never get in trouble
because they're rapping yeah you need to
do you start lip syncing over some songs
while you're doing a review like no it's
a rap song seriously just put official
music video by every title every video
and let's see what that one can start
killing [__] everybody else i
mean they just get demonetized today so
they don't get right they get paid they
yeah they still put ads on my [__] i
just don't get it no no i'm talking
about the rappers with all the questions
you mean you think so right
i don't know i feel like the the label
probably would get that
but i mean saying youtube's still okay
with it oh
oh yeah in that sense yeah of course
youtube's still going to run ads i
always get ads on rap videos [__] i
use well no i shouldn't say that
youtube's page
yeah we'll keep it at that yeah you
shouldn't say that no yeah i love
watching we pay youtube random youtube
premium everywhere youtube red
man even after the 15 a month it's petty
what did i do
dude your channel is pretty clean
exactly and they still get you yeah
crazy it's pretty [__] up um
what time are we at
40. oh not bad cool i got a question for
you all right earlier guys i asked uh
goblin to give me some titles i wanted
to throw some stories out
i want you to throw some stories out
and i didn't want to give it away so
let me just
i'll say something and then you tell the
story okay all right all right all right
let's do that with that let's do that
let's do that let's do that let's
arrange that are you ready
i'm down yeah what are you gonna throw
out first
i think i'm gonna go
revenge
oh wow you picked you picked a fiery one
out the gate you picked veg okay all
right so
to preface this this is one that a lot
of my viewers
have been asking me to tell for a while
because i've gotten drunk a few times on
streams and like alluded to it so it's
something that my viewers are aware of
but i had a friend when i was younger in
high school who sold a fair bit of drugs
his name was ashton he actually
overdosed he passed away a while ago um
but when i still knew him and he lived
in the area
i would hang out with him quite a lot
and we were at a party together at one
point
and he said it was literally just us and
like a few other people there and he was
like it wasn't a party yet and he was
like oh i have a serve coming through
we thought it was like three or four
people and i [__] you not three cars
pulled up there was like 20 people they
apparently buy something they apparently
all left the party and came through here
thinking this was like a new party and
like he let them into the house mind you
this isn't our house like we went over
to some girl that like we knew she
invited us over because she wanted to
buy some [__] from him so we're at her
house and all of a sudden like 20
[__] people show up so she's really
mad and like yelling at people trying to
throw everyone out
and they convinced my friend ashton to
go into the bathroom to serve them and
i'm like dude that's sketchy like why
would you not just serve them out here
so he goes in the bathroom with these
two dudes and they close the door
and like all of a sudden it gets real
loud in there and they like from what he
told me apparently they like pulled a
gun out like pistol whipped him and like
took his [__] like they just kind of
jumped him in there
but they locked the bathroom door so we
were trying to get it open but we
couldn't get it open because they were
like body blocking it and [__] you know
so finally they open the door and like
dip out and obviously none of us have
guns or anything they have a gun so
we're like you know
we like follow him out but i'm like dude
i'm not gonna go fist fight the guy with
a gun
all right this is bad news but like okay
so they get in their car i i instead go
over to like ash and i'm a kid like what
the [__] happened um and he kind of says
he's like dude they [__] robbed me
but we knew who the kids were it's not
like these were strangers like what were
they buying so
i believe they just wanted to buy zans
but he had ketamine and xans and he had
like i think it was acid he had some
other [__] not weed i don't remember
yeah i don't remember he was on
probation so he couldn't smoke weed
um he just sold much yeah so he just saw
that did everything else
so um
he uh he told me he's like yeah they
took everything i'm like what the [__]
like what did you have and he told me he
had like 40 zans 2 grams of ketamine
which is a lot of [__] k um
i don't know he had something else i
don't remember exactly what it was but
we knew who the people were
so you knew them yeah like we knew these
kids they went to like our school and
[__] you guys were in high school at
this time yeah we were in high school we
were all high schoolers so
the girl obviously she's like screaming
and [__] she's like get the [__] out of
my house she's like freaking out so we
all leave and we're like i tell her i'm
like yo
we are so sorry you know like well i did
not expect someone to get
you know robbed at gunpoint in your
bathroom you know
we just came here to smoke weed like you
know i i brought some weed and
luckily they didn't steal that so
they [__] take ash and [__] and leave
but we knew who they were so ashton's
like yo we gotta get them back and i'm
like
okay yeah are you wild as [__] yeah he
uh so he was on probation because he
stole a car i guess
but he did it when he was like he told
me he was like 14 or 15 or some [__]
like freshman year in high school so he
was on probation for a long ass time and
he just didn't give a [__] he was wild
he was crazy um
but that's kind of why him and i got
along because i was also pretty reckless
in high school and i was like down to do
dumb [__] as well
so is your age yeah yeah so we became
friends pretty quickly but um
either way we had hit up a few of my
friends
i'm not gonna name them all on
everything but we hit up a few of my
friends um
and asked them to come help us like we
were like yo we know where this kid
lives like the one who had the gun we
knew where he lived so we were like yo
let's just go like
[__] some [__] up at his crib or
something you know and obviously he
lives at home so yeah yeah he lives with
his mom and we found out the car he was
driving it was kind of [__] we didn't
know this before or like while we did it
but we found that after well all right
we'll get to this but either way we hit
up a few friends we go pick them up we
don't have like access to a gun or
anything so we're like oh [__] man like
what do we do so we got like a two by
four like a hatchet from walmart you
know like a hammer just went and bought
[__] yeah yeah you're like [__] bro
we're committing [__] tonight you know
yeah seriously yeah no we were really
serious about it um
and we were like [__] man we also got
some [__] like from a garage you know
like we obviously we had some stuff
we had like like hats that we like made
into masks you know like we cut little
like holes in them and then like pulling
down [__] but um
we drove over to like near his crib and
his car was out there and one of our
friends in the car was like yo if you
slash three tires insurance won't cover
it like you have to cut four apparently
i don't know if that's true or not but
that's what he said and we're like okay
so we got out of the car and we like
started cutting his tires and smashing
the windows and [__] and the car alarm
somehow didn't go off
and
sorry we just thought this was like his
car because he was always driving it we
later we felt really bad about it and i
still do because he found out it was his
mom's car not his and i was like oh
that's shitty like i didn't i didn't
really mean to mess with his mom you
know like i just kind of wanted to
[__] him over so i felt really bad about
that part but then we like threw
something i think it was like i don't
remember what the [__] we threw probably
shouldn't say it either um at his like
window of like his living room and then
we just dipped we like jump back in the
car but
we found out that like because of that i
guess his mom like kicked him out of the
house and he was like homeless you're
like [__] good damn perfect even better
than ruining somebody yeah we felt a lot
better about that but then no the one of
the kids who was involved in it uh
i like wasn't there for this but i guess
um
he like
caught like my friend in the bathroom
and like beat his ass or some [__]
because of that it was very bad after
they robbed them yeah
yeah after that i'm like dude why at
that point you already got some [__]
[__] like why you know
like why continue you know yeah it
wasn't even the guy who's like house we
messed with you know so what the [__]
was wrong with that but one of our
friends ended up like cutting himself
on one of the windows and we thought he
like left blood there so we were
freaking the [__] out we were like oh my
god and we couldn't calm him down he was
like dude we're fault he was like i'm
going to jail and i'm like well we're
not if you shut up you know like
you better chill out so we just kept
giving him like ketamine to calm down
because we're like we can't we were like
we can't take you to the hospital bro
like he was like i think i might need to
go to the hospital there's a big cup
like you can't go right now bro we're
[__] you know like you can't go so we
just gave him a shitload of k until he
like quieted down bad was a cut not that
bad but he was he was tweaking he was
fine he was fine did he want the k or
you administered this [__] to him i
didn't have any part in it that's all
i'm going to say
that's all i'm going to say but he took
some time
he did actually at first he wanted it
and he got it first
but after we held him down
i understand all i'm gonna say is i had
no part in that [__] it just happened in
my vicinity
and i had nothing to do with it this
whole situation is [__] hypothetical
story you made up yeah absolutely this
whole situation was like a what-if
moment
what if what if it did that this is like
yeah what if this happened this is like
what i'm you know
but yeah
uh we kind of chilled out smoked some
wheat after that and then dropped
everyone off and went home and did the
guy go homeless you guys ever see him
again no we so
he like was supposed to go to the same
school as us but he just never went to
school he's like one of those kids you
know he's just like [__] it kind of like
dropped out on his own i guess just
stopped attending um
so like we never really saw him after
that
well no matter what he he robbed
somebody he's in the room i mean to be
fair it's not like we tried to ever see
him again you know we were like all
right let's just not kick it with anyone
that knows him or anything and that's
just kind of how it went
you know
how shitty though yeah it was a [__]
like i don't understand why you would do
that [__] why do you bring 20 people for
it
wait they were all in on it yeah no not
all of them were in on it but they were
all there bro and i'm like why don't you
maybe did it so it's a distraction maybe
like kind of a smart way to write and
just i mean you come up in there with
all those people it's like intimidating
if it doesn't i guess yeah sitting in
there you just strong arm some [__] and
leave but it's like if they know where
you live what the [__] are you gonna
expect exactly exactly like how stupid
can you be you think we're just gonna be
like oh
thanks
[Laughter]
i mean i don't [__] know man that was
a terrible time but i'll strung out and
show um yeah you know last i heard um
he's still not doing too great he's
still not doing too great i don't the
other guy uh the one who who beat up my
friend of the bathroom he went to jail
for like burglary or some [__] sounds
about right yeah that was great news we
actually celebrated that good yeah we
actually we actually were super happy to
hear that we were like wow this is
best news of the year so far honestly
[__] high schoolers with a gun
fools are wild man yeah fools are
tripping trying to grow up fast as [__]
i feel that
there's a lot of kids who are like that
i mean i feel like most most people are
like that in some way though
yeah i never not to that something
it makes you do stupid [__] yeah
yeah illogical
for sure for sure so that was the
revenge story yeah that was quite the uh
quite the occurrence
i'm always going to take away you went
to walmart to buy a hatchet
that's cool in my mind you threw a
flaming bag of dog [__] out of his
window too just so you know we were
frustrated it was it was something i
just don't want to necessarily say it on
the podcast
we threw a dildo through his window
i used a dildo
i feel like
after we get off i hope it's not like we
we killed his dog
no
in the making of this theoretical yeah
all right
okay okay
uh
we told this story a while back but uh
one of my friends i don't know if i told
you
i told the story i'll tell it quick
because you probably haven't heard it
okay one of my friends got his car
broken into
and somebody stole just a bunch of stuff
from his car and a box but they were
going through the whole parking lot
busting windows taking whatever they
could oh
my homie had packs in there and hella
edibles oh and they got it they got it
wow two dudes were sitting there smoking
weed downstairs oh no the two dudes in a
building they were looking down we're
like yo what the [__] is all these fools
breaking windows and they were in a car
so like three dudes pop out
get in the car and dip
so they ran downstairs on the little
scooters and called the cops
and chased these fools through downtown
and how hard it is to get through
downtown yeah
sidewalk if you don't want to wait
and they were on scooters gave the cop
his description pulled him over so my
friend doesn't know that he's just
sitting there like yo my car my packs
[__]
then he runs into these dudes going back
into the building and they're like yo is
that your car because my friend's making
a report yeah and like yo we chased him
they're getting arrested blah blah blah
my friend saw [__] i can't go over there
like that's my books
two days later they call like yo
these guys we arrested said that you
know they stole something from your car
we look inside it's marijuana a lot of
illegal edibles
not my box
it's like we didn't think so thank you
and hung up those fools stole a felony
that's so how i bet they got hella time
too probably for all the [__] how much
how much are we talking like eight
pounds and like i don't know like
but that's not a huge deal here in
california so bad
oh
yeah a hell of a hundreds of edibles oh
it's got a huge steal here eight pounds
but really on top of burglary
yes
how many cars don't make every charge a
big deal you've got that yeah what would
just eight pounds be out here
mike my uncle got caught with 10 pounds
here in l.a got a [__]
ticket
are you serious
you go to jail in illinois for like
a while you don't go to jail no more
yeah you go to jail in illinois for that
he just got a lawyer
maybe everything
fat probation you wouldn't get no ticket
though that's crazy no that's nothing
over here wow depending depending on
what county because some counties are
like nope where's 2006 you're going to
jail yeah that's if you're out if you're
really anywhere outside of like the
northern like really busy counties of
illinois nothing's getting dropped bro
they're not they're not going to play my
board so the reason i'm losing my
license actually i was telling you about
that earlier is because the place i got
pulled over i was on the highway and
it's in like a really bum [__] nowhere
area of illinois where they have nothing
better to do exactly they're bored as
well yes so i'm getting [__] on that
[__] i'm gonna get
i think it's like another 150 hours of
community service god damn yeah i
already have 250 to do
yeah so i'm going to have 400 total yeah
you should vlog that [__] the whole time
a chess kick
400 hours of communities [__] service
that's a lot man that's so much
that's so much and how much time do you
have to do it the 250 i have
like the end of the year
jesus that's a [__] job
it's a joke yeah i got to work about 25
hours a month
that's not too crazy that's not terrible
but
at the same time that's like something i
got to go every week and do because i
can't get a eight-hour shift of
volunteering oh you can't i mean i don't
know where to go for that [__] gotcha
the thing is i've been really busy
lately i haven't really been
volunteering but now
what i think is ridiculous about it is
i'm about to lose my license so how the
hell am i supposed to get there there
how can you assign the hours and then
say oh by the way you can't drive give
you a pass it's a work pass and like
grocery store [__] yeah but do you know
how long it takes to get that in
illinois
a long time
a long time dude i applied to get a foid
card over a year ago and i still haven't
heard back what does that mean uh it's
like a gun license like a firearm
owner's identification so you have to
get that and then a concealed carry in
illinois too oh you can get them like
that out there if you get both of those
things yes
but i don't if i'm correct i don't think
a floyd comes with a concealed carry i
think you have to get that separately
it's like you can have a gun but you
have to have it like your house you know
[__] you can't like walk around with
that [__] yo yo chill out let me go my
house i'll be right back yeah yeah but i
wanted to get something i was like you
know i want i don't mind that because i
just want to have something to have at
my house you know like if someone breaks
in my house i want to have a gun you
know what i'm saying it's really the
only reason yeah exactly i still haven't
heard [__]
it's been like a year probably so slow
with it yeah
everything that involves the state yeah
yeah that could be that could be i hope
not
problem state department needs to leave
me alone we couldn't get up a warehouse
for to save our lives as soon as i took
my name i'll put marty's we got the
first one really
all cause i like your channel
we assume you think they googled you
probably yeah there's under push trees
you know
i don't think if you google my name my
channel comes out
no no no so i think
i'm just it's long no i know but i'm
saying i think as long as like if i'm in
that kind of scenario at some point like
when i move out of the place i'm in now
um
hopefully i'll be honest oh there's
charges you're catching they're looking
at your [__] [__] yeah hey
yeah hey
[Laughter]
none of my charges are violent yeah
that's true that's true so i mean i'm
not a violent criminal
i'm just not even a criminal you just do
drugs yeah i'm just a drug drug druggie
this is not a crime i did when i was
young get a um
burglary charge they got exposed i i
went into garages with my friends
and we like to tweak it no we were
actually pretty much sober uh but we i
just got in a car and we were driving
around and saw these open garages and we
were just like yo delinquents
that sounds fire
so we we pulled up to a few houses and
just like hit the garages um
but we got pretty much nothing good
except we got a really nice set of golf
clubs out of one that was worth like we
looked it up i don't know if we maybe
looked up the wrong thing but from what
we looked up based on what we got that
set was worth like well over a grand and
we were like damn
at the time that's a shitload of money
to us we were like dude that's gonna
last us a year
like that's so much [__] money we
could buy a pound like you're like
that's it you know this is like a badass
kid this is our ticket so
we ended up getting caught
with the clubs in the car
so not that night it's actually really
[__] that we got caught
so we pulled up to this house and we
didn't see this guy standing in his
garage in the corner and it was open and
my friends got out of the car and i was
the driver and they went in the garage
and the guy was there so he walked up he
was like hey what are you doing and they
were like oh we're at the wrong house
you know so they come back out to the
car and the guy i guess thought it was
suspicious enough to call the cops and
report it
so they had like a record of someone
reporting our license plate and [__]
that night so when people started
realizing their [__] went missing out of
their garages they obviously called the
police and they put two and two together
so small town
not that small of a town though
population like hundred thousand hundred
times oh it's not that small no not
small at all actually pretty big
pretty big
but they did some real police work yeah
this is some goddamn police work but
um
we we hit like four garages about so
enough to be a problem we took like a
leaf blower for some reason i don't know
why the [__] we did that so you could
pawn it yeah yeah we were like [__] it
the opponent and we also took for some
reason one of my friends took this like
kid's backpack and i was like bro put
that [__] back so like we drove back by
it on the driveway oh like turn around
straight pieces yeah
come on bro throw that [__] like give
that [__] back
we drove back and threw that on the
driveway and then left also why is the
backpack in the garage yeah it was just
full of water bottles we were like bro
it's got dora on it you know like leave
it oh i don't know man it might be some
kids like who knows maybe they're like
some [__] kids maybe the kid's
thirsty i don't [__] maybe this gets
thirsty it's the [__] from the signs
i don't know man
yo
so you weren't that bad you threw you
threw it back i was trying to be a
decent person i just did some bad things
did we talk was it before the show
we were talking about stealing [__] yeah
i've never stolen anything yeah that's
crazy to me because i used to steal a
lot i never stole [__] i um my first
like serious crime but i guess i got
caught for besides well no okay the
burglary is definitely fair
but i guess the the first serious
punishment i had to deal with was when i
got caught stealing from walmart
because i had
more than like 20 games though yeah
games
so i would sell them at gamestop when
i'd steal them but what i do you got 12
bucks
no i used to get a couple hundred at a
time here's how i do it just listen to
this so i get a tote one of those you
know those plastic storage totes you can
get so i get one of those take the lid
off put it in my cart and i go to the
discount games bin and just take like 20
or 30 games and throw them in the bin
then i put the lid of the bin on and
scan the bin and pay for it and just
leave
and it worked like three or four times i
[__] i couldn't believe it it kept
working and back in high school i don't
know why but i just had maybe it's
because i did so many drugs when i was
younger i just had no sense of like fear
doing this like sometimes i get nervous
but i just i just [__] do it did your
mom ever punch you in the face
no but she's she has smacked me before
she was she would she beat the [__] out
of you not like super aggressively but
you know like a that's probably why it's
probably why he had no fear
yeah because you're like okay
my parents
do that brother that's a weird concept
to understand
right yeah everyone punched me so hard
in the face if i got caught that's
probably why they were stolen really
yeah i i just [__] did it you know
that's like i mean the concept you have
is genius but i made like 150 200 bucks
every time there's enough for me to buy
a bunch of weeds you go to gamestop and
just cash them in go to gamestop i go to
a few different stores to sell because i
couldn't go sell five copies of lego
batman at gamestop and have any sort of
logical explanation
as to why i could do maybe two would be
like yeah one for me one for my little
brother you know like we played together
but i couldn't [__] sell five copies
of that [__]
yeah you know it was discount games bro
i had to take what i could get you know
but gamestop so trash was giving you
money but i had like 30 games so it
added uh john just do that you take all
his old games but let's get somewhere i
could get six bucks a game and still
make like damn near 200 bucks six bucks
yeah oh california gamestops are playing
[__] out here really what the
[__] king kong you know the king kong
game came out like 15 [__] years ago
for playstation 2. oh it came out the
next week we took it to gamestop the guy
gave us fourteen dollars no eleven
dollars and i looked at john this is
some [__] [__] dude 11 cents one
time they gave us for our star wars game
i brought up i bought an xbox 360 there
one time and they gave me 50 bucks
is that good terrible that sounds like
what you would get in yourself xbox 360
is a whole console yeah
yo mercedes i still got that shot okay
yeah fantastic
game stops where i'm from they would
just play well at least back then
all game stops are [__] though to be
fair you know
like somebody needs to make a cooler
game stop and they'll put games up out
of [__] business yeah but i mean
physical stores are dying nowadays oh
for sure
everyone buys digital on games now you
know but here in l.a
l.a would it would always take off it
could thrive yeah la's just the spot for
tangible [__] creative [__] is xbox
still around or is it really just the
ps5 and the pc like well people play
xbox still yeah uh they just dropped the
series s and the series x the new ones
i've never even heard of that they're
they're brand new they came out recently
they're still super hard to get you
can't find it at stores yet like does it
rival the ps5 or like
i'd say so but i prefer the ps5 it's
like apple and windows basically right
so i was thinking about this kind of
yeah you could make that comparison i
mean the xbox i feel like is more of a
media machine like if you want to watch
videos or stream stuff you buy an xbox
if you want a game i feel like you're
probably gonna buy a playstation got you
you know but people that really game go
on a pc yeah yeah never mind crazy dude
yeah not not max max you're not built
for gaming so weird
yeah little brother has the valve index
thing oh that's i was just talking to
attila about that thing oh it's the vr
[__] yeah the vr headset but it can
detect where your fingers are my brother
has a this he's a [__] gamer and my
little brother has the craziest setup in
his room all this crazy liquids going
through his computers oh yeah
and then the the vr tubes from the top
but he modded he's like coding [__] he's
spiderman swinging from webb stabbing
[__] in the neck
in this warehouse he made up
it's [__] crazy that's so sick but i
get sick off here i can only do like ten
years yeah i know i can do like
spiderman so i used to have a vr headset
when i was younger i had one like a
couple years ago um but i got rid of it
because i
a i couldn't play it for that long at a
time and b like i didn't like many of
the games that were out back then
there's some dope new ones out now
though uh i don't know what games there
are do you ever trip on acid and go on
no i've never been too much i've never
done vr on acid i think that'd be fun i
could see it being pretty dope but i
feel like i'd get overwhelmed really
that's what it is like i get a sensory
overload first you know you'd have to
fall you have to take a small dose you
have to take like half a tab to enjoy
that like a lighter dose to like
kind of not you know lose your [__]
mind in there you know it's realistic
yeah i the guy talks to you what's up
man
you press the button and the guy spawns
up out of the ground dude the valve
index it's so sweet detects where your
fingers are yeah you could do this yeah
spider-man flip people off you can give
them a thumbs up it's crazy you can slap
them punch them like get real close you
can see in someone's mouth you can see
their teeth you can stick your finger in
their mouth dude i held this guy's
[__] head i told you i think i held
this guy's head and he said what's up
man
and i just shoved my knife so slow
through his neck through his whole mouth
and you can see oh oh
dude
inside of his mouth and i went i don't
know if i could do this anymore
it's kind of [__] up she's like what
do you do i thought you were
no i was spiderman vr is brutal dude
vr is brutal that's brutal bro we are
serious it was bad i was i was doing
something i was doing prison [__] i was
like what's up man what the [__] yeah
you're straight up you're actually
killing people dude like it feels real i
don't know yeah it makes me feel like
that's the valve index is brand new too
that thing's new is that all you do in
that world is just walk around murky
[__] my brother has some crazy
dope [__] but there's a warehouse it's
like the the loading where you just
how to practice on guns how to swing
dude i'm sitting here in my brother's
room doing
fake spider-man [__] dropping grabbing a
gun what's up man
and the thing is it's so realistic it
makes me feel bad yeah i feel that it
does i stab the man in the neck what's
up man
you probably had a bad dream about that
at some point i told rosie that this
morning really i had a dream last night
that i was trying to help my uncle hide
a body oh and then we lost the phone in
the mud i went but that's on our
property they're gonna [__] find the
phone cool and i was digging through the
mud and i woke up like
i i have dreams that i actually kill
somebody all the time oh that's my
biggest fear that's [__] i hate it
like hurt somebody by accident oh god
the hell coming back from that no
there's nothing
you can do to fix it do you dream a lot
though like do you dream often because i
don't know all day really every night
really until i met rosie used to have a
what they call lucid dreams you can do
whatever you want really and then the
second i started dating rosie went away
how did you like lucid dreaming
do i like loose and dream
so i'd be a kid and i'd be like alright
where are we gonna go
all right come on as soon as i fall
asleep bam and i'd be there that's so
dope it'd be so [__] fun but i know
that i was dreaming and i used to do
this thing where i just grabbed the
ground and started launching remember
the first hulk the movie yes in the
grand canyon forever yes that's what i
would do through the cities and just
grab the ground and throw myself oh it
was so [__] that's so cool being able
to run and fly
was so funny i was never able to lose a
dream like that and i feel like the more
drugs i did the less i dreamed
yep interesting yep 100 in high school
it started not being as cool anymore
like i couldn't do it as strong when i
started doing it yeah when i i started
just like not remembering anything from
sleep by the time i wake up and not
dreaming i can remember my dreams like
more drugs it i can't i usually lose
them within like 10 minutes being up oh
i got the whole my whole dream last
night word for step by step i hate
really
that's crazy do i have the alien
invasion one the same one all the time
that [__] sucks
that [__] sucks i see
i the only recurring dream i can ever
remember having is when i was a kid i
used to dream that i was like trapped in
a castle
and i would run like infinitely and i
could never get out but that was the
only recurring dream i ever remember
having did you ever watch goosebumps as
a kid no actually well i was saying i
read the books night in tara tower i
read the books but i said night and
terror tower they can't [__] leave
dude they're stuck in the castle i
remember i would i would be in that
dream and i just i remember that's the
only dream i probably remember vividly
at all but i remember being a kid um
and i would just i would wake up in the
morning and be like not again bro like
after the dream i just feel like [__]
[__] cuz like i'd always wake up in a
cold sweat you know and like it would
always feel like it lasted for 10 years
you know it was just the longest [__]
dream every country you know
and like i always felt like i was being
chased you know i was like running the
whole time i was like it was stressful
you know can you punch a [__] in
your dream
i had to control myself like that bro it
would just happen it was like watching
like a highlight reel you know that's a
great way to put it yeah outer body like
i could yeah like i couldn't control it
i was just like [__] let's see like you
know i'll unload
i could never control myself in a dream
like that oh really never ever died in
one of your dreams
um i've like fallen like i've done the
sky and [__] when i smack the ground i'm
dead i get up i would i would always
wake up before i smack the ground i
would never i'd never actually never
wake up i always smack the [__]
ground
every time actually
what would you like to dream of like
dying it hurt
like you felt it i mean that's what i
felt in my dream i just remember like
when you hit your head as a kid and you
get that like water up your nose feeling
that's how i felt right yeah damn yeah
that's weird that's brutal yeah that's
terrible it's kind of scary have you
never had like a trip like that like
he's describing like where you're able
to like he [__] died on acid but i
mean like we're drunk
there's got to be a drug that does that
i don't i all right
i haven't done dmt which i feel like is
the biggest drug
to you
um
which i'm kind of waiting to do that i'm
good to i'm not ready yet i'm gonna
definitely do some deems at some point
but not anytime soon honestly how
straight edge are you playing it like
are you just like i'm just smoking wheat
and drinking nowadays um that's amazing
congratulations man cause last time you
did not have those vibes last on your
first episode yeah yeah i know at that
point
i was going hard because i mean
i had i was
pretty
you know coming off the peak of like a
drug binge that had been going on for
like years straight like
there was not really many points where i
stopped doing at least one to two hard
drugs like on a weekly basis whether it
was coke and sands or it was always coke
and something i love cocaine but
i don't know i just got tired of that
[__] i like it got to the point where it
wasn't fun anymore like i have to do it
i yeah i did it because i my brain told
me to
and like i felt so uncomfortable when i
was on it i was like dude this isn't
even fun anymore you know so you just
kind of just cut it out yeah i just
stopped doing it i was like [__] this
[__] you know i will say
i had a little on a plate and i gummed
it to stay awake like two months ago
month and a half
does your mom know what was that does
your mom know what that i did that no
that you've not been like doing hard
drugs i don't i tell her but i don't
think she believes me yeah yeah i don't
yeah i don't think she believes you
which is fine it's whatever um does your
mom never watch any of your videos she
has she doesn't anymore but she has she
got so disappointed okay she got sick of
it and she's like so
she likes to argue about like minor
facts in my videos with me and i'm like
oh mom like my mom too
it's so irritating
you have a horrible memory yet you're
over here telling me that was not how i
have the [__] out of your mom i feel you
you got another miller light in here we
got many we got manny miller lights
that's all the miller's at i got you
right huh really
oh my
wow shout out miller light
[__] awesome honestly
so she don't believe you
no she doesn't i tell her all the time i
mean recently um emily and i were up
there for a couple days before christmas
just to like see her and say hello um
she was a couple hours from you yeah she
lives about like two and a half three
hours from me so i drive up every now
and then um
payload visit
but
i i told her even then like we were
talking i was like i don't really do
[__] anymore
i just kind of uh thank you i just kind
of do
like you know a little bit of drinking
and i smoke some butter you know pretty
much every day yeah all the time
and she even tells me she wants me to
stop smoking wheat and i just tell her
like too i'm like mom that's never
happening should your mom do for work
she's a stranger so it's actually kind
of funny she's a drug counselor
yeah
yeah it's actually she yeah it's really
it's really ironic actually
yeah
um she has me
i i feel like i could have driven her to
her career but also she started doing it
before i started doing drugs
this was irony yeah are you an only
child yes [__] yes i am i'm an only
child
how did your mom listen as a dad how did
your like did you have a horrible like
did you when i was younger i had a
pretty bad relationship with both my
parents i still have a
i have basically no relationship with my
dad still to this day because of all how
bad you were being
somewhat yeah he was also kind of an
[__] um
but it was in part because of how bad i
was being yeah but
when i was younger i had a terrible
relationship with my you know pretty
much my whole family because i would
just do a shitload of drugs all day like
i didn't i didn't give a damn about
anything else and you know as i got
older even when i was nice though were
you chilling were you a piece of [__]
i could be a piece of [__] sometimes i
would like dip on family events or like
do drugs at family events and [__] it's
different all the time i'm saying like
you know but i'd be coked up and then
i'd kind of be an [__]
you know
were you shitty before drugs though no
no
so that's why they're pissed but as i
got older i kind of realized like
oh you know i should i should keep my
drug use away
from my family like i should do it in my
own time you weren't hiding it and
denying it no no not at all
uh like 16. oh 17.
that's crazy yeah so [__] suplex in
the house like [__] i'm doing it
anyway like yeah i would uh i would wait
till my mom went to sleep and like hot
box my bedroom and stuff i've done that
one time that's different i did that a
lot of times or like
i would do coke in my like my room on my
desk and my mom would like find some of
my blow sometimes and she'd be really
pissed about that
bro i would have killed you i don't know
how to react to that as a dad like yeah
i feel like as a parent your perspective
on it's probably you ever watch
wrestling
yeah but
from my perspective
i don't know triple h
pedigree i would have did that to you
oh [__] i thought you were doing cocaine
in my house there was a lot of times
where like she just wouldn't let me come
home and [__] uh and i'd eventually so
yeah no i don't blame her i don't blame
her uh i lived in my car at one point i
lived at my friend's house for a few
days multiple times i lived in a hotel
for two weeks one time uh like she's
booting me out for that [__] plenty of
times but at the same time
she didn't try to yeah but at this
well it's kind of different when it's
it's your own child i feel like in the
program i've been through programs of
hers not of hers i feel like
so her if you asked her she's probably
like you have no [__] idea everything
i tried to do but not that it's
if she's that's her profession she
wouldn't have brought you into her own i
i saw a counselor like she saw her at
her office it's different when it's your
parent i guess
no it a hundred percent is they can't a
third party is different than talking to
your parents 100 i will never be honest
with my parent in a therapy setting ever
no shot at that
like you can't get that from your parent
you can't go into your mom's office and
sit down again yeah yeah yeah yeah you
like because you need to be able to
freely talk about your parents you know
and [__] like that
you can't do that to them you know what
i'm saying yeah there's probably nothing
stopping it though if it was just your
addiction like what could they have done
i mean i get yeah yeah a hundred percent
if she started punching you in the mouth
at about 11. yeah you would have been
really scared i should have probably
gotten smacked a few more times but
it helped i was not a great kid
but
i feel like i've gotten better over the
years you know yeah but that's great
she's a drug counselor yeah it's really
ironic isn't it does she get fired for
not no no she's like one of the like
that's your kid no she's one of the like
top counselors at her practice like she
does a great job like she's like the
lead [__] counselor great great work
you're out here with a half a million
[__] subs half a million subs and i
have a crack video cocaine video galore
[__] rehab series coke chronicles
all sorts of [__] yeah informational
viewing man yeah damn what the [__] yeah
it's insane it is some irony
truly
it's
it's funny to me honestly yeah it's
[__] hilarious actually
and as i've gotten older she's grown to
understand it and accept it like that's
your son he's 600 pounds what do you do
i'm a nutritionist
you should be fired
no it's different when it's your son
you see what you see what i'm saying now
it's like
but yeah for sure but it's also like
you're not really glorified i've went
back and watched a bunch of your videos
yeah never spitting facts about life
you're not like yeah yeah i'll be
hitting marty up watching goblin [__]
like ah
somebody don't want me i just kind of i
just kind of talk about what happened i
don't really try to talk try to be like
oh you should do this i might say i like
something but that's because i [__]
did yeah
i [__] love cocaine yeah don't do it
yeah it's bad for you no i [__]
cocaine's amazing but that's why i hate
it
like cocaine is something that even when
i felt like [__] i'd keep doing it
that's how bad it is there's no other
drug that got me like that having bloody
nose waiting for it to dry so i can
[__] just yes i'd be in the bathroom
stuffing wet kleenex in my [__] nose
trying to get the blood out so i could
just do another line
and then it would just start bleeding
more yeah anytime you've been on the
ground searching oh that's not coke
oh all the time dude
i had this little knitted carpet that
like the threads were really loose so it
would always get coke
like some other [__] so i'd be tripping
on the floor looking around with my
flashlight trying to find [__] decipher
whether it was coke or something
10 days ago
it was [__] i was like 16 searching
before too when i was uh i get it when i
was younger
when i was younger i used to to like
bring coke around and try to avoid like
it being found by putting it in cinnamon
capsules i would take so what i'd do is
i'd take saran wrap and i'd roll up a
little tube of coke and i'd seal the
ends with a lighter and then i'd put it
in the middle of a cinnamon cap
you're an inmate i guess you could say
yeah
and i ride around with like four or five
capsules that's uh
i guess you could say a tsa method too
but i don't do it anymore so who cares
but either way
it's
the best one ever is [__] cbd powder
jars and just dump them really
cbd is white just get cbd powder from
the [__] liquor store
dump it out like it's cbd powder from
7-eleven [__]
really it's cocaine
my husband you want to hit some cbd like
no yeah i never bring that much around
where i'm dumping a whole damn jar out
you know
the most i bring around is like maybe in
a ball you know like that's what i'm
saying like you can fit in those little
little jars they sell of cbd that's 30
bucks at the liquor store
yeah i guess you could [__] do that
yeah yeah i mean from my friend's house
would be hella cbd jars like why do you
guys have oh there's cocaine right
now i get it like you guys just smoke
cbd now you [__] [__] coke's just
a terrible [__] drug man it's the
best and most terrible thing it's so bad
for you and it's just so it eats up your
insides it ruins your life everything
but
also oh boy
the most fun joke of all time yeah if i
could be like yo would you smoke weird
or coke forever
everybody's got eye from it
am i gonna die cocaine's one of those
drugs that really everyone's [__]
done
damn near not marty really
i'm over here imagine yeah
good honestly
that's [__] good i know a couple of
people have never done it i wish i had
never done hyper insurance i told you my
first time was an accident right why are
you just doing this [__]
oh [__]
just writing lyrics
you could probably write a banger
honestly if you're tweaking hard trying
to bang
in another language
are you ready
ready for what i got another uh question
for you yeah sure
hey what's up guys
welcome to the mid roll ad read for
those of you that don't know uh this
year
for everyone out there let me just say
right now marty and i uh are now the
brand ambassadors for 2022 for miller
lite thank you guys for making this
possible before we even get into the ad
read thank you and from me to you miller
light has always been one of my favorite
beers and if you've ever watched a story
time you know that's a fact i'm not here
to put down any other beers for tasting
terrible but i'm going to say this right
now this is not one of them i've always
loved miller lite because it tasted
better than the others and as i said
earlier if you've ever watched any of my
story times you know some of the best
times in my entire life some of the best
times of my life were with my uncle john
and we're just
this was our go-to beer miller lite it
was this is what we used to drink being
around a bonfire just being slightly
cold but knowing that this beer is going
to warm me up
you guys know that feeling you know the
feeling of it's almost camaraderie and
if you're shaking your hair yeah i know
then you agree with me and you know
exactly what i'm talking about i'm so
excited that it's miller light because i
i've told marty it's one of the only
beers i can actually taste and actually
drink i'd love this beer since
i won't say how long but i love this
beer and for everyone out there that's
in great shape like me and cares about
calories just to let you know mirror
light 96 calories 3.2 grams of carbs for
every 12 ounces for all you fitness
people out there you know that's pretty
damn low for some beer are you ready for
the best part guys right now go to
millerlight.com forward slash yola and
it'll show you all your delivery options
to get this delivered right to your door
isn't it crazy
sorry man this is our first ad reading
still blowing my mind that we have
miller lite right here as a sponsor
let's go
that's pretty dope so go to
millerlite.com forward slash yolo to
find all your delivery options or you
can go to anywhere in the world that
they sell beer it's miller time
uh celebrate responsibly miller brewing
company milwaukee wisconsin don't drink
and drive basically don't be stupid it's
20 22 start the year of right never
drink and drive have a dope ass day
hey what's up guys we just want to take
a quick break from this episode it is a
long one so get ready we just want to
say a special shout out to one of our
sponsors this is fanduel and you guys
already know wildcard weekend is coming
up the super bowl is not that far away
and if one of your teams is in wild card
weekend i'm sorry because that sucks i
know one team that's not in the wild
card weekend
but in all honesty most wild card teams
are really good teams that just lost a
little too much when you make a deposit
for wild card weekend our fans are
getting the opportunity to get 30 to one
odds on wild card weekend you can bet
five bucks you know five dollars and win
150 if your team wins that's a 50 50
chance on losing five dollars or gaining
145. so come see why fanduel is
america's number one sports book if you
win in as little as two hours you will
get your money so right now go download
fanduel sportsbook go get the app right
now in the app store or the google play
store and if you use code dope as usual
all right remember this dope as usual
our personal code for wild card weekend
five dollar bet can win you 150 it's the
easiest most transparent bet you're ever
gonna get for everyone out there that's
already betting already knows what
they're doing and you have fanduel app
already right now go refer a friend they
get 50 bucks for signing up and you get
50 it's the easiest thing you could do
also before i go remember make sure it's
legal to bet in your state all right
it's it fanduel tells you exactly what
states are legal and you've got to be
21. so remember that guys go use our
code dope as usual five dollars can turn
into 150 back to the episode
um
you smoke something synthetic and you
told me the story about it yeah so so
what happened
when i was younger uh this involves the
same friend i talked about earlier
actually a lot of [__] i did when i was
younger was with this guy ashton right
very good friend of mine but this guy
was
hella drugs this guy loved doing
anything he could get his hands on
and
he got his hands on some [__] that he at
the time told me it was just synthetics
now
still to this day i haven't literally
like you know tested any of it or
confirmed 100 what it is but after like
making a video about it getting comments
on that and like looking up what people
had told me about i have a feeling i
know what it is because it makes sense
but i i kind of
freebased this [__] i guess you could
say i smoked it off tin foil and we were
sitting in my car and we were like maybe
10-15 minutes away from our friend's
house we were going to go over there and
like drink it and then send let's drive
after
yeah
you're reckless i'm stupid honestly
yes yeah i mean no back then i was a
complete dumbass like i didn't mystery
no no for i i didn't think like that
like i was [__] dumb i was reckless i
just figured like oh nothing will happen
to me every time i did something i was
stupid i hadn't learned any lessons yet
you know
so
my buddy
he pulls this [__] out and he's like yo
you want to try some and he'd been
smoking it around me you know fairly
recently this was the first time he
gotten this [__] and i asked him i
remember i asked him at the time i was
like what exactly is it he's like well i
don't i don't really know you know and
i'm like
yeah he's just like synthetic and i'm
like all right he was like it gets you
[__] up so
he passes me the tinfoil he just tells
me to light the bottom of it and hold a
straw in my mouth over it which of
course this guy had plenty of straws on
him he he was a bit of a tweaker himself
you know he had plenty of equipment so
he gave me one and you know i i inhaled
this and
i immediately just got this like first
off it tasted like death before we even
get into the effects
yeah straight chemicals it it tasted
like burning plastic almost like crack
it was bad no honestly i only smoked
crack once it was probably very impure
but i mean it still tasted awful but not
quite as bad as this honestly this was
the worst tasting [__] i think i've
probably ever smoked
like i
i think one of the worst tasting things
is xanax because it makes me puke but
even then you mean smoking it no like if
you leave it in your mouth for too long
and it starts to melt that taste is
it so bad if you leave pillow i hate
longer no i know exactly what you're
talking about i know exactly what you're
talking about it's [__] brutal but
where the [__] did we leave off you were
smoking this oh the synthetics okay yeah
all right so
i took a hit of this [__] and i
immediately got this head rush
that felt like not your normal like
let's say you took a big dab of some
sativa or something head rush that kind
of head rush where it felt like someone
took my [__] head and just started
squeezing the [__] it was like this
almost this pressure on my head and i
was like
i was like [__] dude like i don't feel
like i don't know if i can drive you
know like i don't [__] feel good
and i only took one hit of this [__] i
was like yeah like i'm oh i'm good on
this and after that you know luckily we
weren't like super far from my friend's
house but i i was still i feel like i
was gonna pass out but i was still
driving and i knew that ashton was more
[__] up than me so i was like well i'm
driving here i go
here we go so we managed to actually
make it to her house right
and
we we get in there and luckily your
parents aren't home or anything and
we get we go into her basement she had a
pretty big house very nice neighborhood
we love going over there because parents
were never home she had a hell of liquor
and we can invite people over pantry
with don't dope [__] i bet oh
rich people always kind of dope hands
she had like shark cuttery boards on the
go what's that mean dude you know those
boards are like the cheese and the meat
and the crackers
yeah bro on go i'm talking money in this
house yeah that's so like yeah great
time you know like i'm like fantastic
eateries [__] yeah like what better what
more could you ask for 80 inch no like
70 inch tv in the basement giant you
know in the basement yeah bro
perfect yeah we could play xbox on that
[__] dude it was great it was great her
brother was like in college and left his
xbox there so we just [__] play that
[__] all day but
we uh we got there and i'm sitting in
the basement and i'm like yo like i
don't feel good you know like i feel
like [__] i went to the bathroom and
threw up
i felt like [__] was your bathroom in
the basement yes
crazy they're balling no bro big money
they're both and the basement completely
finished carpet walls done like
beautiful they've seen the finished
garage before
like finished marty's got one now
[__] garage
you told me about how much you got that
bathroom done for and i damn near [__]
myself
this guy getting those player prices i
have never seen a price that good i
worked in that industry i have never
seen a price that good that blew my mind
you said it was how much i think we're
at like 65 with it right now dear god
and you probably got nice [__] in there
you probably yeah we're getting some
what kind of like materials do you have
like that's my wife's that's it
she does all that [__] yeah i don't know
still 65 is crazy we like we do [__]
dog [__]
you know not even plastic break into
your materials for like eight five
minimum [__] like yeah that's crazy she
gets those that's those realtor deals
she knows people [__] yeah
yeah not like it's not [__] expensive
yeah that's bomb yeah i know no that's
[__] crazy still so we're talking
about drugs went into something adult
[__] yeah yeah now we're back she's got
money she has a [__] bathroom in her
basement you throw up
yeah so i throw up and the effects went
away really quickly i think it's just
just the pressure
yeah i felt that pressure in my head and
i felt this real heaviness in me where
it almost felt like i had this g-force
on me the whole time and i was like i
was sitting there and i was like when i
got up it was really hard to walk
and
i like i say pretty much glued to the
couch down there the whole time and like
i really noticed it most when i got out
of my car when i first got there because
that was the first time i'd stood up
since doing it yeah i didn't realize how
[__] up it was until i got out my car
and i was like oh [__]
you know like
i'm [__] right now
but we go down there and i threw up and
after i threw up i felt a little bit
better
and
it really was mainly just that g-force
and i did feel a little bit stoned you
know like oh it was it was a weird i've
smoked synthetic weed before that was
the worst voice crack ever but
i smoked them
i smoked synthetic before quite a few
times um but it didn't feel like this
this was different uh because normally i
got a headache from that [__]
but this was different i didn't get a
headache i got a pressure in my head and
i got this g-force almost like
i just kept feeling like i was about to
pass out and puke at the same time i was
like dude the worst i'm gonna [__] my
pants at this rate like this is [__]
up so
finally it kind of went away and i made
a video about this a few years ago and i
got a bunch of comments from people who
were like oh i think i know what it was
they they called it pink it was like u4
770 or something 44 7 something i don't
know a synthetic chemical that's all i
know
and when i went and looked it up i was
like dude this sounds exactly like what
i [__] had and
apparently
it's like synthetic heroin
and when i found that out i was like oh
wow that's why you felt so shitty like
obviously i didn't test this [__] i
don't know for sure but also what the
hell like what else could it be how many
pink powders you got out there you know
like have you seen the cbg [__] cgb
big powder [__] have you seen that no
what the [__] is that my homies were
doing it not too long ago it's [__]
wild it's like molly and coke together
oh no bro i used to come i used to do
that combo a lot it's just this pink
powder [__] no
whoa
whoa i've heard of that child
[__] that whoa you know it's bad when i
haven't heard of this not even that i
knew it my homies probably watched this
this stupid [__] comes to my
house i go
you're doing that [__] again all night
huh he goes no i mean i just saw it go
how do you know go
and i put my phone out
this is pink [__] all over his face like
a kid eating [__] i didn't eat anything
today that's it was just pink powder
stuck to his whole face he drove 45
minutes to my house like that oh no [__]
face i went full stop get driving [__]
up that's real stop and i told you doing
that [__] nah man like
it was
it's like some kramer [__] when he goes
and that's the way he looked at me like
oh [__] yeah maybe i was snorting
[__] grams all night
yeah it's four in the morning [__] my
friend was spending the night at my
house i know when he's [__] up if he
comes back like yo i'm about to be there
well yeah i know it's
4 40.
yeah i know you're about to be here
so you smoke synthetic heroin cool yeah
pretty dead certain that's what it was i
mean i guess i'll never really actually
know it must be shitty though right
because heroin's supposed to feel like
you got hugging it was really different
i didn't feel good at really any point
oh but the only reason it makes the only
thing that makes me not say for sure i
did it is because
as as much as i could find saying like
yeah people had similar experiences on
like forums and [__]
it also like
i i felt like
when you did i just felt like you'd feel
more of a bliss kind of feeling like you
said you know and that's also what i'd
seen some people described and i was
like how come i got none of that you
know i only got the negative effects
like maybe it's just my body synthetics
i guess of you know it's not like people
are researching this [__] uh so there's
not really any knowledge on
you know it sounds effects
but heroin yeah on paper it sounds fun
but not something i would ever do
against my actual heroine oh i mean if
it wasn't bad for you like yo falling
asleep standing up bro i'm there you
know they get there where's it at people
who do heroin really talk it up
and they also live on the floor yeah
yeah it's the best [__] ever you got
changed dude i don't know all i'm saying
is if i found out something was severely
wrong with me like a terminal illness
doing heroin
well i told him if i lived in 88 opm
dens in china really it's one of the
things i've told rosie your whole
relationship i make to adm go to opium
den because might make it to 88 damn why
are you living wow enough that's a good
guy you died i would love to visit nope
can you imagine accidentally dying at 88
off opium just the dopest [__] in
china coolest way to die ever oh my god
off of bliss imagine that
imagine the technology that have in the
opium dens by the time we are that old
well then again maybe i'll live hella
longer than that maybe i won't maybe
it's dude you know i saw this company
oh wow i haven't even sparked this other
one
this is great news i was wondering what
you were doing you just looked at me
like
i was like
he did
equally [__] through our joints thank
you guys yeah thank you wow
what a great surprise honestly i didn't
even spark my other one yet i'm behind
actually all right
so have you like passed on heroin like
intentionally or it's just not been
around are you it's not really something
i've surrounded myself with luckily um
i've known a few people who've done a
lot of other stuff i will say my friend
ashton did heroin here and there i mean
he's the one that gave you the synthetic
yeah yeah he's not he's not someone who
ever offered it to me he was like yeah
that's something i do myself you know
but you always like to insist that he
only did it on weekends
i don't know if i believe that part but
even the kids that do drugs look down on
heroin users and [__] basically somewhat
yeah i always try to encourage him to
stop doing it but i also respected the
fact that it's his decision at the end
of the day yeah we we do our show like
somebody else's i could try to stop at
the end of the day i'm his homie and i'm
not going to drill him with that [__]
every time i kick it with him you know
like
i mean obviously i wish he stopped right
yeah
donald trump you can't control that
i know
it sucks
for real yeah for real so we got through
synthetics
synthetics you ready
i'm a little high you ever done any
synthetic stuff anything like that i
don't think so
it's good honestly he's a purist
yeah it's good you've never touched any
of that k2 [__] or anything i don't
even know what that is synthetic weed
like the scooby snacks you remember that
[__]
no
we had that [__] in buffalo i i caught
pneumonia or some [__] after doing it
once and never it's again [__] yeah
and it's not even it's not even good is
it it feels terrible yeah it was not
like
i had a pounding headache every time i
did it yeah me too i only did it the one
time i got sick as [__] after yeah it's
so bad that sounds i never got a good
effect off that [__] ever not once i i
did it quite a few times but it's
because it was always
told you know advertised to me is like
something different like oh it's not the
same as the last [__] i'd be like okay
you know i do enough drugs wrong no this
one's better maybe it'll be good this
time but i learned my lesson eventually
[Music]
[__] that
up all right i got another one for you
let's hear it
a p.o box
yeah so we were talking about that a
little bit earlier yeah so
tell me when i was younger
uh back in high school i had a p.o box
and
i
so i was on probation at this point
actually and i figured this was the best
time of my life to sell [__] because i
couldn't do most of it
i smoke it my po
i had a hunch in my youtube channel i
never really got like wait when did you
have your channel
uh i've had this channel since like 2013
bro but i was telling drug stories since
2015.
2016. wait you were like [__] 16
years old talking about all this [__] on
time yeah
i didn't know that oh how did you knock
it some of my old videos are like five
years old six years old
damn i didn't realize that no i didn't
realize that either oh [__] you were
talking about it current
yeah current oh hell no current events
yeah a lot of my older videos from like
2016 2017 current events i was [__] up
while making them i have one video [__]
that i've never told anyone which one it
is
that i made while i was tripping on acid
honestly i don't even know if i remember
anymore it's been so long
but
i did make a video while i was tripping
and i remember a while ago i did like
something where i was like yo if anyone
names it
i'll [__] give you like 20 bucks or
something
like no one got it but back then i had
like 100 followers on twitter so i don't
[__] yeah [__] guess i had like
two people throwing out answers you know
but uh
now the uh the p.o box so
back when i was on probation i figured
this is the best most opportune time for
me to sell weed and some other stuff
because i couldn't smoke weed and i
could never like i tried to sell weed
plenty of times before but i couldn't
make any money because i just smoked two
months yeah i smoked too much of it and
i came to accept that after a while i
was like you know what that's fine i'll
just get a job and spend all my money on
weed and also smoke for free you know
like [__] yeah didn't work out that way
you should smoke more than i sold
because i was i was bad i was really bad
i was [__] at selling weed i was never
fantastic but on probation is when i
started picking up steam like that's
when i started really making a little
bit of money never anything crazy but
at one point
i had a p.o box i just totally ashed on
myself i do every [__] episode it
happens but i had a p.o box that i had
to open
and i used to get fan mail to it too uh
to like i i'd order like normal [__]
from amazon and magazines to it to like
blend in with the like drug [__] i'd get
it was really funny because i only ever
had two people who ever sent me any fan
mail
one guy sent me like a letter one time
that's just like hey love your videos uh
it was literally just like a letter you
wrote right wow the other one was that
old school fan yeah just just a
like a little notebook papers like hey
love your videos you know and then the
other guy sent me three separate
packages
and they were all
disassembled parts to build a bicycle
like they were like gears and like
chains and like a handlebar like parts
to build the bike it's terrifying it was
this no it was hilarious i found it so
funny i was like i i made videos of it i
think i privated them by now but i might
still have them on my channel i like
open these boxes like oh the bicycle
guy's back and on the third episode the
final box he sent me he sent me a bag
full of thermite and a fuse
it's like an explosive powder
it's like really flammable like you like
you could set someone's house on fire
with like a gram of this [__] oh he sent
me a ziploc full of it and instructions
on how to use it he was like hey goblin
don't know if you know what this is this
is thermite uh here's how you use it
safely
he said step one take it outside like
don't use it indoors i was like okay i
went out to my garage and dumped some of
this [__] on the floor
and you used it
hell yeah bro you sent it to me i was
going to use that [__] the bike dude the
random bike part this is a different
dude no same guy the bike part guy sent
me thermite at the end i don't know why
he would send me like lego figures and
bike parts and like little toys and like
thermite at the end it was actually dope
okay send me a letter and he'd be like
hey here's some more random [__] i have
oh okay oh he told you why
no he wouldn't say why there's like
here's friends
hey
here's some [__] okay somebody just sent
you a box
knowledge that it's wrong it was okay
he would just be yeah yeah he would just
be like okay here's some [__] i was like
okay
and he wrote like detailed instructions
on how to use the thermite safety so you
sit like that to
see how it goes so i did it in my garage
and it like scared the [__] out i told
you just do it inside first well i
opened the garage door and did it near
the edge so i thought it was good enough
so you're outside got you not good
enough though um totally almost burned
my [__] house down dude it was very
flammable uh i had i i didn't know
research on it i was just like okay bro
let's check this out it was like
terrifying i opened the door i i
probably shouldn't have but i threw it
in the garbage i threw the rest of the
thermite in the ground what'd you do did
you make a little trail of gasoline and
shoot it with the [__] beef no so he
attached he attached this little from
the kelstrom you attached this little
[__] fuse in there he was like oh
just light this and it'll you know leave
the thermometer put the fuse down lit
the fuse and [__] rain do you think
you were like down with this did you
ever do
videos of bicycle and vigilante [__] no
i don't know i don't
if i'm being honest i can barely ride a
[__]
bike i love that you threw that in there
i'm being honest i can't even really
ride a bike does it explode i mean well
extremely flammable you never rode a
bike as a child no i i like had a bike i
was just terrible at it always i like
i'd fall very often my coordination is
bad really yeah really bad barely ride a
bike
whoa did you play sports as a kid i
played football
your coordination is not terrible yeah i
mean i was gonna have to play football
you [__] guard
uh i was a lineman on offense and on
defense there was a nice guy a guard or
a tackle uh guard yeah that's her
figures are you a guard yeah yeah i
figured
yeah it was fun you could see it guy
played as a guard to center a nose
tackle it was fun
oh yeah but you got some coordination
been doing three-point stances and [__]
dude that [__] was a blast honestly yes
defense is very fun yeah
i love i love being on the offensive
line offense is fun because you could
just block the [__] out of the [__] yeah
like you can just be so aggressive with
it it's like the ball's all the way over
there but this yeah like your only
assignment is just get this
[__] [__] to his back your
only assignment unless you're a receiver
is just get this [__]
you know
um sorry thermite yeah this dude sent me
some thermos totally okay with it what
if it was like i thought it was exercise
i thought it was dope i was like dude
this is fire mustard gas i've never
gotten any other fan mail so i was like
this is cool you know wait what else
were you when this happened i was young
bro i just got out of rehab i was like
maybe seventeen eighteen oh okay okay
okay i think i just turned eighteen
damn dude i would never accidentally
that's crazy it was a crazy neck crack
i'll leave i did hear that through that
wow i heard it holy [__] i did hear it
god damn you don't have a fan open fan
mail box now do you no good thank you
don't no yeah i know that my fans would
send me drugs and i'm not getting in
trouble for that that and people are
creeps and dick [__] and weirdos
yeah yeah you know the thermite guy
might be like
yo yo there's my guy's cool though no
yeah i'm saying like one of those dudes
but the anti-thermite guy oh send you
some [__] without instructions i mean it
just explodes yeah just a bomb yeah you
ever seen jingle all the way
jesus christ all right he's watching the
other no
there's bombs in the mail okay i don't
want to get a [__] bomb in the mail
bro yeah no don't it's not yeah i know
it's not worth it so you almost burned
your house down i love it yeah but back
to the p.o box part so uh i was also
getting some
i was also getting some um
some weed in there every now and then
and towards the end i had ordered a few
things i ordered two pounds of some
trash off the dark whip yeah like some
dookie shake
terrible ass weed
and
back at this point this was right before
a lot of these sites got shut down
alphabay no this is more recent alpha
bay hanza uh newer sites it got shut
down and you can't just google that
uh not now i mean i mean
whenever someone says dark web i go but
how
so where is it
you can't just go google dark web stuff
you actually can can you yeah bro you
can actually find links for like markets
on that's so scary
yeah no it so a lot of them are like
phishing links you have to be careful of
that fishing links what does that mean
you can enter a link that's like a virus
you know it'll like track your info or
install something on your computer
like you can enter a bad link that'll
[__] you over you know or like a link
where like you enter it and you enter
your login info and you get hacked
because it's not the real site it's like
a duplicate
you know that kind of [__]
good thing i don't care about that [__]
yeah that sounds scary yeah but you were
on the dark web getting pounds you got
two pounds i got two pounds of some swag
all shake
no nugs
terrible
i paid about 400 500 a pound for this
[__] so i paid total like a grand for
this [__] and i was selling ounces for
the low to my friends like i was doing
at first i was doing like i was taxing
but i was doing like 100 at first and i
got a few kids i got a few kids for 100
and i was like yes
this is it yeah five of these are not
clear of the pee you know that's
it
because i can't smoke none of this [__]
did you know it was so shitty buying it
oh for sure uh for sure yeah they
advertised it as lows they were like
yeah this is trash um they're like yes
but i was like you know what that's what
i want like i don't have much money to
to play with so i want to make as much
as i can so i sold all this [__] to all
my friends as quick as i could uh before
they realized i was flipping ounces for
any price like you if you said anything
above like 40 i was probably gonna take
it you know like i didn't give a [__] so
i i flipped like the first pound like
damn near the first night because i was
just doing only ounces like half o's and
up like if you didn't want at least a
half oh i'm not coming you know because
i was willing to do a half for like 50
[__] yeah like why would you not do
that you know yeah so
i was doing like halfs and like zips and
all that [__] and i got rid of the first
p really quickly
and
then the second one took me a little
longer it took me like a few more days
but still i was doing zips for so low
like
other people i knew were flipping them
for like profit for themselves so i was
like [__] it go for it you know i don't
care so i had a couple friends come back
and take the rest of what i had left um
and after that i had a few more things i
was still waiting on
uh i had a little bit of molly coming in
and i had something else
i'm pretty stoned so i i don't exactly
honestly remember but i had something
else coming but the molly i know i was
really really waiting on and
i got a letter from the post office
uh telling me that they needed your p.o
box was it the post office yeah that's
what a p.o box is bro they're at the
post office
i've never had a po box at the post
office i just have a regular post p.o
box place oh really
i've never gotten a peel box at a post
office all the ones in my area are just
parking is a smaller town yeah yeah yeah
for sure for sure whoa you were a ballsy
[__] yeah
but those two pounds came in big coffee
bags
they got shipped like that just these
big giant coffee ground bags
and in the bottom is just a bunch of
shake and they got put in a po box at
the post office waiting for me in that
condition
i couldn't believe i actually got them
but
then
i got told that i had to come in and
sign for my next package and i was like
yeah that's how they get you [__] this
i'm done you know yeah they told me i
had to sign for the like one that they
had and i have to sign for all future
packages and i was like yeah
[__] this i'm done you know like i'm not
like [__] this piano under your name
yeah
damn
yeah i was pretty dumb
i was pretty dumb when i was young
but i i never nothing ever really
happened it's because they [__]
pocketed all that [__] they found and
just oh [__] i had a good [__] time
with that [__] i bet yeah they did i had
a good [__] time at that all day
so that's how you get your p.o box shut
down
you're ballsy [__] man yeah i
looking back on it probably one of the
dumbest [__] things i've ever done in
my life yeah at least you know
at least that's the double absolutely
absolutely one of them one
all right so i i have a list where are
we at right now 150. oh nice two hours
in we're doing good all right real quick
we're going pretty hard i have not eaten
food today i'm gonna eat an edible which
is probably the dumbest thing nice
nice
do you want a shark hell yeah all right
redder red or blue
wait you haven't got your package yet
huh no i haven't
i've been away from home for like yeah
you haven't you haven't even tried them
gobbles doing a [__] uh review on our
[__] nice now i'm gonna lay it out now
i'm gonna be
brutally honest in my review that's fine
i'm gonna be straight up that's fine i
know you expect that of me but
i wouldn't of course
i just want to let the people know you
know i just want to let the people buy
us but i'm hyped for this you've been
talking about this to me for a while yes
red or blue
blue looks fire
i like i like the color blue
i don't know man i'm just uh
i was going to eat these anyway today
during the show
and then i realized like y'all here's
eight food before we started
i got a salad in the warehouse uh-huh oh
i gotta really dig in here grab it
there we go thank you
wow that really is a shark
that's a shark it's a fat [__] shark
holy [__]
oh yeah let's go i'm [__] starving
though
drinking beer being hungry yeah totally
reminds me of bonfire yeah
tastes fine
they don't even taste like in like an
edible i know
i said they tasted like uh
remember slush puppies the slushy with
the dog on the side
these are the blue i love those
i [__] love those it's different from
a slurpee slurpee's are bomb
that actually doesn't taste like an
edible i know like
it's scary yeah that's just like some
[__] you just eat i know like it's like
the blue my favorite candy or the blue
gummy sharks
dude so yo we gotta do blue gummy sharks
wow
yep wow
i ate some of those every [__] night
when i'm feeding her candy and then i
wake up in the middle of the night nice
yep
here we go
are you ready i am
i love them
all right it just says
girl had a breakdown
girl had a breakdown you know what's
funnier i wrote it
i'm over here to laugh oh it's funny i
wrote it dumb like that
i like that i like that little prompt
yeah i just want to give away too much
i've talked about this one on my channel
this is
probably one of the most wild days
of my life because
it [__] went south so quickly i was with
one of my really good friends named kyle
right
and
he's been in plenty of my streams and
shows
um you know plenty of my videos so
people know him so i can say his real
name and all that but um i was with him
and we got invited to go to this girl's
house who i'm not going to name her and
everything but we got invited to go to
her house
and she initially just said like oh yeah
let's smoke some weed and i had a little
bit to match so
i was down right
i think i had a little bit honestly i
don't remember but she had weed i
remember that part i had coke though
this was at the point where i was like
peak coke consumption so i went over
there
and my buddy kyle and i were both pretty
coked out and she was like she was
acting way different than normal i had
met her through a lot or no not really
but i i'd been around her a bit because
her boyfriend sold me weed pretty often
so that's how i met her that's how like
i'd be around her she invited me there
was like oh yeah like
you know come through i smoke some weed
i didn't realize that she was like kind
of having an episode you know um at
least i believe so a mental episode yeah
mental episode and we got there and she
was just like going off about how like
like men are like after her and [__] and
a bunch of crazy [__] i'm sitting there
and i'm like whoa we're men you know and
i'm invited i'm like yeah i'm sitting
here and i'm like bro what like what
should we even do right now you know
but i just thought maybe like i asked i
was like did something happen you know
and like she just wasn't making any
[__] sense you went over there like
she was like that already
yeah so you smoked a little bit of weed
and
i asked i offered because kyle and i did
a little bit of coke and i offered her
some i was like hey like
do you want some you know like i mean
[__] it maybe she wants to come a little
bit i'm gonna be polite at least like
whatever um and she like
got fairly offended by that for some
reason even though i knew she
did coke and was like
it wasn't like i was trying to tell her
like he would do i was like would you
like some you know um just offering so
she she kind of like got a little snappy
with me and i was like okay whatever
and
eventually i put my coke down
and i had like changed the spot that i
was sitting in right i had gone to cash
the bowl out and i had like gone and sat
in a different spot when i came back
right
so
when i came back my coke was like gone i
couldn't find it i'd put it down but i
couldn't find it and kyle and i were
looking for it we checked our pockets
checked my bag
looked around the garage
and i asked her if she could help me
look for it
and
i need to hit this joint more it keeps
going out it's all good
but
i asked her i was like yo could you help
me look for it
she likes
just snapped like she flipped the [__]
out she was like are you accusing me of
like stealing it and she like flipped
the [__] out she's like here like all
man they're [__] terrible like why'd
you accuse me that [__] i would never do
that i'm like bro what the [__] she was
waiting for you to do something yeah i'm
sitting here i'm like what is going on
and i was like yo i just want you to
like help me look for it i don't know
where the [__] it is and i was like i
think you took it like you didn't even
want to do something i offered i don't
think you [__] took it she did but
we'll get to that [__] yeah she did but
we'll find out
the seinfeld episode with the raisins
when the fake kramer applies and he
takes the raisins yeah she so
she flipped the [__] out and we were
like yo what the [__] is going on and i
i went kept looking for my blow and she
was just yelling at us and kyle started
to get like your team was like you gotta
shut the [__] up like you can like why'd
you invite us here if you hate like
we're men you know cuz she just kept
saying this crazy [__] i don't know what
the hell happened but i was like
not really about to ask this is like
a 16 year old girl sorry what was that
she was like 16.
yeah she wasn't our age at this point we
were all teenagers at this point like 16
17. so
apparently i think she had just broken
up with her boyfriend and she was just
having an episode or something
as i like came back she just like
started an argument with me and i was
like you know like i don't think you
took it but the way you're acting is
making me like think you [__] took it
you know like why are you acting like
this like if you didn't do anything you
would just [__] help me find it yeah
you know uh and she got really mad at
that and like
literally like screamed like roared
like let out like a
just like a [__] screech jesus and
she came at me with like a like a
toothbrush and my friend kyle with a
toothbrush yeah like the end of a
toothbrush bro but not the sharpened no
it was just it's a regular toothbrush
it was just
yeah i don't know where the [__] she got
it i don't know
but she had a toothbrush
so she came at me my friend kyle grabbed
me and he kind of clutched up he like
moved me out of the way he actually he
was really really situationally aware
there right like he really clutched up
so
he kind of moved me out of the way a
little bit
she went to stab you with it yeah and
like smacked it out of her hand you know
and she was like screaming she's like
get out so
we open the garage door right because
you can kind of like pull it you know
you can pull it or press the button so
we opened the garage door and leave and
she slams it shut but she's screaming so
loud we can still hear from the end of
the driveway and i'm running my pockets
and i realize i don't have my car keys
so i'm like oh my [__] god bro like
what are we gonna do i'm looking through
my bag don't have my car keys i'm like
dude what the [__] is going on
so
her dad ends up like coming outside and
we're standing the end of this driveway
and he's like hey what's going on and i
kind of explained i'm like yeah listen
she invited us over here she's being
[__] wild right now like we are just
trying to leave but i don't know where
my keys are you know
and like he was like oh like what did
you guys do and like i was like we just
smoked some wheat like you know that's
it he was pretty cool about it honestly
he helped me find my keys actually in
the garage yeah he actually was he
understood he was like he said to me he
was like oh she gets like this sometimes
i was like oh what the [__] bro like
that's like i don't yeah i was like bro
i don't want to be like here you know
like i just want to leave but like i
don't have my keys you know so
he ends up finding my keys for me i
don't know where the [__] they were bro
but he found him somehow um
i i don't know what happened to him why
they were away maybe they fell in my
pocket i don't [__] know but he found
him and we [__] ended up leaving like
an hour and a half later it was just the
craziest thing ever waited outside for
an hour and a half no no it took like an
hour and a half for us to like him to
both calm her down and find the keys for
us because we were looking but he was
standing outside the whole time yes we
were just standing and he was like in
there trying to calm her down and look
for our keys and he couldn't do it so we
were just standing there forever
we were like
we couldn't do it dude like we were like
yo
this is [__] like she's freaking the
[__] out she's screaming like the
neighbors are gonna wake up at this
point the sun is coming up you know
at this point we went over there when
the sun was down it was like 3 30 a.m it
was now like
sunny time like it was like 5 30 you
know it was like six so the sun's coming
up so we're like
this is [__] you know we gotta go
and
yeah we we ended up getting our keys a
while later from her dad luckily and we
dipped the [__] out of there after that
[__]
yeah it was crazy dude it was
i don't know like that was she was
really like coming at me dude like she
tried to hit me with the toothbrush and
then she tried to like hit me and [__]
and she like she didn't find out like
she was just weird i never talked to her
again i just like blocked her on
snapchat i was like okay i don't really
i'm over it yeah i was like i'm you know
i'm just not gonna deal with this again
you know like whatever what her
boyfriend sold weeds everybody from him
yeah yeah i actually did i talked to him
and i was like yo what the [__] he was
like yo like
yeah i'm sorry about that he actually i
think they broke up for a while i don't
know about now but i haven't talked to
the kid in years
but
uh they broke up for a while last time i
talked to him what do you have to ask
sorry sorry last question on that was
her freakout just to steal your coke
i don't know because he told me she had
the blow yeah that's what i'm saying
like did she do that just to get you the
[__] out doubt it she could just
deadlines with you yeah i don't know i
don't know what it was for
because i didn't like expect her to be
that kind of person or anything yeah but
how weird
of course
that [__] yeah i mean boyfriend told you
that she's yeah yeah
he told him she told him yeah
she's crazy as hell yeah she's crazy
yeah she didn't do it to be sneaky she
did it just because her brain says grab
it yup
yeah yeah no that's some that's some
next level i'll murder this [__]
yeah and then shank him with the two dab
with the toothbrush find the nearest
object would she have connected with the
brush
if you didn't like yes yes she would
have connected there with that brush
that would have went into your body yeah
it would have been [__] that would
have hurt yeah
that would have been really brutal
that's something that's some psychotic
[__] well yeah that story from a girl
had a breakdown that's a true breakdown
yeah yeah a complete break the fact that
her dad was like wait wait there's two
boys no her dad was so cool basement at
3 30. that's not the first thing he
asked the first thing was what's going
on yeah he was like why is she screaming
yeah he checked on you guys first yeah
he came out well i don't know if he
checked on her because we she closed the
garage and then he
you know so i don't know if he checked
on her us i'm not sure but he came out
to us pretty quickly after we realized
we didn't have our keys um
because we were in our our did you know
the driveway for a few minutes just
fumbling for our keys in our pockets and
[__] looking around on the ground and
all that
seinfeld yeah and he came out and he was
he was really cool about it he was like
i understand
it happened she gets like this every
time we do coke together she throws she
didn't even touch the coke she did none
of it until she stole it
i don't know she didn't go inside at one
point so maybe that's when she stashed
it
but
i i that has to be that has to be yeah i
think about it 100 no it has to be
but well
you're a [__]
what a [__] chick to just invite two
dudes over to steal the drugs yeah
i mean she was to be fair having a real
mental episode she probably was no she
absolutely was because she actually uh
from what i heard ended up in a like a
treatment facility oh because it really
was a mental thing yeah no no this
really was
i actually don't really know what the
[__] happened but
nice catch
oh this is a white wow
over here yeah that's fantastic
get out of here
um i love it so she really did have a
mental episode never mind yeah yeah
talking [__] i just thought she was so
yeah i don't really know what she could
have i mean she didn't take it she'd
steal it let's be clear on that
wow i don't have any
i don't stay away from crazy
[__] when i was a kid yeah
wow i don't have any stories of like
about
i would have just left immediately i
think is why i'm like oh i'm [__] out
of here what did you say what'd she say
she's weird i'm out
yeah i feel that i don't have any
stories like i'm just thinking like have
i ever been in a situation like i don't
think i have
i mean you hung around the right people
i was i was much more lenient when i was
younger about who i'll hang around now
with the liquids i kick it with like the
same people i try to keep my my circle
of friends as small as i can you know
yeah i don't like you know i don't go
out on my way to meet a bunch of new
people because i feel like i know enough
people you know like i'm not going out
places like
i don't do that [__] anymore that much i
don't ever but you live far away from
where you grew up from yeah that's
probably a big factor in it too yeah i
lived nowhere near where i grew up and
not having a license really cuts me off
from that area too you know and i'm
about to lose my l's so what's keeping
you there like couldn't you i mean like
honestly it's cheap
and
i have good internet
you guys got legal weed no i guess if
you're comfortable like yeah i'm
chilling i mean [__] dude i don't
really give a [__] i i do i work from
home yeah that's true that's true
yeah that's a fair [__] point you're
not you're not wrong i mean if i can
save some money while i'm young hell
yeah
but i do want to move uh i am planning
on moving out fairly soon yeah uh i'm
probably going to move to chicago
bigger spot man yeah
yeah more opportunities i feel
especially
i mean i just feel like it's it's a
really nice city because people are
leaving so rent prices aren't going up
like that
but i still love the city i don't give a
[__] if people are leaving you know
so
people are leaving because it's known as
being so [__] violent are you saying
i mean crime is getting pretty bad but
i feel like that's [__] everywhere
right now you know that's not a
you know
chicago exclusive thing you're like you
know i've heard la's been getting fairly
bad you know it's always shitty yeah i
mean
have you lived in chicago before
in the city when i was very young like a
baby not i've never really experienced
living in the city city i always lived
outside in the suburbs you know
somewhere around
you'll be getting into all kinds of [__]
like that's a whole different direction
yeah yeah exactly
um
i mean the extent of my time in the city
was just one time i lived in my car in
the city because chicago yeah yeah so i
had a friend who was really wealthy
and his family had a boat at this
[__] harbor and we couldn't get on
the boat but he let us park at the
parking lot it was gated and [__] and we
could park there for free
so we'd just take his pass and go sleep
in the car there
me and my friend bob um because i got
kicked out of my house my friend bob
just like wanted to get drunk all the
time she was like hell yeah bro i'll
sleep and shoddy you know so i shot it
damn this full we've got nothing to do
no we're homeless i'll be homeless with
you yeah no literally that's how it went
he was like yeah i'll be homeless with
you so like is that a good friend or a
bad friend he was he's a great friend of
mine okay okay he's a great friend of
mine i got the friend that'll do just
sleep outside
i don't know if we want him around those
are some cool guys though don't say is
he cool oh yeah yeah yeah good friend of
mine but
no he was just down to be homeless with
me and i was like [__]
how old were you we were like 16 we just
turned 16. oh he was 16 also yeah yeah
[__] okay and um it was summer bob is
not selling a teenager's name bro yeah
yeah i don't think i've ever been a
teenager named bob but i've met a lot of
adults named bob and i don't think they
were ever teenagers before well this is
the first one you listen to the first
one but um
either way he um
when i met him he was just kind of down
to do whatever the [__] you know
so we uh we lived in my car for a little
bit at this this harbor and we go to
mcdonald's
and like just grab some food and live
off that [__] you know because we didn't
have much money to spend like you know
we'd have a budget of like 30 dollars
but
back in the day they used to make money
by cleaning people's boats i did this
like a couple times with them but
they go to the harbor and find those
rich [__] at the boats and
since we had a pass we could get in and
like go up to the you know all the spots
and stuff so
we'd like wax people's boats and [__]
not weed like i wasn't i was only there
once or twice for it but they'd go wax
people's boats and that's how they made
money for like weed and [__] back then
and these [__] would tip like a
100 bill for every person there
so like because they're so rich dude
they're sitting on a [__] yacht they
don't give a [__] dude like they have
[__] you money you know
if you have money to park a boat at a
yacht and a major or park a park a boat
at a harbor
uh in a major city like you have [__]
you money i feel like you know that's
expensive yeah that's so much money um
so they just make money like that and
that's how bob had some of the money he
had on him and we were just smoking off
that [__]
but i mean we kind of lived
uh
pretty nicely because there's this hot
dog place kind of close by which is so
fire no i [__] you not bro how long does
go on for uh
so he lived in my car for like a couple
nights like two three days um i lived in
my car for like about a week because at
this point i was already kicked out of
my mom's house i was living with my dad
dad was an [__] so i didn't want to
be there so i was like you know what the
whip is fine
so
that's what i did
regretted it pretty quickly but it was
fun this is the same car that flooded
water no no no i bought that much more
recently actually
yeah i bought that uh
right before i got my so a little over
two years ago about two and a half years
ago i got that car
it was only three thousand dollars which
explains it
i mean nowadays i probably could have
sold that for more with the current car
market honestly yeah you probably could
have current markets [__] dude i just
bought a kia right um i was telling you
about this earlier it's got 130 000
miles on it guess how much i paid
2012.
it's got options it's got remote start
all type of [__]
but seven thousand dollars
way way higher way uh 120 thousand a
month oh a 2013 2012. 2012 uh you paid
14. 13. yeah i would say it was like 13
3 damn yeah expensive yeah that's [__]
isn't it yes yeah i mean i'm not the
kind of person who's 13. if i buy a
flashy car i feel like it's got to be
something really high-end you know
yeah and like
i don't want to spend that much on a car
at this point you know i just want to
whip something that's average and will
get me point a to point b
key is that [__] you know key is
that dude
he is that dude it's great dude it's
comfy nikki optima's are dope i used to
have one of those i [__] loved it
honestly i i love this car the more i
drive it i'm like damn this thing's fire
dude 2012 kia sportage great pickup
that's literally my sister's car 2012
kia sportage
she's got the new version of it dude
they're fire as [__]
they're honestly decent dude
my seats are coming i already uh ruined
one of the seats though i asked on it
and the cherry just completely
yeah
it's all right
it's really not though man
[Music]
dropped an entire qp cherry
on my seat in my brand new car oh
his name is og
and he said he was gonna fix my seat
four years ago and he still hasn't fixed
it i sold the car
before because he works at honda bro i
got you four years cool
now i got i sold to my dad for my little
sister we just put seat car seat covers
on it
i'm surprised og didn't take care of
that for you that's petty it was it was
it was his fault completely how long
it's actually on camera
it's on camera it's about three or four
years ago yeah it's called
uh three ounce
hot air pump hotbox oh you made a video
of this yeah we we uh
attached a bed pump
okay we're at the house and we're
smoking we go yo that [__] bet you
you could [__] put weed on top this
is like four or five years ago and it
would blow weed out right
because i used to have this little
machine i bought at the smoke shop i did
that on the stream one time it worked
yes it worked good we did it with like
tin foil we poked that's exactly what it
did yes yes it worked so good it works
great what i did is i rolled a heat or i
had og roll like a three ounce i rolled
it a three ounce joint and we attached
it to it okay right over the hole so
when you light it
the machine would just
that's fire
but what happened is og couldn't see
because you couldn't see in the car
anymore in daylight
i couldn't even see
couldn't breathe
and he just oh got out and dropped the
whole chair bam right on my seat and i
didn't notice for like 15 seconds
because you can't see dude i've been in
a hot box had everyone had i had to take
my damn shirt off bro i couldn't do it
that's too much there's a lot of those
hot boxes really last like three minutes
yeah dude there was one where
i rolled this blunt with my friend in
high school we called it the assault
rifle we put i don't remember if it was
five or six swishers like back-to-back
mega extend though right it was like
probably damn you're six issues right
here yeah yeah probably right here but
you can get four or five but we smoked
it in my car because you couldn't smoke
it in his house my car was a two-seater
it was a two-door um so we le i leaned
the seat all the way back and my first
hit my nose started bleeding so oh
i'm a shock on ripping pages out of my
owner's manual putting them in my nose
we didn't have any money so i was like
man we can't get no tissue like i got a
[__] you know like i'm not gonna put
toilet paper from the gas station up
there i'll use the owner's manual you
know like [__] it so
i ripped out a good like 10 pages out of
that [__] uh did what i had to do and
we smoked this blunt for probably a
total like two and a half hours of just
straight smoking
and we drove around picking up
different friends of mine and letting
him hit it like dropping him off and
[__] it was we were like a traveling
blunt but we tried to keep the the
windows up as long as we could but we
like couldn't do it while we were
driving because we were driving on main
ass roads and yeah like yeah we like
barely we were like [__] this dude like
we gotta stick to the neighborhoods you
know like we're like
this isn't gonna work and i let my
friend drive my car because i was like
i don't know i didn't feel like driving
you know i was like you can think about
this [__] you know like go for it he
actually broke out my tail light one
time
that was bad doing backing up yeah we
were backing out of a driveway because
um all right kind of a terrible thing to
do but i don't admit to being a good
person in high school
um we used to steal packages
but uh sports pirates yeah but we would
all right so there was one time we
accidentally stole like some kids
birthday [__] we put it back we were
like okay that's [__] up
but um
oh you opened it and saw it was birthday
yeah we were like yo we gotta go put
this back
i wouldn't go back yeah like we just
threw it in a child's life you know sure
so we went and like threw it back but um
we used to [__] go hit porches and
one time he pulled into this really nice
house that had this stone mailbox like
it was like encased in stone yeah
beautiful and they had a they had a
package and i got the car and i ran up
and grabbed it
and we were leaving and he backs into
their stone mailbox frame and breaks my
tail light
and he's like [__] he's like i'm so
sorry and i'm like bro just leave like
now we have to leave like like
the mailbox was fine yeah you can't yo
mailbox a-okay like it never happened
they probably didn't know
this is before ring cameras were in
everyone's [__] door you know so
we thought that
you know we just maybe got a little
scratch on the bumper so we drove out of
the neighborhood and we stopped in this
parking lot we got out of the car and i
i noticed that my whole taillight is
just smashed out like the glass is gone
almost like
there's you could just see the exposed
bulb the bulb wasn't broken luckily but
like the the outer casing thing was
[__] and there was also a huge dent on
my bumper so i was like yo this is
karma this is terrible like wow karma
really hit me right there instantly yeah
yeah i will say i never got anything
good except for one time out of taking
packages
i got a samsung gear like the vr headset
they sell for like 100 bucks and i took
it to my plug and he gave me weed for it
that was the best thing yeah it's not
everyone orders like some crazy boozy
[__] everyone just orders dumb [__] yeah
that's what i'll be back
you're not gonna get something you could
really get money for like that like
we were under 18 too so our limitations
were what's our plug gonna give us weed
for yeah yeah
like can we get a goddamn video game or
something like we're gonna get a
playstation you know
never happened but
we there's one time we got like some
pictures like some paintings but they
were like you know copies not real like
literally on like paper just like
regular ass paper
those were those were shitty never got
anything good
good
yeah good now i know i know we were
terrible i feel awful about it now i
only did it like
to do drugs yeah i mean i was feeding
dude i was like i was like [__] i gotta
get some money you know i wasn't i
didn't give a [__] how i did it at that
time you know i feel like that's how a
lot of people are with drugs like when
you're really into it you don't give a
[__] how you give them [__] when you're
on drugs and drugs are gone you don't
give a [__] how you get the money for it
nope
it's sad
it's wild
um
i don't know how we got into that whole
story i don't know either but i have
another uh
one written down okay
damn we're we're getting into it you
ready yeah yeah yeah
it's just this k-hole at girl's house
so there's this one time
a lot of these stories involve the same
buddy of mine it's really funny actually
um
my friend asked him we went to this
girl's house who um so
we had a nickname for
for her we called her danielle because
she did a lot of zans
so uh we went to her house and we had
ketamine and she invited a few of her
friends over and ashton was like
you know kind of into one of them he's
like oh you know that girl is pretty
cute like you know let's give him some
ketamine and i'm like
do they you know i sure i'm down i'll do
some k2 you know like let's do some k so
he asked him he's like yo do you guys
want to do some k
i feel like the way i said that sounded
kind of wrong actually
he he offered
he said let's offer this again
it wasn't all like that
it wasn't like okay um
some [__] and there are drinks yeah he
was like let's let's do some k with him
maybe you know so he offers on some k
and they all oblige and we come to find
out that none of them have ever done it
before
and ashton's definition of a line of k
is so different from mine right uh or
like not a lie but a fair amount for
like a starter for me i always say like
the very end of a credit card you you
put it in the bag and you scoop maybe
the corner out and that's your bump just
a little pinch
this guy thinks a lion is a first-timer
dose
a line of ketamine
is enough to knock you the [__] out if
you've never done it like
that's a shitload you have to have an
extreme tolerance for that but at the
time i was doing lines i didn't really
pay attention to it i still figured like
oh maybe he'd tell him you know
do half or some [__]
but they just got right into it
and my friend danielle uh she did a fair
amount
and got super k-hole and so did her
front her friend so k-hole means you
just can't think you're moving so
k-hole is
some people like it in k-hold and i
couldn't imagine that but it's one
person you lose almost total control of
you know what you're doing and
speaking is really difficult when you're
holding it's kind of weird like you you
try to talk but you don't know what
words are coming out of your mouth
it's really strange it's really strange
are you like in slow motion
somewhat yeah
yeah you could say that
i would say slow motion is actually a
pretty fair description but it's slow
motion and
you can't really feel or control many of
your movements or what you're saying and
it can get almost frustrating in my
opinion because you you're trying to
communicate but you feel like you can't
so it's like sleep paralysis
yeah
i mean ketamine is literally a
tranquilizer right
vets use it the [__] [__] old school
where you shoot just [__] darkness
you're cool man
yeah yeah yeah no kevin is is [__] but
she did like a whole line of this [__]
along with all of her friends and they
got so [__] k-holed they were like
they had to sit at the table and we were
like yo we gotta like
[__] take care of them dude like this
is fun so they're just sonked out
we had a much higher tolerance because
we would do this [__] at school together
we go we had the same lunch period so we
go in the stalls that were next to each
other and pass pay under the stall
together and like do it he'd bring a
baggie and like pass me a debit card and
i'd do a line and then passing some
money back under
and that's how we do it you know and
i do a lot of lines at lunch so our
tolerance was way higher where even i
didn't think a gram was too much you
know or not a gram but a line i was like
i didn't even think that was too much i
thought that was okay so when i saw them
super [__] up on it i was like yo
i like we got to stay here for a little
bit you know and he was like yeah for
sure so we were kind of chilling there
for a little bit hanging out and
one of the one of the girls just like
sleeping on the couch not sleeping but
like laying on the couch like knocked
the [__] out like super slump uh the
other girl was like sitting at the the
dining room table and then danielle was
chilling in the kitchen with us you know
she was she was hanging out with us but
still so [__] up she was making no
sense oh i've never seen that before i
had another friend there who
i was talking to him and i was even
borderline chaol because this [__] was
so fire it was so pure i remember
looking at him and he looked like he was
almost nine feet tall and i looked at
him and i i remember i kept asking him
if he was good to drive i was like are
you good to drive bro and he was like
are you dude because i drove
i was like are you [__] good to drive
and he was like i'll drive your car you
know like like i'll whip home because he
rode like
it was really funny actually he had this
little like tricycle that he would like
ride places it was like a bike but it
had three wheels and it was kind of
actually just literally a tricycle like
it wasn't a cool three-wheel bike a
giant tricycle it was not yeah no it was
just a big-ass tricycle i needed like a
bike or did he sit down no he sat up
and
this thing it was so funny watching
right around on this but it was it was
small enough to fit in my trunk because
at this point i drove a honda crv to the
function uh it was my mom's car i [__]
it up i feel bad i'm sorry to my mother
but um
i did hella damage i let my friend drive
it he backed into an s-class it was bad
yeah wait same night
no not the same night but we that was a
hit in rome he just left oh
oh
the s-class too oh i feel terrible about
that but i wasn't driving and i was like
bro i'm not doing like that's a [__]
100 000 car probably i'm not doing this
you know yeah but um
they were all k-holding [__] up and i
was so [__] up that one of my friends
who had gotten there
he offered to drive my car back so i was
like are you good to go i like kept
asking him i did a little more k with
ashton um i did another like so is he
fine ashton or is he [__] his
tolerance is higher than anyone's hair
he was totally fine he was like probably
the most collected out of most people
there uh but i did a little bit more and
ashton did a little bit more
and he was
he was even [__] up
at this point because he did more than
me when we when we like redosed it he i
remember he chopped up quite a few lines
and i only did like one of them one and
a half more uh but even then that was
enough to almost completely k-hole me at
that point and when you do a lot i feel
like ketamine takes a little bit to set
in because everything is slow mode so no
matter how quick it sets in it feels
like it's taking a while almost and i
remember my buddy don uh the one i kept
asking if he was good to drive when he i
guess he was he drove the car back um
was he doing a deal with you guys
yeah he did a little bit but he he
insisted he's good to drive and i
trusted him i was like you know what
drive my damn car i can't drive it was
snowing out and [__] it was like the
worst driving conditions
oh bad it was like snowing out it was
brutal dude
classic illinois weather yeah yeah so um
so we're like we're we leave this house
eventually because uh after a few hours
you can kind of come out of the k hole
uh enough to be coherent and
obviously those girls didn't drive there
i don't know how the [__] they got there
um her friends were there when we got
there i didn't ask questions about that
i was just like all right you people are
standing we're heading out of here right
so
they leave i'm pretty sure one of them
bought more ketamine from ashton yeah i
don't know why he sold it to him but
that's not my business you know uh
but it happened you know i think one of
them bought a little more because they
liked it and then we left and i just
remember getting back to my house and
trying to get up my stairs
and at this point i had you know when
you're on k it's almost like your
thoughts don't connect with your actions
it's like you're thinking you want to do
something but your body isn't doing that
like you're like okay i want to go up
the stairs but your legs aren't [__]
going or you're like
oh i want to uh get out of bed but
you're [__] stuck like truly truly
stuck you're glued to the bed you you
almost can't function normally
and when you try to speak
you're gonna [__] it up pretty much
every time that's kind of how k is and
even i with my tolerance at this point
was completely k-hold so i went into my
room and this is before luckily my mom
got home from work so i just like laid
in my room and tried to go to sleep and
i was like yo if my mom doesn't come in
and talk to me and hear my [__]
absolutely k hold like
oh guys
right now yeah
then i'm good
i'm a drug cousin so i'm laying in the
head
yeah
i'm laying in my [__] room and i'm
like oh my [__] god man i can't let
her come in i turn my lights off trying
to act like i'm asleep and [__] you know
uh just doing whatever i can and it
actually works she didn't come in so
i was like
totally unable to sleep at first
and
the girl danielle
she called me on facetime and she was
like i can't see
can you tell me if my room is clean she
can't see
yeah she was like so cait up that she
couldn't see i guess she like i believe
she could because she facetimed me
somehow but like she was so cute up her
her thoughts weren't connecting with
what was happening she convinced herself
she couldn't [__] see at all
which i mean to be fair everything looks
[__] up in your own case so i believe
it i believe it you you don't really
process what you're seeing like your
brain doesn't look at something and say
that's close or that's dirty or clean
you don't you know
whoa your brain works super different
yeah
it is it's fun in light doses because
it's a different drug it's almost like
being uh really really cross-faded and
like lit uh it's got like a little bit
of that serotonin like that that molly
feeling combined with being drunk and
stoned at the same time in small doses
it's fun but in high doses it's a
completely different drug and there's a
very thin line that you cross to get to
that like k-hole phase
it's it's kind of [__]
ugh so she can't see yeah so she called
and she was like
i can't [__] see my room can you tell
me if it's clean and she's pointing her
camera like all around on the [__]
walls on the ceiling and [__] and i'm
like yeah
looks reasonably clean in there you know
like [__] yeah i can't try one of those
red ones yeah [__] yeah that
was fun oh god oh i've gotta there we go
did you see her room was clean
it was clean
so i didn't know that
that was it
she [__] no so
she hung up
and i guess her parents came home
there's still a few people over there
who were like completely chaoled in her
house her parents came home
and she's like freaking the [__] out
and she's like texting me about it and
[__] and i'm like so okay hold that i
can't type back i'm like processing
what's on my lock screen but like i i
don't understand how to respond to it my
[__] mom comes home
like in the middle of me laying on the
bed
and
i was like so terrified she was gonna
come in so i'm laying there and it was
the worst case experience ever because
i'm sitting there and i'm like dude if
she comes in i can't even say hello
like
i'm brutal i tried to sit there like not
making any noise for the longest time
and i'm like dude i just want to talk
some homies or something because like i
was so careful that i was freaking out a
little bit i was like scared man
i was scared bro i was sitting there and
i was like dude i need to take my mind
off this because i was i'd never been
that [__] up on k before like it hit
so slowly over time
i started to really get hold and i was
like bro this is [__] because at first
it was so light and it was like oh
whatever but
k is one of those things where it hits
you slowly you know like it just like
smacks you
so like you can imagine that feeling in
my [__] hand i did like two and a
half lines that day which is so much
ketamine like that's enough to [__]
knock your ass out and i slept like a
baby that night you know but
it was brutal dude
sounds horrible it was brutal dude it
was i i ended up throwing up later in
the night
but like
i couldn't go to the bathroom because i
want to wake my mom up she had to like
do it in a trash bin and then later i
snuck out onto my lawn and i threw the
trash bin into like my neighbor's
garbage man in the driveway
he was like where the [__] is the trash
man i was like i have no damn idea like
that's honestly crazy in the same show i
threw in the neighborhood yeah i was
like that's honestly i have no clue but
they're kid [__] he threw up i was
like still a little like i i'd recovered
somewhat from the cave and i like woke
up and i was like dude
sounds like yeah in this [__] room
you know i was like oh my god
i puked in the garbage bin earlier you
know so i like i grabbed it and i just
snuck out of my house and [__]
threw it in the neighbor's garbage man
it was [__] exactly what i would have
done yeah 100
yeah i i had to leave my room eventually
and then i i recouped but yeah bad night
i've never done it it sounds kind of fun
it's small i mean it does sound kind of
funny but i don't think i'm good i had
too much [__] to do to feel like that
yeah i ate mushrooms the other day my
whole day's over you know the more i
think about it that that little bike my
friend wrote over it might have even
been motorized because i remember you
would talk about how like would modify
it a motorized tricycle i don't remember
if it was motorized or not
i just know he wrote that [__] all the
time and he he kept insisting on how it
was better than a skateboard
he would ride a skateboard sometimes too
but i i i just remember him riding this
stupid [__] thing
he'd be like bro
yeah try one of these [__] what is it
he's
yo
so i'm pretty high i'm pretty big bro
pretty damn high marty what time are we
at right now 2 30.
2 30. doing pretty good we are we're
actually killing it right now we're
doing pretty good we're doing fantastic
you ready i got two i got two more
things left okay out there two things
left two more things on this list
actually three but okay two stories that
i wanted to hear from wow you ready wow
all's it says i'm just gonna say it
undercover
i don't want to say too much oh
man
so this is oh
this was a bad one man
i got arrested on my birthday
uh my 17th
i believe yeah it was my 17th um i had
lost my phone in a forest preserve
yeah i was walking with a couple friends
uh i was smoking weed uh and i lost my
phone like in the snow it was really bad
but somehow it still worked i had a case
on it so i guess maybe
that's how but back when i was younger i
was dumb
and
like i i was talking to you about
earlier i sold a little bit of weed here
and there to like maintain my habit um
and i had sold
you know enough to have people like
text me you know fairly often asking if
i had like any butt or like a card or
something so when i lost my phone i
guess a forest like ranger found it or
something and i had text because i
didn't i didn't have like the you know
hide the preview settings you'll see yes
you could see what someone texted me
when i was younger and they saw that
like
you know i was [__] getting weed i
don't know how they did this though so
i texted
um well actually i i know how i didn't
have the previews on uh but they texted
me back i texted my own number from my
friend kyle's phone i was like yeah let
me let me hit them up so uh i texted
their number and i was like hey
so i don't have this phone it delivered
so i was like oh [__] bro like someone's
gotta have this [__] thing
and i got a response from a different
number that was like hey i have your
phone you know and they they said like
some name they're like oh yeah you know
i found your phone like on the force
preserver i was like oh i was there you
know like that makes sense that must be
where i lost that's where i thought i
lost it because when i realized it was
missing i [__] went back and like
looked for it that same day um
couldn't find it though
they texted me they're like oh like uh i
found your phone they were like we can
meet up like at the forest preserve or
something and yeah back at the place
yeah so i was like federal grounds well
i was like okay whatever they just wanna
give me i was like whatever at first it
was fine they asked me like oh by the
way i told me to be weird but i saw a
text about you selling weed
uh can't get some and i was like
i i don't know man got a new friend i
was like maybe yeah i mean
maybe dude i just want my phone back
first then we can you know
do whatever but like i just that's the
main thing i said i was like i just want
my phone back first but then it got
really sketchy
and he asked for coke
and i was like no i can't
like i can't really that's when i kind
of knew it was [__] i was like no i
can't do that i can't do weed either i
just want my phone actually
that's what i said but at this point
i was still really dumb about it still
didn't like how many days later did they
hit you up
no so
this is lost it and when did they get
you up like yo oh oh it was like
probably a week oh [__] maybe a week
pretty pretty soon after
but um
this this happened about a week later
and
they uh
i i was talking i was like no i can't do
that [__] i don't have any of that i'm
just going to meet up with you
and get my phone so i got a ride because
my friend kyle didn't have a car so i
got picked up by these two other kids
that i knew back in high school
uh and i didn't realize all the [__]
they had in their car
i knew they had a little bit of weed but
i didn't realize how like much other
illegal they had like open liquor and
[__] i didn't realize they had all this
in their car and they dropped you there
yeah they drove me there uh and i was
like yo i don't even have anything on me
so what are they gonna do bro you know
like
i don't even have anything like i just
need my [__] phone back because
literally i don't have money for anyone
like i was going i was literally using
like a text now app on my computer at
home to hit people up and i needed a
cell phone you know like i i don't know
i was dumb i was eight i should have
just waited to buy a new one but i was
desperate because like this [__]
belonged to my mom
so like i was like bro she's gonna beat
my [__] ass if i don't get this [__]
back
so
i go there
and i'm like walking and this cop pulls
in
and they pull up and get stopped the car
and one of them walks up to me and he's
like hey
he at first he says some [__] he's like
hey we're
we're looking for a lost dog
and like he's trying to talk to me to
like i don't know i guess like see what
i'm there for
and i'm like oh i [__] saw a dog it
was this way i'm trying to get him to go
away so i can just [__] leave i was
like bro i'm gonna like run at this
point you know
um
and he walks up to me
and they go up to the car i guess they
watched us come in right because i
texted the number off another one of my
friend's phones i was like yo like i'm
coming in right they watched the car
come in so they came up to their car and
they like stopped us like i don't know
what reason they gave to like look
through the [__] in the car
i don't remember what the [__] it was
but they searched the car and found like
weed in there alcohol uh i guess like
there was some speed trap set up like
some little park ranger waiting for us
you know and the person we were texting
was obviously a same person because the
cops did have my phone um my mom had to
like apply to get it back and still
never got it back
um but
i got
like arrested on my but not like fully
arrested like i didn't go to [__]
jail and [__] you know what they do but
um they they ticketed all of us they
like since i was a minor it was much
different than if it would have happened
like when i was adult uh if i didn't
have anyone to pick me up they would
have had to like actually arrest me but
my mom picked me up so they just gave me
a bunch of tickets but i didn't realize
the [__] my friends had in the car i
thought i was riding like clean you know
i was like bro who care what can they
even do you know like i just want to get
my phone
but they searched the car
and they found all that [__] and then i
never got my phone
and after that it was like i literally
only i i don't know exactly what i got
because i never got my phone back but
i'd imagine i only got a few texts for a
week because i wasn't selling any other
[__] at that point you know they're so
sword
i would i imagine i only got maybe two
or three texts for wheat i didn't even
sell much i would buy like a zip at a
time you know i'd sell [__] eight
sting operations they did a stinger they
just sting out for eighths
they did a sting out for a zip teenagers
and an ounce yes they did a sting out
for a zip
they told me bro when i was walking to
the car the most [__] up part they
like so i had my friend's phone right
they were like yeah like you know bring
it back to like text them
and they said they were in a [__]
black suburban and i was like oh i'm
going to prison
i was like what car are you in they said
black suburban i was like oh [__] and
there was one parked there one like they
had a bunch of cops for some reason bro
they thought i was like like i don't
know who the hell they thought i was bro
but
they never gave me they never gave my
phone back and like soon after this um a
couple months later cops came to my
house
and they were asking me about like
someone i knew right one of my friends
and they were like my mom brought up the
phone thing and i was like mom why'd you
even let him in the [__] house you
know like why'd you like let them in
she's like ah you know
my mom used to like
really do that [__] like she'd like if
cops came she'd always tell them
everything and let them in you know she
was like that so i was like i could
never get away with [__] if cops were
involved you know like it was brutal
like my p.o
[__] knew everything
knew everything so um
like after this happened
cops came to my house a few months later
my mom brought up the phone thing and
they were like asking me because like
the person they were asking me about
sold a lot of weed like a shitload of
weed they asked me they were like oh do
you like sell drugs and stuff and like
that's what they asked you yeah yeah
some crimes they were in my dining room
bro and i was like no dude i actually
did a live stream where i read a lot of
my arrest reports i like blurred them
out because um i submitted one of those
like information requests you know uh
for the county that i grew up in and
they sent me originally i only requested
my mugshot for my dui because i wanted
to put it on my merch yeah they gave me
every single piece of paper and mug shot
and picture affiliated with any time
i've ever encountered police even like
police reports all that [__] police like
officers different perspectives and like
notes on like the same event
everything i have 85 pages from one
county bomb yeah they would you find
everything um
so one of the things i found out from
that is i found out that one of my
friends told on me
when i i never uh knew about it when i
was younger
wanna so remember when i told you about
that burglary thing earlier
so
how we got caught on that did i talk
about in trouble off that
yeah
oh yeah the garage oh sorry i thought
you were talking about when your friend
got robbed no no the garage thing the
garage yes the garage thing yeah your
license plate so
when we got in trouble originally i just
thought like oh they they traced my
plate which they did
but
the reason that they knew i was like for
sure involved and what really happened
is because after the cops came to my
house i called my friend right
i one of my friends was in the car and i
told him hey
cops came to my house you know like what
what do you think we should do
we discussed it a little bit
and he was like obviously nervous and he
hung up on me and he claimed what
happened was his mom overheard our
conversation on skype right
because i called him on skype he claimed
his mom overheard it which he used
speakers i knew that he didn't have a
headset so i kind of believed it but
what he claimed was his mom overheard it
on skype and called the cops
at the time i've been friends with this
guy since kindergarten like we were five
years old so i believed it i was like
okay that's my homie so
later when i got this report i found out
that what really happened was he got
nervous like he got scared after hearing
that he was like oh i don't want to go
to jail and he told his parents and they
brought him to the police station and
that's that's why they were like on me
and they called my phone number they
gave them my phone number so they called
me and they're like yo
bring the [__] like that you stole and
i'm sitting there and i'm like what are
you talking about
like i i at first i was like no shot bro
like this has got to be something like
gamer like [__] this you know i was like
what are you talking about uh and then
finally my friend called me and he was
like hey like
bring this [__] you know like
and it turned out when i read the arrest
report
he like he got scared and told them
everything
like he went to the police station and
told them everything that happened
so that's the only reason that any of us
got caught and that blew me because for
the longest time i just believed him
looking back at it i shouldn't have it
was stupid his explanation yeah it made
no sense
but he was just my friend for so long
that i felt like i had to believe him
how much longer until you found out that
he was lying when you got there um a
good four or five years you still hang
out with him when you do that sometimes
yeah i i i honestly have spent so long
i'm not that mad about it because i was
so young it was actually my first ever
criminal offense so i got off really
easy i got like some court supervision
[__] and some community service
that's it um
[Music]
14 15. yeah yeah i was like i was like
16 just freshly turned i'm pretty sure
but um
yeah no i got off pretty easy on that so
when i found out about that i wasn't as
mad as it been a long time but i was
still pretty pissed and i did bring it
up to him you did yeah oh [__] yeah i
brought it up we were we were actually
playing the game tonight yeah
i was like so yeah i heard you told on
me
i was like i found out you told me he's
like what are you talking about
you know and i was like dude i got our
arrest reports for a video um
and i found out that she told on me
and
at first he kind of denied it and he's
like yo like we were young dude i'm
sorry you know like all that kind of
[__] and i was like you know i didn't go
to [__] jail like it's not like he
got probation i don't really it's not
like he got a felony even like whatever
it got expunged off my record when i did
the service so it wasn't the end of the
world so i wasn't that upset about
it but still oh yeah it's still good it
blew me dude i was so mad about it i was
so mad about that [__]
like
i wasn't mad at him but i was more i was
more trying to do that to me like i
wasn't mad at current him i was just
like i was blown more yeah i was in
disbelief you know i was like [__]
dude that's so [__] wild uh did you
ever watch did you ever watch wwf or wwe
when you were a kid yeah actually i
loved that [__] okay i played all the
games too
yeah of course austin 360 is still
called stunner yeah yeah so you kick a
[__] in the stomach
you
bam you still get stuttering yeah you
know the sixth grade i started doing
that to all the kids in my class oh
that's right recess i had this kid named
chad and he would distract him
and they'd turn around i'd go bam and
i'd really do it all the way to the
ground i sit down it hurt myself
but we like and we get up like
it was just wrestling that's fire though
then i got in trouble i got called in
principal's office one day
and somebody told on us that we were
doing this really and i didn't lie i go
yeah i did and he was just like what the
[__] he didn't lie to me he's like chad
didn't lie to me either
like so you guys just like wrestling
like yeah we're not hurting people i got
in-house suspension all that [__]
i didn't find out until seven years
later who told us the way you talking
about it yeah how'd you find out
we were talking to one of my friends and
he brings it up that
it was one of our good friends really
his older sister thought we were [__]
beating up her little brother it's his
older sister saw it and went
nah and went and snitched on us because
we were just [__] around wow but i
found out years and he knew and he never
said shh wow
i never even brought it up to him but
wow
not a seriousness that's [__] up
no yeah that's true that's so [__]
did you bring it up to him like did you
i didn't really hang out with them as i
was like in 12th grade okay i found out
yeah it was the last week at school
and i found out it's like bro this was
in sixth [__] grade
still sometimes that [__] just blows you
no matter how long ago it was dude it
just changes everything like you're like
holy [__]
past six years have been a lie yeah
it changes everything like for real it
truly does um so you're a homie
uh
confessed
and you guys are still friends
um yeah yeah we're pretty good friends
still i mean it wasn't really the end of
the world but it it just blew me that
he'd do that because i was like damn
dude
i get it i don't think i mean i get it
too like i get you were nervous it was
we've never done something like that we
were kids you know and that's why like
we're still friends like you're a little
kid yeah like whatever we were stupid
dude yeah you were stronger on robbery
yeah i mean i didn't really expect this
to be like a bank robbery to your team
you know like
we were we were [__] 15 16. um
i i did so much goon [__] because i was
one of the first my friends to get a car
so like i everything yeah
i was doing some [__] [__] i got this
this little two-door honda accord
doing the work and i
did any and everything the first day i
got it i backed into a car at the mall
yeah and dipped because like
i
in it it didn't fall down but i got a
good indent and it's trying to cover it
i tried to cover it with black duct tape
because my car was black i was like dude
if we just tape it it'll look straight
from an angle you know like it won't
look indented we just have to put tape
over the little indent yeah so we
[__] did that and of course my
parents found that [__] they were super
pissed but like
i still had the car until eventually i
crashed that thing into a tree
i i bent it around a tree when i was
racing through a neighborhood with a
friend of mine
uh you put like 50 bucks on like who
could race through this neighborhood
faster and i came around a quarter when
it was raining and i slid sideways i
kind of fishtailed and slid to a tree
like bent my car around it and i had a
friend and shotgun yeah his girlfriend
did his lap actually
they were okay actually
no one was really hurt
but you wrapped the car yeah i [__]
you weren't hurt either oh i i was hurt
emotionally i totaled the car
but no i was fine physically somehow
because the car was [__] where the
windshield was like all cracked the car
was bent it was like it was shaped like
a boomerang the way it slid to the tree
you guys were fine yeah you're
completely fine they climbed out of the
car caught my friend's car and they took
all the weed and laughed
they were like yeah yeah you know they
got my friend's car left and i was like
i'll stay here you know it's my car
obviously i gotta [__] stay here uh
and i like called my mom and i was like
momma crash the whip you know
because at that point it's like dude i
can't not
tell her
you know like yeah i can't hide this bro
like how do i come home with no car like
how do i explain this like yeah the
keep paying the bill but yeah the car is
gone you know like oh
there's no way to explain that no
there's not
none that's another so that's another
fear yeah they took me to the hospital
like because it was a requirement
because i was a minor uh you [__] up
no not really let me like drunk or
anything i was a little buzzed not drunk
at all though so they didn't even
question
no they didn't question me at all they
didn't breathalyze me or anything they
didn't think i was [__] up because i i
really wasn't i was just a dumbass like
i was raining i [__] slipped yeah
yeah i fished hailed and i slid uh and i
just couldn't get away from the tree
bent around the tree it was bad
[__] that's my first car dude that thing
was i love that thing that was the one i
lived in um that was the one i lived in
yeah i had it um
bumper sticker i live in here i had it a
long time dude i had it like
over a year like a year and a half not
that yourself that's not super long but
like long for for me at the time yeah
because
i crashed a lot of cars have you yeah oh
yeah you're safe yeah i am now i haven't
gotten in a car accident in like four
years five years
um but when i was younger and i did a
lot of drugs i would drive [__] up
like a dumbass so
i would get in a lot of accidents
um so i totaled
um a mazda
3.
uh i rear-ended someone
so the car i don't really think it was
like super totaled um but it
the i [__] up the front like wheel
well the way i hit the person um because
they cut into the lane in front of me
and i was really tired kind of falling
asleep yeah um i hadn't slept the night
before i was super slump and i just
smoked a blunt and i was driving back to
my house to go to sleep um but i i just
couldn't [__] like keep myself awake
enough and this guy got in the lane in
front of me and i noticed too late and
rear-ended him um
and i [__] up my car
it was actually a guy on a motorcycle
it was bad yeah yeah it was bad he was
okay he was okay he didn't have any like
permanent damage he was fine
it's not the speed i hit him that was
bad it was the angle as you get the
angle motorcycle yeah yeah i felt i feel
a little bad about him
i didn't almost kill him he was fine um
but his bike was not his bike was gonna
fly off
a little bit you had unless you just
barely [__] left it a little bit
little little fling but you play enough
gta to know what a [__] does
yeah you need that back wheel
i felt really bad about that but um yeah
i um
that happened and that's how i totaled
my other car it wasn't like i had him
going like
i'd break a good bit before but i still
hit him going like probably 20.
which like yeah that's like enough to
definitely yeah [__] up the bike so fast
yeah like 50 yeah i had i had a yeah
you ever tried to run alongside a car 20
is fast for you for getting hit 20's
fast yeah that is but no the guy was
like pretty surprisingly actually okay
but the the
uh what he was the bike he was almost
[__] did he freak out or
he was
cooler than he probably could have been
honestly
um i mean i was also i was just saying
sorry i mean i was like yo i'm so like
holy because when it first happened i
was sitting there i was like yo holy
[__] because like i'm sitting there like
bro did i just like kill this dude like
obviously looking back at it like that
didn't like that wouldn't [__] really
kill anyone he didn't like fly off he
just kind of like you know
he like got flunked forward a little bit
but he didn't like do a [__] you know
like 20 feet up
um but i was sitting there and i was
like oh my god bro like i really just
hurt somebody you know um
he got up and walked fine like he was
okay but i was sitting there and i was
like holy [__] um and i felt terrible
about that one i i remember for a while
i didn't drive after that one hey
because i didn't have a car but b like
cause i was like [__] bro like i was
tweaking about that [__]
um
you lucked out sir
yeah
after that i didn't drive for a while uh
i didn't lose my license or anything but
i didn't drive for a while um
[Music]
because the thing that saved me was they
had a witness and the cop asked the guy
was like did he try to break and he's
like yeah cause like i pulled my e-brake
and [__] i was like you know oh [__]
that's the only reason he was like
probably okay because i noticed like
before it happened i was like oh [__]
you know uh that was bad that was a
[__] one
as a [__] one
a lot of car accident stories on this
[__] episode in this episode on this
show really she's talked about multiple
have you been in some real bad ones yeah
i've been in some [__] horrible
accidents not in a super long time i had
a stretch of them kind of back to back
really yeah slamming into medians mainly
that was kind of the thing oh man
slamming into people with other
accidents not always like me driving
yeah people hitting us [__] like that i
don't know what it was
it's just dude last year [__] my
cousin adrian i don't know how he had
such a crazy year
first he's backing in this crazy story i
don't know really my cousin agent is
backing his truck up into his driveway
and on this road
it's a straight road merced you have to
look
unless you're doing this
you're not going to not see a car in the
way okay and my cousin's got his friend
outside like guiding him back and [__]
like that
and
this full on a motorcycle just goes like
65 never stops oh it just goes right in
the side of my cousin oh
[__] just flies into pieces and [__]
oh my god are my cousins just sitting
there like what did they die yeah yeah
i'd imagine at that speed i [__] died
yeah oh my cousin's just sitting there
with a [__] right away
and
not even the right way just completely
thinking everything's fine his friend is
like looking at the motorcycle guy like
no he's gonna stop
it's traffic you have to stop yeah and
when he said he saw him yeah he was like
at least 200 yards away but the guy was
just [__] taken off with him like he
never even it was in the day
like he never even saw the truck that's
[__] [__] crazy that's [__] man
my guys have found hella like [__]
parts and [__] all over oh it was sad
man yeah that's terrible it was awful
then [__] what two weeks later i get
a call
he's doing my cousin andrew does the
moves
my brother
is doing a move with him and he's behind
my cousin just happens to be recording
because it's such bad weather yep
and my [__] cousin loose tractions on
the snow on the mountain oh just hits a
ramp of snow you just see him fly off
the couch
just disappears off a cliff and they
look down and he's like 40 yards down in
a tree just perfectly fine
all in like a month
damn he was fine he was fine how was the
car totaled
but fine
nothing wrong like he got out on his own
he was fine i remember there was my
brother said the car was this that's an
advertisement it was a f-150 oh wow but
my brother he's like i got out thinking
like holy [__] agent just died in front
of me and he's like yo from down there
that must have been the most relieving
moment ever on video he has this
just happened to record he's like yo
this is crazy oh [__] and it goes off a
cliff
it's crazy oh my god it's pretty wild
but all that [__] happened with you guys
are talking about this crazy [__] no
that's the motorcycle yeah oh [__] yeah
dude it's so as we say every episode be
safe drive safe be careful for real i
learned that eventually the hard way
because i used to be a dumbass and i
drive on all sorts of [__] but as i got
older like especially after my dui i was
like yeah like it's not worth it i don't
i've for i've never driven drunk since
then i don't really even drive when i'm
super stoned like i just don't have [__]
bro yeah like why why even leave your
house you get instacart licks
why why do you even need to leave if you
leave you have uber yeah yeah
yeah
like the gas stations within walking
distance to my house i don't even need
to uber
they just walk there
i don't know dude we talk about it every
[__] episode because we get so many
dms like yo i total my car listen to the
episode
gotten like
30. really
a lot of people crash every day it's
crazy yeah no it is dude it's crazy i've
been in so many actions where like i
didn't even get total like i got t-boned
coming out of work one time i've been
rear-ended i've done the re-ending and
fled um and fled you know i mean
it's like the [__] liar liar scene
oh oh running a red light and speeding
there was one where i like love to have
some like lady at a light and she like
kind of waved me on to like follow her
so i did and she went to this parking
lot i just gunned it
i was like i'm gone you're a [__] out
there some ladies like that's him
yeah
innocent boy she's gonna see this
someday like this [__] dude
she might know
oh sorry
um i don't know how we got on to that
but you ready i got one more all right
let's hear it
i will just say getting suspended
because the second part is [__]
hilarious yeah so
uh i've talked about this one on a few
streams i think but
uh i got caught
well all right we got caught
i had a friend who used to pick me up in
the mornings and drive me to school
instead of taking the bus because when
this girl would pick me up it was like a
free uber and she'd take me to walgreens
to go steal liquor because walgreens
used to have hennessy yeah walgreens
would open at 7 00 am and they'd have
fantasy bottles with no alarm on them so
you could take that [__] just leave and
i would just take it and just walk out
as fast as i could because normally
they'd have like some old-ass man behind
the register what's he gonna do chase me
you know like yeah i don't know i you
know i i never got like physical with it
like if someone kind of my way i'm like
okay you got me but uh i had friends who
like push people out of the way and [__]
that i i drew the line at that though
but that would never happen at walgreens
so i would go in and grab a bottle and
just [__] leave and i did that this
morning
and we were drinking a little bit of
hennessy i was drinking quite a bit and
this girl named tiffany hit us up and
asked us to pick her up uh so we went
over to her house i called her tina in
my videos because she she liked to tweak
uh sometimes on some hard [__]
not necessarily meth but
anything else under the sun um but she
was a fun time she's a she was a fun
person so we went and picked her up and
she brought we didn't realize she had
that she had like a crack pipe that she
was taking dabs out of but wait of hash
no i'm just like like kind of like
shatter oh okay so yeah yeah yeah she
was like hitting the bottom of it like
dropping dabs and [__] um
are those little little pieces of the
circle at the end of those cracker meth
this is that's a meth pipe meth pipe my
bad either way yeah yeah little meth
pipe but she had that right um
and
she she had brought that we didn't
realize she had that because she just
brought a couple zans with her and
that's all we thought she had you know
you guys are going to school yeah like 7
a.m we go to i i would go to school off
acid molly i'd take your [__] in the
bathroom you guys have that much time
between i pick you up let's go well we
missed our first period quite often
thank you yeah okay you guys left with
me we would come in as late as we wanted
because i went so i went to this
alternative school where they didn't
assign homework
it was like a like a like a playground
you could go in there as [__] up as
you wanted we had a streak during my uh
my junior year but we had about an
overdose a week where we'd have a nice
ambulance come through
people wouldn't die uh overdose of what
oh it depended there was there was a lot
of fake sands going around my school so
there's west there's some kid who took
too many like passed out in gym class
one day um
my friend had a cardiac arrest in
history class um
like there's been a lot of [__] that
happened at that school because it was
it's so boring out there people do hella
drugs out there like midwest i hear so
boring dude people just do pills and
that's why uh
opiates are so the sober activities you
want you can do in suburbian midwest if
you're outside of chicago
or a big city in general you go to a
movie theater you sit in a parking lot
and smoke or you maybe go to a
restaurant but that gets really old
really fast you know because that's all
there is to [__] do man maybe you
find a goddamn topgolf you know that's
like the extent of your fun there's like
a six flags nearby maybe yeah but even
then when you're young you'll got the
kind of money to go there a lot you know
so
i mean
everyone does drugs out there especially
at the school i went to because
i i grew up
in a pretty good school district right
so
they would try to pad the graduation
rate by sending all the kids who were
going to flunk out to a school where
they had no homework and they couldn't
fail
it was it was a clever little system
it's called valley yeah yeah yeah every
district has one i feel like you know
yeah um but at that squad did hell of
[__] and on this day we we took a couple
zans and i drank so i was [__] up
and i guess uh they
they found out because one of my friends
the girl who drove us she was way too
[__] up by the time we got there and
this school like everyone did drugs at
this school so they were pretty like hip
to it like they knew how to spot when
someone was [__] up and because it was
a much smaller school total of maybe 100
kids whole building right so
it was a much smaller school so they'd
pick up on that way easier so one of the
girl who drove us to school was like too
[__] up and they have cameras
everywhere and they knew that like i
always came to school with her and [__]
so they searched her car they like
called her to the office and search
their car and they found the crack pipe
the meth pipe pardon me um
in in the girl's bag in tiffany's bag
right so they bring all of us to the
office they like look at the camera see
us come in together they bring all of us
to the office and we all get suspended
for it and i'm [__] up at this point i
get called in and i'm still substituted
i'm absolutely blasted at this point so
they call me in and i'm sitting there
and they're just like we found the
bottle and all that like if you want
like we can breathalyze you and i'm like
no you got me dude
like you don't have to breathalyze me
i'm suited you know
like i promise you got me you know let's
skip the [__] [__]
what's gonna happen such a defense they
just spend to me not that long for two
days because the girl
so luckily the girl who had the pipe
confessed to it so what happened to her
uh good honor you know she was a cool
person like i said so what happened is
she got transferred to a school that was
notorious in my district because you had
to sign a waiver allowing the teachers
to get physical with you
yeah yeah like the teachers would beat
your ass if you got in a fight bro they
could scrap like if you swung on a
teacher they had like you had to sign a
waiver it's just like yeah that teacher
could fight back you know like they'd
they wear this if you're fighting they'd
come tackle your ass like that wasn't my
school but that was the school she got
sent off to because of this incident
you guys are in the 70s in illinois
apparently dude it was it was honestly
so funny because that school was
notorious
i knew another kid who went there uh
he was really [__] though that kid was
crazy he like
i think he called in like a bomb threat
or some [__] so they sent his ass there
but yeah it's all the bad kids no it's
all the real
max security bad kids bro all the really
funny you just have a girl that likes
hash yeah and then like some girl who
like smokes every now and then you know
she might smoke a little funky something
but i mean whatever life is life uh what
are you gonna do
that's true where does a meth addict
find one of those [__] meth pipes the
[__] head shops
oh gas stations in illinois gas stations
yeah they sell them everywhere you can
get them at a gas station they're not
called meth pipe but i mean i know they
sell like the little trick things like
little crack pipes like in the [__]
little rose things or whatever
but i'm saying like a meth pipe seems
like it's a [__] meth pipe what else
is it like no they're called oil burners
i mean the thing is you you can smoke a
hash out of it yeah you can you can dab
out of those [__] that's where i told
you the first time i saw dabbing i
walked in and jeebus was hitting a
[__] torch lighter and twisting this
pipe and i [__] started screaming at
him
i thought my homie was doing [__]
meth when i walked in yeah i was so
[__] mad it was what and then i was
oh it's oh it's that
oh this is cool daddy yeah now it's dope
that's cool
but i was pissed yeah it's a metaphor
called oil burners justin from texas he
sells a million today oh i gotcha that's
crazy people smoke man people tweak dude
in my town you go to smoke
shops and at this are whip it's big out
here
balloons oh yes sir i don't like them i
don't like this i don't i don't do that
[__] but all these smoke shops in in
anywhere like rural illinois or like
central illinois something like that you
go in these smoke shops and they have a
whole shelf that's just dedicated to
whippets oh for sure like there's
nothing to do yes it's crazy to me
though because people buy that [__] uh i
have a friend actually my roommate cody
he works at a smoke shop and he tells me
he's like dude one of the top sellers in
our store is [__] whippets
it's because people are like
they sell like damn you more weapons and
vapes sad yeah
i get i get a lot of comments about it
too like people always ask me like oh
god but what do you think of that [__]
i'm like dude
so [__]
that's not fun dude when i was a kid
there's nothing to do we made our
homemade whippets have you ever done
like
all right you ever done it out of a
whipped cream can no so what my friend
used to do his version there because who
can afford whipped cream yeah you can
steal it
i never yeah yeah anyway we're at his
house right his house
my friend got a towel and then doubled
the towel over okay
and then sprayed remember those glade
[__] powerful air fresheners yes
i use those at my house
i just
hit it for like 10 seconds i would just
get so [__] [__] up for 15 seconds
and i'd come back like i no i can't huff
somebody bro
[__] i've done it like 30 times oh
no lie it's like dumb as [__] i mean the
worst thing is when you forget
and then to move it off the wet spot and
it just peeks through i've gotten so
much floral taste in my oh i'm like oh
go to this dress how long does that last
in your mouth dude probably probably
forever
but i smoked something like oh what else
can i do
so being a little
in the
a kid with no money is like [__]
having nothing
no matter where you're from there's
always that town in that county of like
there's nothing yes to [__] do but
drugs you get [__] up or you do
nothing oh you do nothing yeah yeah for
real
so we're all like
yeah we've come full circle
from buffalo to
illinois to l.a or to merced
[__]
so real quick one more thing yeah
when you left here last time we were
talking about your merch and since
you've left you've been dropping the
[__] out of some [__] i have been yeah i
uh so i finally got my own domain and my
own like website and everything um i'm
working with a new company now because
the one i was working with before i had
some like shipping issues with where a
lot of people just weren't getting their
[__] on time um
and also just like some quality control
stuff yeah and i got uh before i
i lost a cut like of the income from the
merch they took a cut of the profit but
now i work with a company that produces
it themselves so i just you know cover
production cost and that's it um which
is way better yeah and i'm able to price
my merch at cheaper now too because of
that like i do 20 t-shirts and [__] now
you know that kind of [__] um
which is pretty dope yeah but yeah i've
been dropping a lot of crazy [__] i'm
getting ready to do glass actually
i've been working on that so i haven't
really locked anything in like all the
way yet but
in mind i like
so
i've been looking at doing some bongs
that have like my logos kind of in the
bottom so when you clear it you see like
the goblin logo and i want to do some
real thick [__] like some nine
millimeter [__] some really like quality
like beakers and and dab rigs and [__]
like that you know um but i'm still in
the phase where like i have to like get
samples and test [__] and like this are
you trying to stay in america um
preferably yeah but
i i'm pricing accordingly so stuff
that's not from america is not gonna
cost as much you know but i'm trying to
stay in america
it's really hard to stay in the u.s
because glassblowers here they're
they're doing their own thing the real
good ones they don't do that [__] like
it's really hard to find someone who's
talented and willing to take that on you
know in production yeah it's really
tough i'm working with a few people i
mean i'm not gonna name any names or
anything cause it's so early yeah but um
i plan on doing a mix of both you know i
mean obviously it's going to be like
clear whether it's import or whether
it's american um
but yeah that's that's kind of what i've
been working on lately you know okay
obviously you just drop hell stuff yeah
i've been dropping a lot of a lot of new
merch because the the new company i'm
working with they can make [__]
anything dude sound like yeah let's do
some funny [__] i made aprons like these
little only gas cooking aprons
yeah um i've only sold like five or six
of them but that's like a niche item
yeah so like i don't care you know it's
like they're cool saw the
like you as a soldier was [__] yes
the war on drug [__] so i have a i have
a designer i work with on uh on a lot of
my designs like disney like disney
character yeah yeah no it's [__] dope
that's one of my favorites honestly yeah
that's one of my favorite ones but yeah
i've been i've been grinding the merch a
lot now that i got d monetized this
morning this morning
not this morning yesterday morning
actually like a day or two ago it was a
nice birthday gift for me [__] it it's
like yeah happy birthday get [__] up
get [__]
up [__] you
susan comes through for me man the first
podcast we did i just got demonetized we
were talking about this then too yup and
then you got it right back yep so here
we go but we'll see this time i mean
it's like they know you're coming on the
show or something yeah yeah they know
they're like yeah we gotta we gotta make
him bring this up again dude something
yeah that's the whole reason i came to
la cause i was just in vegas for [__]
nine days and oh i sleezed it out i got
so drunk i face planted the elevator
going back outside
i got [__] up but um
i i woke up one morning and i realized i
got demonetized and i was like dude wait
what do you do for nine days
get wasted and lose money you gamble
yeah oh that's why of course i hate them
in vegas i don't know i see so i wanted
to go when i was 21 but kovit just hit
um so i i couldn't go in 20 seconds same
thing at this point i'm like some places
are in that weird limbo where they're
like in between restrictions right now
so i'm gonna go while i can so i went
got ransacked absolutely
ruined at the casinos but it was fun it
was fun actually uh i had a good time i
just think i stayed for too long but i
woke up
yeah seven days too long i woke up the
uh the other morning and i i literally
had like a like a sixth sense moment you
know where like i i snapped out of
somebody's sleep at like 1 a.m and i
checked my [__] gmail and i just saw
the d monetization i was like god damn
it
i dude like god [__] your birthday no
yeah it was like the day after my
birthday i was like [__] off you know
i was so mad so i stayed i was like so
upset about it i stayed up for a little
bit i was like just pacing around the
room i was like god damn it you know um
and that's what drove me to come here
because i was like you know what
i'm gonna fly to la for a couple days
i'm i want to come get stoned have some
fun
whatever i mean i leave tomorrow at like
3 p.m so
[__]
still a bummer yeah yeah it is for real
it is a bummer but it's all right you
know
since the last time i've kind of worked
a lot more on like
making income from other sources like
i've i've tried to the reason i'm making
better merch and [__] and like dropping
more is obviously to like offset the
youtube stuff because
i mean i can't rely on the monetization
for income
youtube is so inconsistent with it you
know yeah and getting demonetized the
first time kind of taught me that you
know
you can't rely on that [__] like have
you ever been monetized
i was i've
yeah i was monetized for like a year
uh but they never gave me money really
yeah
why
it's my little bar was just gray
oh
you could see the money i never got to
get it
and you still to this day haven't gotten
any oh i'm completely demonetized i said
for life basically on there really you
can't even reapply no oh wow
wow
no for a long time they would say that
that's brutal i wasn't allowed to touch
it
and then it started saying like four
cents on seven eight million views yeah
dude that happened to me so my zoom
video
i got four and a half million views on
that i made about two hundred dollars
off that video should have got like 30
bands yeah exactly dude nowadays a
million views are worth more than ever a
million views is like [__] six
thousand dollars oh damn yeah
but like
with that [__]
especially like holiday season ads dude
holiday season ads are stupid
they're crazy i'm not monetized i don't
see [__] yeah no it it sucks when you're
not monetized you just watch these
banger videos just they put ads on them
and you don't see a penny because
i feel it's so dumb that they'll
demonetize it but just for you like they
still feel it's okay for ads just not
for you to profit from yes that's
exactly what that's so [__] it's
[__] up like if you're gonna
de-monetize it take all the ads off yeah
you know don't run ads for six months it
was only donald trump ads
yeah that's dude yeah it's crazy and you
can't even choose what kind of ads you
should you can't even choose what kind
of ads wrong
they're like [__] you dude who's gonna
put anything we [__] want on here i
got a [__] weed company ad on my
video while you've gotta monetize that's
gonna piss you off so much to have
another company just run in there like
10 cent ads she pissed me off i dude you
know what i get a lot of that's really
funny i get a lot of rehab ads
it's actually super it's like keywords
no it's it's fire it's super perfect
it's keywords i get i get a lot of rehab
ads dude i get a lot of comments like
dude i gotta add for a rehab facility
and like when i watch my videos on my
laptop or on my phone yeah yeah i'll be
getting those rehabilitations it's so
funny yeah it's fire actually
i hope they work
i hope they work yeah i hope people go
to rehab for real drugs are not good
they're not and that's why you're drug
free yeah yeah
20 22. where can everybody get your
merch out
oh goblin 420.com goblin spelled normal
yup justgoblin420.com
all right we'll
pop it up on the screen
goblin420.com yep goblin fork
oh you have so much [__] on there i have
a lot it's pretty are they drop shipping
for you yeah yeah they take care of it
they do the customer service we have a
dedicated email for that they have a
[__] phone number you can call oh
yeah it's sick don't call that just to
call it [__] yeah yeah call it
with a purpose yeah you know when people
do that [__] yeah dude somebody took our
number one so i promise people i
you know it's cool but i call it a
mistake because i promised every
purchase a thank you message because
that was the first year so there's yeah
there's this little app that comes with
my website right
that like oh i do audio ones where like
i like school yeah i like say like i'm
like yo what's up like whoever it is
like thank you for copying like i talked
to them because they get tired they can
write a message to me and then i respond
to it so i can like ask me something
like [__] like that so i like i made the
promise our videos everyone gets a
message and then i did more sales than
i've ever done in a month and now i'm
like way behind on messages every day
like that's a problem i have so yeah i
have some [__] many we should do
handwritten notes for everyone and it's
not like i can
just delete the videos that that's in
anymore you know i'm like i'm like
[Laughter]
[Music]
a [__] crazy promise yeah yeah i'm
like i think i'm like a good oh [__] bro
i probably have like over a thousand to
do
to do yeah
oh yeah because
so i the other day i put out a christmas
discount code of like 20
and like people just kind of went ape
[__] for that
because like i had some items where like
i don't know i tried to sell myself like
a good price right some items were like
20 was like my profit margin you know so
like i i had some items where like
people were buying t-shirts for example
bro i mean like a dollar like a t-shirt
at that point you know but like i got so
many [__] t-shirt cops that day that
like i'm just more behind now dude yeah
i guess this serves as my disclaimer
dude i'm lagging on them like it's okay
you can say right now i'm gonna stop
because i've decided on that yeah no i'm
gonna catch up one day
i'm gonna sit down one day i'm gonna
drink like eight coffees i'm gonna go
nuts
it sounds cool yeah also
don't hold them to that [__]
yeah you know don't hold me to it
completely just hope for it there you go
optimistically
hopefully [__] one day yeah that's a
lot it's a that's a whole job yeah for
real no no it's crazy
that's community service yeah that
that's how much time you're doing i wish
i could dude i'm gonna be sitting at
community service recording that [__]
you should be tight
that'd be for one attempt for one
a two for one and recording get paid off
and we need your channel [__]
monetized
that's fine
that'd be funny so just cutting through
all the different takes i just sweep it
dude my second channel i don't even know
why they approved my vlog channel for
monetization uh and then all my videos
are age restricted demonetized every
single one they demonetize all of them
at this point you cussing them
hell yeah that's probably why yeah i
mean i don't i don't really try to go
too far out of my way to get monetized
on that channel because it's just like
my experimental like [__] around channel
you know
but i get it but yeah i have the other
channel i just try to keep it completely
clean yeah i feel that i need i need to
do that especially now that susan's on
my [__] nuts about my first channel
it's just another job it's a whole
another like dedication it is dude and i
just hate how youtube is so unstable
like they don't give you a warning like
hey we're going to demonetize you in
this amount of time she's like yo
effective today
[__] you yeah you know and there's a lot
of people like i'm lucky enough to have
sponsorships like i'm okay but there's a
lot of people who that's like their
income like
that's their primary income and like
that could happen to anyone you know
yeah that's [__]
dude that's [__] yeah that's why i
never got paid i was like i gotta do
something else yeah for real you have to
figure something else out you have to
make it like a business you can't rely
on ad revenue no it's not gonna happen
yeah [__] yeah insane like
never pay me yeah any day they'll just
like it from you yeah or your [__]
channel yeah exactly
whack for real youtube is very unstable
uh i don't know what else to do they're
the biggest [__] platform on the
planet yeah exactly hopefully one day
they turn it around some competition
would be nice or some improvements to
youtube but also true is just like 18
and over i get it weed isn't federally
legal whatever but
it's internet culture and they're very
they're not consistent with who's
allowed to smoke weed and who's not yeah
you know that's one thing that just
pisses me i see like so many celebrities
smoking yes
you got snoop dogg seth rogen on there
of course no hate love them but like but
on tick tock grinding a pound yeah
they're all tick tocks smoking giant
joints and [__] but we post that and we
get banned i got banned off tick tock
instantly my videos can take off
i posted one tick tock i got a jar i got
like an ounce and a half of some some
honey from a buddy of mine and i posted
a tick tock while i didn't even say the
word wax or wheat or anything it got
like almost a million loops and like i
got a bunch of followers off it and then
they deleted me
my whole account not just the tick tock
my whole account
i don't even post weed [__] i just say
the words that i'm talking about and
then you're fine and you won't hit
anyone's for you page on no no they take
the video down oh yeah i don't know
i can't even say weed can't say it you
have to spell it different if you're
gonna spell it yeah yeah for real you
have to spell it like with an o
so [__] stupid it's dumb as [__]
[__] annoying
sorry
time
3 20. hey wow
wow we did good wow i didn't think we
would do three hours yeah we we we're
well past three hours actually good [__]
yeah epic first running running on no
food over here yeah yeah yeah yeah
just miller lights
gummy sharks are weak that's a [__]
combo though that's a diet like that's
good that's a diet
you ever met those older ladies that
only smoke steaks and drink pepsi but
don't eat a lot of those at casinos oh
yeah that is exactly you know i've seen
him in the wild yeah in the wild
vegas got me so bad with those [__]
free drinks at the slots man you just
sit there forever you just sit there and
they just keep bringing them to you and
i had one night where i turned 200 bucks
into 1100 and i was oh i know good win
right but so i did this strategy where i
was wasted and i was like when i feel it
i was doing minimum bets and then when i
felt it in my heart and my gullet i
would do a five dollar bet and i kept
hitting the bonus on the five dollar bet
so i was like yo this is it i'm doing
this [__] but
i kept getting really wasted all the
other nights and losing a bunch of money
so it wasn't really profit like the one
night i fell into the elevator i was
telling you about
i i drank like
so i didn't i forgot to close my tab
because i was so drunk i just got up and
laughed
so i had my card though they let me take
my card back but they they already had
my card info so they ran it and i
checked my bank statement the next day i
they ran it for like nine or ten drinks
so like maybe they threw in a few extra
for a tip because my bad i left early
but um
i was like walking back to my room and i
couldn't walk straight and i forgot to
like present my room key because i had a
guy who's like standing by the elevator
and you have to scan your key to like
walk yeah
i just [__] went right past him dude
like i guess i was so like i don't
remember him trying to stop me really i
was so drunk maybe he did i don't know
but i got away who [__] knows all i
know is i made it to the elevator and i
i know i didn't scan my damn keyboard i
didn't pull out [__] out of my pockets
so i got to the elevator and like as i
was i was kind of leaning up like on the
door right i would love to see this in
person and when it opened i just like
fell the [__] in face first and like i
bet my glasses all out of shape kind of
they're like wide now see they're like
wide but yeah they're like wide body
glasses now they're see no they're
[__] actually i i bent them all out of
shape really bad uh because i just face
planted right into the [__] railing
in the elevator
and like i got back up
what was nice though is i had a room on
the top floor because originally i had a
room in like the middle floors but we
opened the drawer and found a bloody
pillowcase ew yeah really you so we
called the front desk and we're like yo
can we get into the room and they put us
on the top
vegas is despicable
yeah yeah
but then they they added the smoking
feed because they caught us smoking a
blind there
that was brutal i get 250. it was 500.
five yeah but the whole lower level's
full of smoke yeah they had so we asked
for a smoking room initially and they're
like well if you're down for a
non-smoking room we'll upgrade you for
free because it's your first time
staying here and i was like [__] yeah
i'll still smoke in there you know uh so
we go there that's where we found the
pillowcase and they put us on the top
floor i smoke in there our privacy light
was on for like two or three days
straight so in vegas they come check on
you for that but we didn't know that at
first you know but they like go around
and check for the rooms you have had
that do not disturbs on for like days
straight so two managers knock at our
door and open the door and we just
smoked a blunt ten minutes prior not
even like we just put this [__] out oh
so yeah they were like oh it smells like
weed no it's like well i never smoked i
don't have any weed and they they just
said they were applying the charge and
like dipped
they were like we can inspect the room
and they were like can we and i closed
the door and i was stuffing weed in my
bag because i told them i was like yeah
let me get dressed first so shirtless i
close the door stuff and weed in my bag
[__] emily and i are packing
everything we can away hiding it they
come in the room they're just like yeah
it stinks in here like we're gonna add a
charge um it was 500 [__] dollars so
i had to smoke more at that point [__]
yeah make it worse
see they shouldn't tell you that until
the end like if they really don't want
you to smoke in there why would you tell
me you're adding that i've only got
kicked out one time of a hotel
i hot boxed it so with charles
we have no tape we hop out really so
severely they kicked us the [__] out of
the hotel and my friend had another
floor in the another room at the floor
below we just went down how many nights
did you have booked my friend had it for
like three nights yeah but what about
the room you got kicked out of same oh
that's still [__] though
i almost got kicked out of when i was on
acid
uh we were smoking uh he wouldn't even
smoke a bunch he was smoking bowls but i
guess someone near us complained
and the security guy came to my room and
he was super cool he was like actually
chill as [__] over there he's like oh is
that some lemon and like i was like oh
like this guy's cool he's like listen
you guys can't like smoke that much in
here like you got to take it outside and
i was like oh for sure and i was
tripping balls dude i was [__] up and
i was like oh yeah for sure you know he
was he was really cool about it like he
like he like thanked us and everything
he was like thank you guys you know i
was like oh thank you dude he's like
that [__] smells good by the way he was
like talking to me he was like i used to
smoke a lot when i was younger i still
smoke sometimes i've got some [__] in my
car and like i'm like oh hell yeah you
know like this dude's [__] awesome
but it scared the [__] out of me because
i thought we about to get booted out
because i'm looking through my people
and i see this dude with a [__]
security badge big ass ball guy and i'm
like oh dude
she looks like steve austin bro i'm so
[__] like
that's what you know what's gonna be
yeah no i was sitting there i was like i
was just i was like [__] i turned around
and i told my friends i was like yeah
get rid of everything
oh my god dude i was [__]
my brain just let things go i had
something i was about to say about you
it happens dude [__] it was right here
it happens
i feel so
dumb now
uh i can't remember
it's all right dude
[__]
there was something about your damn
story i just forgot stone cold steve
austin oh the guy smoked um
no i [__] lost it i lost it i lost it
i'll leave it at that it'll come to you
at some point i'll text you before yeah
yeah i was about to say that's what i
was thinking yeah you'll probably end up
attaching it to me i'd imagine what time
is it 3 30
no what like actual time 3 30 not 10 15.
oh nice that's how you're doing good
yeah we're doing all right that's like
well good time
i think that's everything i got right
now because i feel like every time you
come to l.a just [__] come back
yeah you wanted me to just just come
back i mean i will just keep talking
about i like to come out here dude it's
always a fun time when i'm out here
because the wheat is so [__]
different like when i was smoking that
half gram joint with the tiller earlier
i was stuck off that little thing dude
dude the ice ash rosin out here is so
[__] fire it's crazy every time i'm
out here this like i don't think i've
had bad weed out here
it's it's hard to find super super super
fire right now but good weed is
everywhere yeah the crazy [__] is hard
to find right now yeah really but good
weeds fine i mean when i went to that
dispensary i mean until it did warn me
that it was a pretty expensive one but
when i went there dude they had like
eighty-five dollar eights
oh eighty dollars yeah all branded weed
though yeah backpack boys [__] canatique
antibiotics that kind of [__] yeah all
sorts of super expensive yeah i [__]
with antibiotics yeah they're no they're
fire to the max i really like that dude
that blueberry crawfin [__] i got that i
was telling you about so far
it's fan i don't know i think that might
honestly be in it i'm not sure
don't quote me on that but
all i know is i had a i had a friend who
brought a bunch a bunch of [__] back
from cali he brought like a bunch of
backpack boys um some like blueberry
cruffin some other [__] um it was all
fire but
the main thing that i liked the most was
that blueberry cruffins when i saw that
[__] today i paid 80 and 8 for that [__]
bro
yeah
80 at the dispensary yeah um
without tax so i believe
yes but i i had a first time 25 discount
so
it was okay it wasn't terrible
what's a tax percentage so [__]
excessive 35 or 45
percent
really yeah is that for out-of-state
years only no it's for everybody do they
accept out-of-state med cards here i
don't know
okay you don't need a med card
yeah it's just completely recreational
here no i know but i'm saying if you
have a dude you don't get a tax yes yes
you get a discount if you have a car
yeah yeah yeah like in illinois my car
is a big thing i need to renew mine
still i already paid for it i just
haven't called my doctor yet and got my
[__] renewal yeah i'm gonna have to
do it in a minute
dude [__] um the tax illinois is
about the same for concentrate a grammar
concentrate in illinois is about 95
bucks yeah you told me about this
terrible but even the black market here
the ice ash brothers the [__] yeah
yeah i mean the real crazy [__] out here
is just as tags but i feel like you get
more of a value out here than you do
almost anywhere else you know it's like
buying from a farmer like yeah
like i feel okay about paying 80 for
that eight because i know i'm gonna
[__] love it oh for the wheat yeah i
got you yeah i like i feel totally okay
paying for that [__]
i don't mind you know no i get it i mean
i buy hash that's expensive as [__] yeah
everyone rozzy came out i was like 50
grand you're [__] tripping and i was
like 50 grand you're tripping i didn't
buy that [__] i have a buddy i met
back in illinois who used to be one of
the the head growers for one of the like
like big companies at the dispensaries
in illinois and he got fired because i
guess some from what i was told uh by
the guy he got fired because like
somebody worked with found out he was
making dmd like dmt in his basement
pardon me but um
he got fired for doing some other [__]
too like he was like growing a shitload
of their strains in his house and like
selling them so he got fired and because
he was one of their head growers he had
like contractual rights to the strains
along with them so they can keep growing
them but he had the rights too so he
just started growing that [__] in his
basement and selling it and he started
making his own concentrates too
so i have a buddy who serves me some of
that [__] and the last time i bought
from him i got like an ounce and a half
of just this jar bro this jar full of
straight sauce and i paid like
probably for i got like close to 40
grams and i paid like 500 bucks
what yeah just a jar full of this [__]
it was f i was dabbing on this for so
long dude this [__] lasted me forever
bro i was dabbing on this [__] for like
months because i would still smoke other
[__] it would just be like on a rainy
day like oh let's crack the [__] jar
open yeah yeah that's what i'm saying it
was it wasn't like some crazy like hash
rosin or anything but it was still fire
and it got me sewn that it tasted great
you know that's the only time i really
buy street [__] from that guy other than
that i try to stick to dyspo because in
illinois it's not like out here we can
find that fire like yeah [__] in
illinois it's different like if you want
fire grow your own in illinois it's kind
of i mean it's it's it's legal there now
yeah if you have a medical card it's
legal middle court [__] yeah it's so
easy to get dude my doctor so it's
actually kind of funny um i don't know
if i should say this but when my doctor
called me be cautious he um
he said he asked me he was like what's
your condition again
he like didn't remember my condition oh
yeah a lot of pain
yeah yeah but it was it was pretty
[__] funny it was pretty [__]
funny because i had to remind him
i said yo i can't sleep i told him i
told him what i did for a living and he
was like oh let me save your number i'll
call you um like i need a social media
manager and i was like dude you told me
about that i was like dude if this guy
pays me like enough to do it from home
i'll [__] do it yeah like hell yeah
that'd be so lit like [__] [__] yeah
doctor
i'm on twitter like yo dude hit the dock
you know like [__] yeah probably help
you a lot of people just don't know
where to go for real yeah that's really
what it is and on top of that also it's
like
i feel like i could do that [__] so
easily you know because like i feel like
being in that [__] that's something you
could do so easily for a company just as
a side hustle yeah you know i used to do
this [__] all the time attila was
telling me that today told me you should
do it for raw
yeah i did uh did all their [__]
all the cookie [__] all connected [__]
before they started all that that's fire
yeah we did all of it that's fine yeah
we did all their social media grew
everything that's sick yeah and then
just stopped
one day and just you just decided to
[__] do it on your own no i was
always doing my own [__] this is what i
was doing
you just had to stop doing both one day
and like stick to your own [__] is that
what you're saying no i just stopped
doing it stop working for them one day
separately like i was like i'm done with
this and i'm [__] done with that
that's so much it's a long [__] story
what am i really [__] doing here i
was doing it for free
really raw just to show them i could do
it
and then it just it's a big old jimmy
and josh
we we worked it out so it's [__] dumb
anyway stop working for them and the
cookie [__] they got deleted and just
like we're gonna let we're gonna stop
paying and go okay
the next day it's like
i'm [__] over it that's funny
i'm done that's [__] but this is like
six years ago
you were like early
because cookies and connected you know
connected the brand connected yeah yeah
i've heard of them they were cookies
okay and when they separated they're
like [__] that we're still keeping our
identity we're the c connected with blue
okay that's why they look so similar
yeah because cookies did their own thing
and connected was like no
we're gonna do our own thing too okay so
that's why connected and cookies look so
similar but i used to run
the brand for the owners of connected
that are no longer cookies that's how i
that's how i knew all those dudes nice
but yeah the owner connected uh [__]
luke is one of the funniest people i've
ever met my [__] life
i even said he's like he's like [__]
goblin but like an older man
i mean he's not oh i'm saying he's older
like he's not [__] in his 20s 40 but
yeah he's talking i woke up on the beach
in my ass class and just
i don't know how the [__] i got there
but i was doing [__] drugs all night
but this is like when he was young he
was telling us like one time when i was
a kid
but dude he it might be one of the
funniest people on the [__] planet
shout out to luke he's just
sounds like a fun guy you know what i
mean like it sounds like the [__] i used
to do but like oh you're rich when
you're young so you did [__] like absurd
yeah yeah [__] you talk about he told me
[__] like that but it's like
you
the cops he's like yeah sfpd called me
one time said we found your mercedes
submerged slightly into the in the water
he's like i was at home
oh my [__] car got to the beach i
have no idea did it still run it was
fine it was just like um
shore nice and it was just splashing on
his car but it's like an s am he don't
give a [__]
but this is when he was way younger now
he's like an actual human like yeah now
he functions and yeah he follows him but
he bumps
the [__] he was talking to me like wow
he's the [__] funniest dude ever dude
i love that guy people like that are a
trip dude i love it got any more melee
lights
i think we do
[__] yeah
shout out miller oh yeah here you go
pop that open
and uh so we talked about it
goblin420.com yes and that's you can get
everything yep everything i got right
now okay instagram is did you get it
back no not my old one yet i got deleted
dude
i got deleted uh a new one's gbln420
though gbl and 420 yes that's why i
think i mixed up the [__] website
yeah yeah i i wish i got my old
instagram back so that was so close to
100k man i was at like 85.
they deleted me the other week again too
they're deleting everyone dude they get
eric every other [__] week dude i
always see him
yeah he i don't know how he does it bro
i need him to give me some info dude if
eric sees this please help well i don't
know what he i think he's just doing the
same thing everybody that they just that
method
i mean i'm just saying that it's not
even a method you just hit up support
i have a link and everybody i give the
link to it works dude me i use that
[__] link and it didn't work for me
either they were for me they don't want
me you're on that list i'm on it you're
on that too [__] facebook doesn't
want me bro you're too explicit should i
say meta now they're new
yeah you're too explicit man that's what
it is that's what they do for me it's
it's [__] isn't it yeah it's [__]
but it's okay it feels like most other
other platforms are kind of loosening up
on that except for instagram and
facebook like snapchat i don't get i
don't have any problems i barely get
problems with snapchat yeah like once in
a blue moon and they don't delete you
yeah they leave you alone uh youtube has
gotten even a lot better like they'll
they might demonetize you but they're
not gonna strike you for smoking back in
the day
yeah same here back in the day you could
get strike down just for smoking some
weed
like
there was a period back in 2016 2017
where a lot of weed youtubers i watched
got a bunch of strikes and to take down
their videos i deleted over a hundred of
my old videos during that time yeah
yeah i had to delete like and back then
it was like half of my [__] catalog
dude it was so [__] mad yeah i was
bro i was super pissed because like
i i've gotten to the point where like
now i'm remaking some of those so like
you know going back and like yo
the ogs have seen this but the new heads
haven't um but still i've got so many
like classic [__] videos that like
some of them just you can't remake the
same way you know like some of them are
just they're that [__] banger you
know there's someone wishing you can't
recapture that like
when you made it you had that you don't
know you had it yeah you almost don't
want to
yeah you don't want to interfere with
the original like the 40 gram joint
would love to do it again because that
just a better quality was that the that
big raw challenge cone or did you like
hand roll it
nice big one nice
i would never want to do it again
because that [__] hurt first i feel you
but two like i can't capture that again
on 420 i think i told you about this
when we smoked that joint there was like
three ounces or some [__] yeah that
thing we had to like break it into parts
because it wouldn't smoke it's hard you
have to you have to roll it where you
can still squish it it took us hours to
roll and hours to smoke and even though
it was it was a cone but so we didn't
have to do any rolling but just the
grinding we're sitting there with two
grinders in a garage like brian did all
this [__] weed i had a grinder like
this big though
yeah we didn't know we did not have that
[__] we had two little smoke shop
grinders that were like all sticky and
[__] you know
brutal it almost gets aggravating yeah
smoking yeah we're sitting there
grinding weed forever dude i got a great
hand workout that day dude i probably
accelerated my arthritis for real
i don't have it yet but i'm gonna
everyone in my family has it oh really
yeah yeah man you [__] you be gaming
yeah and i'm gaming all day i'm on the
keyboard mouse i want the controller
yeah i'm [__] our whole generation's
[__] yeah i know i dude i'm on that
[__] all day yeah like i don't get off
that [__] oh you're playing gage all day
yeah dude like when i'm not when i'm not
making videos and [__] i'm on i'm on
there i said this to myself before i got
here like you know i think i'm gonna
play playstation tonight
since i'm not gonna do anything today
it's fun man
what are you gonna play
uh my little brother got me the
spider-man game no that's a good game
that's a good [__] game dude and
mortal kombat both good games
spider-man's fire we might play you have
the ps5 right yeah yeah [__] dude play
spider-man it looks so good yeah i might
play it spider-man's so fire i dude i
started playing [__] skyrim again oh
that is uh really
yeah i always always forget yeah i
always forget you don't game like that
dude i i i gave i've been gaming my
whole [__] life dude like ever since
i was a young kid i had like the
playstation one and like i mean i had
all that [__] i just played yeah yeah
yeah oh [__] yeah dude i love just
driving around and running people over
that's all i ever do
still yeah i get on gta 5. dude some of
my game plays in my videos it's just me
[__] around gta still to this day
since we're talking about gta real quick
uh-huh i will just say it now
i've told you the story
okay we're gonna have a guest come soon
okay
i'm good i'm good
we're talking about gta we're gonna have
franklin gta come on the shows really
yeah that's sick he's a real person yeah
no i've seen like interviews with that
so that's cool he's a cool [__]
man that's dope yeah he's gonna come on
the show this month i think that's so
raw actually this month hope if not it's
gonna be early next year that's that's
[__] speaking of gta like i don't
really get that's the only game does he
smoke like are you gonna are you gonna
like someone controlling it [__]
he's really that dude yeah that's so
dope yeah he's cool that's so dope cool
that's [__] awesome i i'm excited to
see that one it could be dope i could
not go hey and then this one time you
know that part of the game yeah
how do you handle like like how do you
handle interviewing all these [__]
people bro like i just talked to him
like bro i feel like if i'm sitting
across from stevo dude
i'd want to ask that [__] a
million questions you know well if you
want if you i don't know if you watch he
talks a lot so i had like i watched it i
watched some
yo i know i didn't ask you to answer any
of these questions
i just talked a lot it's fine
that was exactly perfect
everything we got was perfect [__] these
questions so that's how i felt about
that
um the only person i like like he knows
like you know if adam sandler i'm like
all right get prepared [__] to
sit up
talk because that's the only person like
[__] these [__] really here huh
you're a big adam chandler guy yeah he's
my favorite guy he's he has some really
good movies he just like them i just
like that [__] he's so funny and
as a kid i just grew up on chris farley
and himself oh yeah for sure so it's
just
you know it's like if jay-z and every
jay-z barney be over here [__]
fake dribbling and [__] just just
getting trying to figure out his brain
it's just those times yeah like rosie's
real quick rosie's favorite person ever
is puff daddy p diddy really did we tell
you about the story uh-huh yeah and
rosie was at the spa which this one in
west hollywood
and there's like always a bunch of
celebrities when they're in there like
they shut off the [__] spa you can't
go nobody else come in yeah but rosie
was already in there she goes there a
lot so rosie is sitting in the [__]
sauna and then she notices all these
people are coming in and they start
kicking people out
and it's [__] p diddy and they kick
everybody out and they're like she can
stay she comes here a lot so it's just
rosie having a conversation with him and
his wife for a [__] hour because he's
trying to be and starting into veganism
and rosie just became vegan back then
so rosie gets to have a whole [__]
hour conversation with this [__]
about nothing it's
when she i couldn't [__] just talk in
the [__] that's her favorite dude she's
like wait that's so sick what did you
just get stuck in a [__] sauna with
and his wife holy [__] that's so sick
pretty cool dude mm-hmm so i don't know
it's pretty [__] awesome i don't
think i've ever had a celebrity
encounter like that well you know like
your favorite person everybody yeah
yeah
but i don't i don't even think i've ever
had a moment where like i was in person
like i recognized someone i guess it's a
celebrity oh you're in [__] illinois
yeah i know but like even you know i
feel like i travel enough like i figured
that would maybe happen at an airport at
some point or something you know
but i know what you're saying yeah you
know but it just hasn't happened to me
yeah i just thought it was really like
your favorite no that's [__] sick
it's like you've read a restaurant like
yo brett favre i've just walked and get
the [__] should i should i chest bump
him or say hey i love you i love you but
i also want to slap the [__] out of you
not for real you know what i'm saying
you you know what i mean i feel you i'm
a bears fan so are you a bears fan oh
yeah yeah
oh i see your hat yeah i noticed that i
forgot i am so
all right i'm gonna say right now i'm
not a current bears fan they're brutal
to watch and have been for years
it's really bad and it has been for a
long time but it's been bad forever yes
since brian or lacquer yes bad yes
exactly but
even back then we couldn't catch a a
ring we couldn't get into this it was
just we went against the patriots with
rex [__] grossman like no [__] we got
destroyed no disrespect to that guy i
think he went to the redskins and
retired or some [__] but
oh my god dude that sucks you're a bear
i mean that sucks that you had to sit
through that no you could say it's
successful my mom's a bears fan and she
we've been sitting through my whole life
just watching the bears no i and other
other stuff watching football other
bears viewers out there are going to
understand for sure it's heartbreaking i
will say it's nice that the bulls are
having their time right now i think we
watch basketball too oh bowls are doing
great right now bulls are very good
right now
which is which is great because i'm not
a big hockey guy and the only other like
i'm not a baseball guy either so like
the cubs blackhawks don't yeah
i can't sit through a whole baseball
game
i can
if i have nothing to do
and i can't go anywhere even then i can
always think of something to do because
my adhd is so off the [__] wall oh i
see what you're saying it's so [__]
boring yes
like even when i'm drunk i almost get
more impatient with it i'm like
yeah yeah yeah for sure well he's a
[__] bills fan he's only had what two
years of his life
okayness
yeah one of them they lost the super
bowl one or two of them i've tried four
of them in a row or since you've been
alive yeah oh god i was like five six
seven eight oh what a terrible
four in a row what a brutal upbringing
there but hold on we just haven't also
got to this usual four years ago i know
but yeah it's [__] normal i didn't
realize it was amazing yet
dude i've been betting on sports a lot
lately man you should use fanduel
sorry that's one of our sponsors i
actually do have a my bookie sponsor oh
by bookie we just yeah do the ad read
for them yeah dude i love those guys bro
my book is great yeah so easy to work
with i love them all right we worked
them last month and we're with fanduel
this month we were just like you know
what
we don't we're not into like betting
i've never done that in my [__] i
love betting so when they hit me up i
was like [__] my friend justin boyd i
told him he goes
i have both of those [__] apps i use
them every [__] day i didn't know you
could win actual money yeah bro yeah
i didn't realize that
people could actually do that oh
absolutely dude it's fun it's
it's fun you got to be responsible it's
slippery slope but it's fun yeah i know
but we're uh well our code gets you into
the chance to win the super bowl i mean
to go to the super bowl really [__]
cool that's sick and i've just recently
learned about the risk-free betting
really yeah that's
dude this shit's complicated until you
actually just sit down and look at and
go oh it's a video game
it's like a video game just pick the
teams you like
it's really interesting i feel like as
people in like the kind of industry we
are we work with the broadest range of
[__] companies you know i think
they're just like who's our demographic
yeah for real like we have a very niche
demographic we are like and you want to
try to advertise to college kids we are
it you know it's funny he just brought
something up about colleges the other
day
about about that yeah like my average
age demographic is like 21 to 24. like
oh really yeah like vast majority and
then the second highest is like
25 to 30.
mine always says like 35 and down really
yeah i get some that are in that range
but like probably solid 70 of mine to
those two age ranges yeah i know i oddly
have like 5 65 and up yeah i have a
little spike at the top too yeah
dude it's really so there's this one guy
so i have like a fan made like subreddit
right they they made it reddit for me uh
and they just post some funny ass [__]
they i don't know how they did this but
they got the reddit goblin like it's
just r goblin it's pretty sick but i
don't like moderator or anything it's
all like fan ran and stuff but there's
this guy on there
who
he like gets [__] he's like a truck
driver i guess and he like all caps post
trying to get me to do pcp like usually
every week like he's like goblin gotta
try pcp don't be a coward like this [__]
is
and i like dude he's my favorite poster
on my subreddit honestly don't be a cat
he is he when i think of my when i think
of my 65 and up demographic i think of
this guy i'm like yo this dude's [__]
great this is [__] great he might
hear this dude while he's like trucking
at some point how you got your [__]
accident for a [__] gta
no dude so
on gta oh man i gotta get back into that
[__] i haven't streamed my gta [__] in a
while i was trying to explain it
tomorrow the other day it's [__]
mind-blowing that people just get in
there do a whole movie no it's crazy
like it's it's free like it really makes
for such an entertaining like watch
because you like so much [__] happens
there's no other game you can stream
there's another game you can stream
where [__] like that happens you know
that's unfucking real yeah actually
arrest [__] yeah like it's real
in real life you go to work it's weird
you go to work you buy a house and [__]
like it's crazy it's weird it's crazy
but you can shoot somebody if you want
yeah you can kill someone but you you
might get caught the detectives might
pull up
crazy they can raid your house bro they
find evidence they can like cops can
rage your house yeah so you have a house
like on these gtrp servers cops can like
get a warrant for you and rate it and
[__]
i like it can you shoot the cops in the
face if you want to yeah but you're just
gonna get more jail time that's fine
yeah there was there was one time i
robbed a bank i used to like
you know rob banks on there with my
friends for fun uh and we got caught and
like you do real jail time like you get
teleported to a jail and you're like in
like you know a jumper and you [__]
like you you serve like dude i got
sentenced for three real hours i was in
that [__] for three hours [__] doing
like push-ups and like i was doing labor
to reduce my sentence i was doing labor
to reduce my sentence i swear to god
like a horrible piece of the game but no
but the thing is it's so fun because
like other people are in there and
they're [__] around too they have
nothing better to do so they're like
forming gangs and [__] and like making
fights on the yard it's so goddamn fun
you're like meeting people there i'm
like yo when i get out i want to buy a
pound of meth and they're like dude
write down my number i got you you know
and like you like take note of their
number get out of jail [__] buy some
tweak like you buy drugs on the gta yeah
bro you can make drugs that's how i made
a lot of money on there
yeah i gotta i gotta get more i gotta
see this no bro you can make drugs on
there and sell them to people i gotta
see this like you're gonna see more of
this i've always seen my whole shtick
was like i was a country dude that
smoked meth so if i ever got meth i'd
use it like i'd always smoke it does it
[__] you up in the game yeah bro it like
affects you
no it's fire it's christ i would like
get really drunk in that drunk drive
like i got a dui oh that shit's crazy
i've done the job yeah it's hard yup yup
you could do it on the servers you go to
the whiskey store you go to the liquor
store and buy whiskey drink that [__] i
i would get drunk and go rob banks and
[__] like drive around
i love this game so much gta is amazing
i love it
it's such like a like a marvel like
there's no other game that would ever be
like gta so it's my favorite game it for
real no yeah and it's it's a very
respectable favorite game like it's so
fire it's so fire my favorite game is
when i played when i was a kid uh it's
the one that came before skyrim it's
called elder scrolls for oblivion i've
heard of elder scrolls before yes i
never got into this [__] i'm telling you
i i grew up playing this game and i
still go back and play it sometimes
and runescape i play hella runescape
i've never played it it's fire yeah my
cousin memphis isn't all this [__] all
these dooms and [__] skyrims yeah
crazy dope [__] but when i'm playing
it's like when he's playing i watch it
like yo this is amazing but i don't want
to do all that no it's so cool dude and
gaming's at the point where everything
looks real it looks real the doom like
doom is [__] insane the point we're
at right now imagine where we're gonna
be at in five more years vr that
oh man vr is getting crazy with the
valve index and all that like the finger
tracing it's getting crazy you're gonna
be able to do all that [__] you see the
one uh they they have this little suit
that it has sensors so it touches you so
if you're getting punched
i haven't seen that but i saw one that
was getting touched i saw one where you
get strapped into this little machine
where it's a circle it's got a treadmill
on the bottom so it tracks
yeah you've seen that
that [__] it's a circle like treadmill
so you can run in anything
it detects all your moves are like
[__] doing army [__] running
sprinting full speed
you're crouching it's like you know
crazy yeah yeah that's what like
technology's at such a crazy point
because i feel like we're the age where
we watch this [__] all happen you know
like honestly i feel like we were born
in a really cool time you know the
coolest of the worst
yeah a little bit of both yeah cool
technologically but pretty terrible in
most other aspects but yeah but we do
have medicines yeah we have medicines
and like
just seeing technology be what it is
like i remember being a kid playing
these games i thought wow these graphics
are incredible being on the nintendo 64
and being like this is it dude yeah this
is it okay this is the [__] one you
know super mario 64. i'm like wow this
is the pinnacle of graphics you
yes and you catch it if if the computer
says yes when i was a kid my family had
the the original nintendo the nes and i
remember i would play mario and duck
hunt on that thing i had a little gun
well i had the gun yeah i still have it
orange in my closet at my house i still
have this thing yeah um i'll never
[__] get rid of it i love this thing
but i used to play mario and duck hunt
on summer vacation uh when i'd be home
from like school and [__] because i'd
have like [__] all else to do so i'd be
playing dude i i could never beat the og
mario when i was like hard it's it is
bro it is so it's crash bandicoot oh
crash bandicoot makes me so angry bro
you can never find all the they recently
remastered it and put it out on
playstation oh yeah me rosie got it yeah
pissed in two [__] days dude i'm
telling you same [__] with me the game
makes me sick aggravated it like oh
double jump up there off the app like
you're ready to throw it yeah
no i'm sitting there talking to my tv
i'm like that's not [__] possible
yeah i'm i'm mad as [__] i'm like oh
jump off the wall oh
nope it's just you're like halfway up a
cliff and you fall and you start at the
beginning but you can't do it it already
took you eight retries to get there
so like you just give up that game has
you ready to throw a controller thank
you i stopped playing it yeah yeah
have it beat it don't have it beat it
even as a [__] adult i can't beat
that [__] no i feel that i'm done you
ever play uh any of the uh nba 2k games
[__] yeah
those are the older those make me the
same way oh the older ones were great
i've watched i haven't played the newer
ones the older ones are good the newer
ones
i i mean i walked in my homies and i
thought that was the [__] to be a
game all the time see i just make like
fun characters at this point i made like
a so i made the shortest possible like
like shooting guard so i can like dunk
but he's five two
so like i still don't know i put yeah i
put all my points in a vertical you can
download the lyrics i dunked on kd like
three times one game dude it was
actually so fun but i go online and i
get clapped bro because it's all these
kids that spend real money on the game
yeah it makes me so mad dude like it
makes you want to throw my goddamn
controller bro cause like i just wanna
be this little like five two
[__] just killing it but
i have to spend money to do that and i'm
not willing to no [__] pisses me off for
all these all these online games are
like that now yeah you gotta spend money
yes dude it makes me so mad like i mean
like
it's like i never get into it so i'm
yeah yeah there's very few games that
can get that kind of money out of me
like where i'll i'll spend more than the
cost of the game i didn't even know that
was possible like two years ago
yeah we can spend money and get upgrades
dude
pretty much every game that comes out
nowadays you could probably spend the
cost of the game just on additions like
add-ons and [__] it's [__] like for
every six dollar game you got another 60
bucks in add-ons to buy yeah that's true
it's [__] like
how the [__] did we get into this
i don't know
we just talked about gains for half an
hour i think nice what time we at about
four
for half an hour that's pretty fire i
like that it's pretty funny i like that
that was pretty good i like this game
that [__]
yeah i mean i don't i i just
it's just how i spend all my time like
free time like
i don't know maybe it's just because i'm
from illinois so there's not as much
[__] to do but like you're not wrong
there's nothing more fun than just
getting baked out of your mind in gaming
you know
i'll try spider-man tonight
yeah try that mortal kombat no
spider-man banks i think you're gonna
like it i'll try it i'll try it it's you
could swing around the whole city it's
like the scale yes
then the graphics are crazy and there's
like hidden items at the top of the
buildings and [__]
oh [__]
see if you can just shoot [__]
that'd be the ultimate game or if you
could swing around a gta no you hey you
could download mods and do that yeah but
i'm talking about the game yeah
so i don't know how to do the
modification [__] i don't know how to do
any of this stuff i just play the
[__] game in madden
yeah that's all i got yeah you're big
into madden aren't you i don't really
play
you used to play it a lot though didn't
you i feel like i feel like i remember
you telling me that was like one of the
only games you really got it's only the
only games i have yeah i probably played
the ps5 twice madden's fun i like madden
a lot yeah it's fun man's a good time i
[__] love it i hate the online modes
now they milked them dude i know you
probably haven't played them but like
yeah they you got to spend a lot of
money to be competitive oh yeah no i
never know i never do that yeah yeah i
play [__] computer i just like to
yeah i just like to play with my friends
and [__] like when i was in high school
we do like madden tournaments and throw
like you know 10 bucks each on them
that sounds funny it's really fun dude
you get like you know five or six people
together you make them all 1v1 throw it
down like a bracket tournament it's fun
so i don't know how to do any of that
i would get lost as [__] and just
facetime all right start no you just
like write it shut up no well i'd be
with my friends like at my house and
shoot oh that's different yeah yeah i've
done that before like we'd all be over
and like you know throw some money on
some madden games in the shade
we just smoke bombs
that would be involved too but i've
never bet money on it that sounds bomb i
mean my friends all like to gamble a lot
like uh back in high school a few of my
friends got this like
they built this like poker table
like they made it like you guys are
bored out there i was just getting into
the game yeah so we used to we used to
like go to my friend's house and go to
his basement play poker at this table
really nice uh and we we'd have like 20
buy-ins and [__] we'd play like all
sorts of different kinds of poker
sometimes blackjack um
so like
i don't know we always bet on [__] like
i just always had no money i just buy
more weed i'd never bet on [__] see i'd
go in with my last twenty dollars hoping
to come out and i mean sometimes i would
yeah sometimes i could sometimes i
couldn't you know i mean it just that's
the way that yeah i mean there was one
time i i was shooting dice with my
friends um and
we were at my friend's mom's house and
so it's kind of funny this this woman my
friend's mom we all learned not to sell
her we cause she'd ask for a front and
not pay you back
you know so like it sucked but we also
had to go to her house but she got
really mean to us when we stopped
selling her weed so we stopped going
over there but we went over there and we
were shooting dice i ended up making
like a hundred bucks damn near and that
was a great day
that's what i was oh i thought there was
gonna go something way crazy no no no no
not that bad no not that bad i was just
talking about gambling no the guy's mom
i don't know [__] her she she owed
everyone money that's wow she owed
everyone money yeah pretty sure she owes
me money
yeah for real and like brought you guys
over on purpose and no yes she would be
an [__] about it too like she'd be
really entitled about it like oh like
give me some weed and [__] and
yeah it would be bad what a loser
hey kids give me your wii
what kids give me your [__] med
get the [__] out of here lady for real
hell no
she's girl she could have gotten medical
medical was around back then [__] no you
just gotta call the right guy you know
are you in high school
oh she's a dick for sure taking high
school for sure it's [__] up for sure
whack yeah marty man we have four hours
damn wow damn it didn't seem like it no
no it really didn't it really didn't
[__] flew by what's the longest
podcast you've done i think four hours
wow i think it's a long we did it yeah
we did it we caught the new year record
got it started the year off [__]
strong wow yeah that's a start good [__]
that was fantastic so before we stop yep
your instagram is gbln420
yes which is twitter uh the goblin with
three n's on the end oh [__] the goblin
yeah t-h-e-g-o-b-l-i-n-n-n
the guy who has like just the act goblin
[__] uses it he like retweets [__]
once a year so i can't get i've dm'd and
i've been like dude i will buy this from
you yeah they have um
i don't know if you're into
cryptocurrency at all but they have like
these these new kind of domains they're
called ens domains and i've been trying
to get goblin.f for the longest time but
the guy won't respond to me
i just have bad luck with trying to get
my accounts
add an extra in [__] it like you did
twitter exactly yeah exactly but exactly
uh youtube is just gobbling yep just
goblin did you twitch
i do yeah which switch uh gbl and 420
same as my instagram okay cool
[__] dude let's call those drinks and
the gummies and nothing yeah no the
miller lights the miller lights have
been getting me gonna drink beer in a
minute so me neither i totally feel like
i haven't drank beer in a hot i could i
could go for like some wings right now
and it's crazy i'm saying that because i
just had a fat bowl of ramen
but the miller's got me ready dude it's
[__] campfire beer i'm telling you
this reminds me just
oh yeah oh yeah no it reminds me of high
school dude being at bonfires
this campfire like my uncle john used to
have this [__] fire pit outside
yeah it just it just reminds me of
[__] fire
my clothes smelling like smoke in the
morning you know what i'm talking about
getting drunk is enhanced when you're
around something on fire
it's just better it's just better it's
the caveman [__] yeah it really is our
like primal instincts just like this is
dope like this this is [__] great
some people have fireballs yeah for real
no i get it for sure i had a friend in
high school that that a
wealthy friend of mine had talked about
she had a fire pit in the backyard so
we'd go over there and like
just like throw logs in that [__] and
light it up
and we go to like the grocery store and
grab like meat and like grill it and
[__] but we'd all be so drunk we just
[__] it up dude we'd burn the [__] out
of it we bought steaks one time everyone
was well done dude no one got a medium
rare you're not getting any pink in that
[__] she went and bought you guys no we
we bought them we bought them in games
no no no we bought we bought the
supplies and stuff like the logs and the
yeah you know like she just had the
facilities for it you know was it a man
was it a maid pit or she bought it
i don't know
when you buy a pit i don't know i don't
know it was it was big but it wasn't
like in ground or anything it was like
you know
she probably bought it probably
she's got money yeah that's awesome yeah
yeah
that's big money [__] right there for
sure
um
god dude i feel like we could do seven
[__] hours if i had more joints yeah
but i dude it's not gonna have those
payrolls no it's it's all good
there's more to come you'll come to l.a
more and i know [__] out there
you know it's been four hours
[__] you guys but also hey just put it
up into two parts yeah i mean you got a
road trip the same [__] you know dude
it's truly the best [__] [__] podcast
is the best for road trips yeah drive
for real drive safe please or flights
that kind of [__] too fly safe all that
true
dude i'd be watching the most random
[__] on planes because i get so damn
anxious yeah you told me yeah i can't do
it i just [__] put my head down i
can't do it on airplanes man i get so
like i literally my knee my legs will be
like shaking the whole time i'll close
my eyes like i try to put in noise
removing earbuds i don't even listen to
nothing bro i just don't want to hear
the plane you know make it worse yeah
because i'm a fucker's loud you know
like why is the engine like that you
know and i make it worse for myself
because before i have flights i look up
plane crash videos like i look up like
info on it because i'm like i want to
know what's going to happen you're going
to do
yeah i want to know what it's like so i
look up like crash reports and then i
tweak myself out and when the plane
makes it noise i'm like oh this is it
you know we're like like when you you
were telling me that story about the
plane de-icing earlier i'm like bro ice
is like the number one cause of crashes
like [__]
like is it it's up there bro yeah a lot
of planes like crash because they didn't
get the ice enough
it's like a it's not common but like in
in terms of plane crashes it's a common
reason for them you know
it's not like a common thing but it's
not like a plane's crashing every day
because of that [__] it's gross yeah
so yeah don't do that man
no i i can't help myself sometimes just
do that you're giving yourself anxiety
but then it helps me calm myself down
it's like watching my videos i'm like
dude no i know what happens if they have
an engine failure that's not happening
so i'm chilling you know you're studying
i see for a while i i got this idea on
my head when i was stoned one day i
wanted to learn like i wanted to learn
how to fly to like conquer the feel like
i want to get a pilot's license i'm like
dude that's so much work like that's so
much that's good that's a lot of money
probably too yeah but a shitload of
money yo could you imagine yourself one
day i'm a commercial fighter yo like
that's that's what i'm thinking like
dude i buy a little two-seater plane i
hit up my homie like yo
i'm about to fly in like what are you on
let's link what are you on i'm about to
fly in i mean as a career he's he's like
oh like what what airline i'm like
goblin my own goblin airlines well you'd
be a commercial pilot my friend got his
pilot license on ecstasy three pills
really my friend he took him we were
taking because they're in class and he's
like today's my last [__] pilot's
test i'm like what the [__] he's a
commercial pilot now really yup i
haven't seen society i don't want to ask
who he flies for i i don't know
yeah i don't know i haven't seen him in
a long time i i dude i don't know if i
could do that for a job though bro i'd
be i don't know if i can handle fun yeah
every cuz those guys go on those shifts
for like weeks at a time bro they just
fly every day yeah like so many times a
day like how do you how do you stay calm
when it's turbulent like that like
you're like oh you're controlling it
yeah i mean i guess so you're like you
know it's it's chilling but still it's
like [__] it's horrible you gotta have
balls of steel for that [__] honestly
it's so sweet up to the pilots yeah [__]
that for real [__] that i can't do that
no i wouldn't i could never do that
shout out milly light honestly manly
dude honestly i would drink a two or
three i feel i feel this is my fourth
i'm feeling great i feel for sure i had
some i had uh some drinks earlier too
you know in the afternoon hotel man i'm
telling you
hotel bar prices here made me feel so
much better compared to vegas it's
obvious oh it's like 25 a drink in vegas
vegas is bad yes and we went to the
gordon ramsay [__] pub
terrible
beef wellington i love gordon ramsay but
we love his content like bro this is
yeah that's what you say i'm like you're
telling me this got him the tv show it's
no shot no way i would like i want to
eat gordon's cooking yeah honestly i we
went like five years ago
yeah
and he has like four [__] restaurants
out there
but how was it okay
yeah best
but i ate duck bacon that was like eight
years ago and it was pretty good
but i don't think i've ever had duck
bacon it was good from what i remember
but nah hell no that was a regular ass
hamburger yeah probably thirty dollars
for that [__] [__] that oh hell no we
paid like it was like ah 65 or 70 a
person for the beef wellington like
course that's not too bad it wasn't
terrible but it was trash like every
part of it was bad there was like
nothing about it i was like oh this is
good you know oh
should i always steal the [__] the man
so they had the mashed potato and like
i'm a big mashed potato guy you know i'm
like if i go to somewhere that serves
like meat or something like that i
expect a good mashed potato with it
[__] they had there tasted like it came
out of a box and i was like no way
was the one on the strip
it was at caesar's palace that's the one
yeah oh that's what we were gonna go
ahead and use the bathroom remember
rosie well yeah he's your bathroom i'm
going to the gordon ramsay's restaurant
how was the restroom i didn't go in and
i was like [__] dad's good you went to
the bathroom didn't you
how was the restroom
[Laughter]
dude i was disappointed um
i just went to vegas like last month
actually as long as you say only two
days man i can't do more
the win
dude we were just there too the wind
yeah the encore yeah it was cool oh
that's the same place it's it's it's
like the same yeah it's like attached oh
okay walk to the wall yeah that's where
we were at yeah they're like connected
yeah it was cool we got a lot of [__]
designer stores in there dude yeah we
[__] smack we went all through it
yeah it's pretty quick i went to a
mirror
i went to amiri uh for my birthday i got
myself a couple pairs of shoes nice yeah
yeah dude that whole strip is i wanted
to come out with something so i was
getting [__] so hard at the tables in
the in the slots and all that i like the
virtual tables that i was like dude
i gotta at least get a pair of shoes or
something something you know yeah like i
gotta come home with something so i had
to buy an extra duffel bag to like bring
my shoes home looks like i didn't have
space in my bag oh [__] yeah oh because
the box
well i didn't bring the box i bought
three pairs
so
i didn't i didn't bring the box but it's
okay i don't plan on reselling them so i
don't care about the box oh no no i'm
just keeping that [__] so i know exactly
yeah i have the bags though like the
little like this one it was baller yeah
they're so nice they have these little
leather straps
straps for your shoes these are
beautiful dude designer shoes are so
wild i know they're really funny i don't
buy much other designer [__] but shoes
yeah everything i love designers
yeah like i saw this button down
everything like it was like 900 and like
it's not that bad i honestly i was
considering buying it but i was like
dude i'm gonna wear this like once a
[__]
like once a year bro i'm like
millionaire what the [__] you might not
have yeah sure for and even then bro i
feel like even if i had that kind of
money like i'd be dumb to buy it i just
buy more weed that's how i feel like i'd
buy a bigger rosin press and just start
[__] smashing [__] yeah dude i don't
care about the shoes different but yeah
yeah shoes are dope i buy a lot of shoes
but
probably more weed i run weed over
[__] everything that's literally my
whole life budget it's just buying yeah
so much of my income just goes straight
to rich every day exactly i like i wake
up and i check my dispensary menu
religiously like what do we have in
store
[__] yeah that must be kind of cool
though at least you know a place that
always has something no it's nice it's i
mean i will say illinois doesn't have
the variety of a lot of other places
like even vegas honestly had more
variety than my my illinois dispensaries
i went to the cookies on the strip in
vegas
they got some dry wheat out there man
really yeah
yeah i mean it's in the desert whatever
but like [__]
dry that sucks like like you could take
a nug and just press your fingers
together and it would just disintegrate
type [__] whack yeah i bought um i think
it was like some um
[Music]
something cake it was like
oh my god i don't know bro some sort of
like no it's like cereal milk it's
expensive i don't know um 60 65 and 8.
that's pretty so pretty up there yeah
but not quite as bad as the [__] i
bought today yeah um
[Music]
but it like was not nearly worth the
price like here i feel like yeah i pay
tax but it's worth it i'm gonna get some
fire but like out there it's not worth
it that sucks yeah i mean maybe i didn't
grab the good [__] obviously i didn't
buy everything on the [__] menu but
the [__] i got was disappointing that
sucks i always bring weed yeah i mean
the thing is i try not to fly with flour
oh you're in a different state yeah i
try not to fly with flowers because i
mean flying yeah flying out of here this
is going to go out by the time i flew
out so i mean i mean flying home yeah
flying out of here is different like lax
i mean they're allowed to fly with a zip
really is that fact yeah
ellie actually allowed to fly out with
nouns so san francisco really
i don't know if you're going oh you're
doing a medical state you're fine
that's like a that's like fact
i i had a dude at lax behind me pull out
his weed he's like nah bro you could
have like a [__] zip and then [__]
this and that of the concentrate yeah
hey fine it's four grams of closure
trades but you do i mean i don't know
do you have to declare it no i don't
think so people do that [__] all right
google it
google it you're fine there's articles
about lax like lax and that's their
website i'm going to the dispensary
again before i leave do it man
google it before we're off just in case
it changed yeah but three years ago they
didn't announce that [__] all the time
wow
zip it under your phone i'm about to
jump for joy yeah you you're fine and
you're about to actually do a little
like heel clap metal medical state man
you'll be all right oh wow you bring
some
how are you doing buddy some shake at
home how are you feeling
are you done
are you ready you ready to wrap this up
bad we're at 421 yeah we have 420 damn
near wow after these [__] ad
reads we will be all right right all
right cool cool
yo we did a very long episode
thank you very much yeah we just went
crazy thank you for having me it was
these i think these guys yeah they're
talking millers gets you loose
the millers get you loose honestly dude
i think that's what it was yeah you know
well when you mentioned beerus i don't
really drink beer anymore i'll maybe
crunch a couple but here i am [__]
four deep i mean dude i usually never
really drink beer and i mean i'm just
surprised to drink
yeah i don't i don't i sometimes i try
to drink beer i tell myself like oh beer
sounds nice but i only end up drinking
like one or two out of the case i bought
you know but
it's the most beer drink in a minute
same i don't drink just drink liquor
yeah but we'll see it's a new year i
don't know
2022 resolution get drunk
[__] yeah dude [__] yeah how you feeling
it's a great start to the yeah you're
busting down drinks over there too
all right all right hell yeah all right
well if
if you leave with anything right now
goblin420.com
yes
right essential key
all the product everything perfect you
still have your mug shot one yes oh yes
yeah that's it's tight yup i got my mug
shot one i've got i've got a lot of new
[__] too uh i when i moved to the new
site i took a lot of my old designs and
like redid them so like pretty much
everything's pretty like new [__] yeah
yeah all right well everybody
goblin420.com
hit it up thank you for being here thank
you for having me man i'm pretty [__]
up yeah i'm feeling fantastic i'm stoned
and i'm really crossed yeah i feel great
i haven't drink beer in so long yeah no
really you're feeling a bit for real
[__] up and drinking beer is so
awkward for real like the taste of beer
yes drew me back yes i feel that
in a good way
absolutely yeah i feel great
thank you so much dude appreciate you
thank you
man goblin on youtube
marty you got anything else
man this was the only proper way to
bring this [__] in we're out of memory
cards by the way oh wow
but that's okay yeah yeah no but this
was dude we've never done that before
let's go bring this year in you know
what i mean this whole new vibes and
[__] also you guys back there
so thank you and sorry
are you guys having to sit here that
long
i'm very very sorry
i could see both of you guys
tired i'm sorry there's so much smoke
over there it's kind of awesome yeah we
smoked this room oh [__] i just see a
haze over the whole building yeah
there's a smog in here yes you guys were
smoking too
that's why
all right well
marty thank you so much appreciate you
oh yeah thank you
thank you
thank you so much for being here of
course thank you for having me guys oh
yeah i definitely feel it
yeah it definitely feels a little you
really feel it when you stand up too
that's what it hits you like a [__] it
was just like i haven't moved my legs
yet yep so i know they're asleep i know
when i get up
i'm gonna be brain blasted when i stand
i can feel it i haven't moved my feet
for four hours there we go i just road
trip to merced without moving my [__]
knees i've been trying to like rotate my
ankles and [__] to like oh no i haven't
done it once i can feel the pressure of
my legs when i just move oh oh hit that
ankle rotation or something man
oh they're so shitty stiff oh yeah
you're in trouble it's okay we'll be out
we'll be all right thank you so much for
being here i know we just said that [__]
but we're [__] up thank you for being
here guys this has been the dope usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between maybe a little k
holes
of course maybe a little synthetic hair
on a little here and there stuff
sprinkling the special stuff a fear of
flying it's fine we both agree flying
sucks dick i hate it but drugs are all
right but don't do them yeah it's a
contradicting show yeah i should say
all right don't do drugs but also
they're fun
yeah
be safe
but don't do it get the fun part through
us yeah there you go yeah you get the
fun part through the bad yeah and the
best you can get the whole spectrum the
whole [__] you guys can see my coke
stories snorting coke with a bloody nose
is just a bad sign it's a red flag
literally and your nose hurts for so
long when you're done oh [__] was cut
with meth
oh
i really hurt all of this behind my eye
you ever snorted molly no has the coke
ever made your eyes water like that
where you're like oh yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah it's the it's the
the worst brutal brutal it's the worst
don't do drugs don't do drugs kids
all right youtube thank you for
demonetizing us i appreciate it i
appreciate it please don't age restrict
us thank you for being here of course
appreciate me thank you guys so much for
watching this has been another episode
of dope as usual podcast have a dope ass
day
i am [__]
perfect
i am [__] high
yeah i'm [__] up
i'm like kind of nervous to stand up
honestly
[Music]
perfect perfect
perfect
[Music]